hello everyone welcome to simply learn's
youtube channel we are stepping into a
new year with new resolutions
resolutions of mastering a new
technology and getting ahead and much
more so we have conducted a survey and
got a list of top trending i.t jobs in
the current iit industry this week we
will help you learn about all those
interesting technologies and get ahead
and be future ready by 2022. on day one
we will be learning about the artificial
intelligence and machine learning
artificial intelligence and machine
learning have been in the industry for
many years but the buzzword started to
skyrocket in the recent years due to the
evolution of business intelligence and
data analytics organizations worldwide
are incorporating artificial
intelligence and machine learning to
automate their operations and elevate
productivity
recent surveys prove the technology's
potential in the future and also finds a
huge demand for the professionals with
the knowledge of ai and ml
in today's session our real-time
industry experts will take you through
the end-to-end ai and ml tutorial with
real-time examples for better
understanding so without further ado
over to our experts
so we'll start off by learning the
basics of ai and machine learning from
short animated videos
then we will understand the different
supervised and unsupervised learning
algorithms such as linear regression
logistic regression decision trees svm
knn as well as k-means clustering
then we will shift our focus towards
learning deep learning where we will
look at what is deep learning and how
neural networks work
we will also cover two important deep
learning frameworks tensorflow and keras
finally we will understand about
generative adversarial network and
recurrent neural networks so let's get
started
picture this a machine that could
organize your cupboard just as you like
it or serve every member of the house a
customized cup of coffee makes your day
easier doesn't it these are the products
of artificial intelligence but why use
the term artificial intelligence well
these machines are artificially
incorporated with human-like
intelligence to perform tasks as we do
this intelligence is built using complex
algorithms and mathematical functions
but ai may not be as obvious as in the
previous examples in fact ai is used in
smartphones cars social media feeds
video games banking surveillance and
many other aspects of our daily life the
real question is what does an ai do at
its core here is a robot we built in our
lab which is now dropped onto a field in
spite of a variation in lighting
landscape and dimensions of the field
the ai robot must perform as expected
this ability to react appropriately to a
new situation is called generalized
learning the robot is now at a crossroad
one that is paved and the other rocky
the robot must determine which path to
take based on the circumstances this
portrays the robot's reasoning ability
after a short stroll the robot now
encounters a stream that it cannot swim
across using the plank provided as an
input the robot is able to cross this
stream so our robot uses the given input
and finds the solution for a problem
this is problem solving these three
capabilities make the robot artificially
intelligent in short ai provides
machines with the capability to adapt
reason and provide solutions
well now that we know what ai is let's
have a look at the two broad categories
in ais classified into
weak ai also called narrow ai focuses
solely on one task
for example alphago is a maestro of the
game go but you can't expect it to be
even remotely good at chess
this makes alphago a weak ai
you might say alexa is definitely not a
weak ai since it can perform multiple
tasks well that's not really true when
you ask alexa to play despacito it picks
up the keywords play and despacito
and runs a program and is trained to
alexa cannot respond to a question it
isn't trained to answer for instance try
asking alexa the status of traffic from
work to home
alexa cannot provide you this
information as she is not trained to
and that brings us to our second
category of ai strong ai
now this is much like the robots that
only exist in fiction as of now
ultron from avengers is an ideal example
of a strong ai
that's because it's self-aware and
eventually even develops emotions
this makes the ai's response
unpredictable
you must be wondering well how is
artificial intelligence different from
machine learning and deep learning
we saw what ai is machine learning is a
technique to achieve ai and deep
learning in turn is a subset of machine
learning
machine learning provides a machine with
the capability to learn from data and
experience through algorithms
deep learning does this learning through
ways inspired by the human brain this
means through deep learning data and
patterns can be better perceived ray
kurzweil a well-known futurist predicts
that by the year 2045 we would have
robots as smart as humans
this is called the point of singularity
well that's not all
in fact elon musk predicts that the
human mind and body will be enhanced by
ai implants which would make us partly
cyborgs
so here's a question for you which of
the below ai projects don't exist yet a
an ai robot with citizenship
b a robot with a muscular skeletal
system
c ai that can read its owner's emotions
d ai that develops emotions over time
give it a thought and leave your answers
in the comment section below since the
human brain is still a mystery it's no
surprise that ai2 has a lot of
unventured domains
for now ai is built to work with humans
and make our tasks easier
however with the maturation of
technology we can only wait and watch
what the future of ai holds for us
well that is artificial intelligence for
you in short
we know humans learn from their past
experiences
and machines follow instructions given
by humans
but what if humans can train the
machines to learn from their past data
and do what humans can do and much
faster well that's called machine
learning but it's a lot more than just
learning it's also about understanding
and reasoning so today we will learn
about the basics of machine learning
so that's paul he loves listening to new
songs
he either likes them or dislikes them
paul decides this on the basis of the
song's tempo
genre
intensity and the gender of voice for
simplicity let's just use tempo and
intensity for now so here tempo is on
the x-axis ranging from relaxed to fast
whereas intensity is on the y-axis
ranging from light to soaring we see
that paul likes the song with fast tempo
and soaring intensity while he dislikes
the song with relaxed tempo and light
intensity so now we know paul's choices
let's say paul listens to a new song
let's name it as song a song a has fast
tempo and a soaring intensity so it lies
somewhere here looking at the data can
you guess whether paul will like the
song or not correct so paul likes this
song by looking at paul's past choices
we were able to classify the unknown
song very easily right let's say now
paul listens to a new song let's label
it as song p so song b
lies somewhere here with medium tempo
and medium intensity neither relaxed nor
fast neither light nor soaring now can
you guess whether paul likes it or not
not able to guess whether paul will like
it or dislike it are the choices unclear
correct we could easily classify song a
but when the choice became complicated
as in the case of song b yes and that's
where machine learning comes in let's
see how in the same example for song b
if you draw a circle around the song b
we see that there are four votes for
like whereas one would for dislike if we
go for the majority votes we can say
that paul will definitely like the song
that's all this was a basic machine
learning algorithm also it's called k
nearest neighbors so this is just a
small example in one of the many machine
learning algorithms quite easy right
believe me it is but what happens when
the choices become complicated as in the
case of song b that's when machine
learning comes in it learns the data
builds the prediction model and when the
new data point comes in it can easily
predict for it more the data better the
model higher will be the accuracy there
are many ways in which the machine
learns it could be either supervised
learning unsupervised learning or
reinforcement learning let's first
quickly understand supervised learning
suppose your friend gives you one
million coins of three different
currencies say one rupee one euro and
one dirham each coin has different
weights for example a coin of one rupee
weighs three grams one euro weighs seven
grams and one dirham weighs four grams
your model will predict the currency of
the coin here your weight becomes the
feature of coins while currency becomes
the label when you feed this data to the
machine learning model it learns which
feature is associated with which label
for example it will learn that if a coin
is of 3 grams it will be a 1 rupee coin
let's give a new coin to the machine on
the basis of the weight of the new coin
your model will predict the currency
hence supervised learning uses labeled
data to train the model here the machine
knew the features of the object and also
the labels associated with those
features on this note let's move to
unsupervised learning and see the
difference suppose you have cricket data
set of various players with their
respective scores and wickets taken when
you feed this data set to the machine
the machine identifies the pattern of
player performance so it plots this data
with the respective wickets on the
x-axis while runs on the y-axis while
looking at the data you will clearly see
that there are two clusters the one
cluster are the players whose code
higher runs and took less wickets while
the other cluster is of the players who
scored less runs but took many wickets
so here we interpret these two clusters
as batsmen and bowlers the important
point to note here is that there were no
labels of batsmen and bowlers hence the
learning with unlabeled data is
unsupervised learning so we saw
supervised learning where the data was
labeled and the unsupervised learning
where the data was unlabeled and then
there is reinforcement learning which is
a reward based learning or we can say
that it works on the principle of
feedback here let's say you provide the
system with an image of a dog and ask it
to identify it the system identifies it
as a cat so you give a negative feedback
to the machine saying that it's a dog's
image the machine will learn from the
feedback and finally if it comes across
any other image of a dog it will be able
to classify it correctly that is
reinforcement learning to generalize
machine learning model let's see a
flowchart input is given to a machine
learning model which then gives the
output according to the algorithm
applied if it's right we take the output
as a final result else we provide
feedback to the training model and ask
it to predict until it learns i hope
you've understood supervised and
unsupervised learning so let's have a
quick quiz you have to determine whether
the given scenarios uses supervised or
unsupervised learning simple right
scenario one facebook recognizes your
friend in a picture from an album of
tagged photographs
scenario 2 netflix recommends new movies
based on someone's past movie choices
scenario 3 analyzing bank data for
suspicious transactions and flagging the
fraud transactions think wisely and
comment below your answers moving on
don't you sometimes wonder how is
machine learning possible in today's era
well that's because today we have
humongous data available everybody is
online either making a transaction or
just surfing the internet and that's
generating a huge amount of data every
minute and that data my friend is the
key to analysis also the memory handling
capabilities of computers have largely
increased which helps them to process
such huge amount of data at hand without
any delay and yes computers now have
great computational powers so there are
a lot of applications of machine
learning out there to name a few machine
learning is used in healthcare where
diagnostics are predicted for doctor's
review the sentiment analysis that the
tech giants are doing on social media is
another interesting application of
machine learning fraud detection in the
finance sector and also to predict
customer churn in the e-commerce sector
while booking a gap you must have
encountered surge pricing often where it
says the fair of your trip has been
updated continue booking yes please i'm
getting late for office
well that's an interesting machine
learning model which is used by global
taxi giant uber and others where they
have differential pricing in real time
based on demand the number of cars
available bad weather rush r etc so they
use the search pricing model to ensure
that those who need a cab can get one
also it uses predictive modeling to
predict where the demand will be high
with the goal that drivers can take care
of the demand and search pricing can be
minimized great hey siri can you remind
me to book a cab at 6 00 pm today okay
i'll remind you thanks no problem
comment below some interesting everyday
examples around you where machines are
learning and doing amazing jobs so
that's all for machine learning basics
today from my site welcome to artificial
intelligence tutorial what's in it for
you today what is artificial
intelligence so we'll start with a
general concept types of artificial
intelligence covering the four main
areas ways of achieving artificial
intelligence and some general
applications of artificial intelligence
in today's world finally we'll dive into
a use case predicting if a person has
diabetes or not and we'll be using
tensorflow for that in the python
environment what is artificial
intelligence and today's world is
probably one of the most exciting
advancements that we're in the middle of
experiencing as humans so what is
artificial intelligence and here we have
a robot with nice little clampy hands
hey what am i you are what we call
artificial intelligence i am your
creator reminding him who programmed him
and who he's supposed to take care of
artificial intelligence is a branch of
computer science dedicated to creating
intelligent machines that work and react
like humans in today's place where we're
at with artificial intelligence i really
want to highlight the fact that they
work and react like humans because that
is where the development of artificial
intelligence is and that's what we're
comparing it to is how it looks like
next to a human thanks any tasks you
want me to do for you get me a cup of
coffee poof here you go he brings him a
cup of coffee that's my kind of robot i
love my coffee in the morning you'll see
there's kind of a side theme of coffee
today's uh tutorial so here we have a
robot that's able to bring him a cup of
coffee seems pretty far out there you
know that we have a walking robot that's
doing this but it's not as far out there
as you think we have automatic coffee
pots we have devices that can move an
object from one point to the other you
know anything from amazon delivering
packages or whatever you want all these
things are in today's world we're right
on the edge of all this that's what
makes this so exciting such an exciting
topic and a place of study so let's take
a look a real general look at types of
artificial intelligence in the really
big picture i mean we drill into it
there's like machine learning and all
kinds of different aspects but just a
generic level of artificial intelligence
so hi there discovered four different
types come have a look so we have our
kind of einstein looking guy or
professor at some college so the very
first part that we're really this is uh
i reactive machines they've been around
a long time this kind of ai are purely
reactive and do not hold the ability to
form memories or use past experiences to
make decisions these machines are
designed to do specific jobs remember i
talked about the programmable coffee
maker that makes coffee in the morning
it doesn't remember yesterday from
tomorrow it runs its program even to our
washing machines they have automatic
load balancers that have been around for
decades so reactive machines we program
to do certain tasks and they have no
memory but they're very functional then
we have limited memory this is kind of
right where we're at right now this kind
of ai uses past experience and the
present data to make a decision
self-driving cars are kind of limited
memory ai we bring up self-driving cars
because that's a big thing especially in
today's market they have all these
images that they brought in and videos
of what's gone on before and they use
that to teach the automatic car what to
do so it's based on a limited memory
limited memory means it's not evolving
new ideas they have to actually when
they need to make a change they have the
programming built on the memory but then
they have to make those changes outside
of that and then put the new setup in
there so it's continually reprogramming
itself theory of mind these ai machines
can socialize and understand human
emotions machines with such abilities
are yet to be developed of course that's
under debate there's a lot of places
that are working on the theory of mind
and having it be able to cognitively
understand somebody based on the
environment their
facial features all kinds of things and
evolve with them so their own they have
some kind of reflective ability to
evolve with that and finally
self-awareness this is the future of ai
these machines will be super intelligent
sentient and conscious so they'll be
able to react very much like a human
being although they'll have their own
flavor i'm sure achieving artificial
intelligence so how in today's world
right now are we going to achieve
artificial intelligence well the main
arena right now is machine learning
machine learning provides artificial
intelligence with the ability to learn
this is achieved by using algorithms to
discover patterns and generate insights
from the data they are exposed to and
here we have a computer as we get more
and more to the human realm of art and
official intelligence you see this guy
splits in two and he's inside his hidden
networks and machine learning programs
deep learning which is a subcategory of
machine learning deep learning provides
artificial intelligence the ability to
mimic a human brain's neural network it
can make sense of patterns noise and
sources of confusion in the data let's
try to segregate different kinds of
photos using deep learning so first we
have our pile of photographs much more
organized than my boxes in my closet of
photographs the machine goes through the
features of every photo to distinguish
them this is called feature extraction
bingo figures out the different features
in the photos and so based on those
different features labels of photos it
says these are landscapes these are
portraits these are others so it
separates them in there if you've ever
been on google photos i'm a favorite of
mine i go through there and i type in
dog and i get all the images of my dog
it's pretty amazing how it's able to
pull those features out so when we're
achieving artificial intelligence and
the deep learning let's take a closer
look and see just how deep learning
works there are a lot of models out
there this is the most basic model used
this is a neural network there are three
main layers in a neural network the
photos that we want to segregate go into
the input layer and so we have a picture
of mona lisa it looks like and a couple
of people when it goes into the first
input layer the arrows are drawn to like
individual dots each one of those white
dots in the yellow layer or in the input
layer would be a pixel in the picture
maybe a value for that pixel so the
picture of the mountains goes in there
and it fills in that whole input layer
and then the next picture of the
nightscape goes in there the hidden
layers are responsible for all the
mathematical computations or feature
extraction on our inputs so when you see
here we have the two uh kind of orangish
red layers here and there's all these
lines in there those lines are the
weights each one of those represents a
usually a float number or a decimal
number and then it multiplies it by the
value in the input layer and you'll see
that as it adds all these up in the
hidden layer each one of those dots in
the hidden layer then has a value based
on the sum of the weights and then it
takes those and puts it into another
hidden layer and you might ask well why
do we have multiple hidden layers well
the hidden layers function as different
alternatives to some degree so the more
hidden layers you have the more complex
the data that goes in and what can they
can produce coming out the accuracy of
the predicted output generally depends
on the number of hidden layers we have
so there we go the accuracy is based on
how many hidden layers we have and again
it has to do with how complex the data
is going in the output layer gives us
the segregated photos so once it adds up
all these weights and you'll see there's
weights also going into the output layer
based on those weights it'll say yes
it's a portrait no it's a portrait yes
it's a landscape no it's a landscape and
that's how we get our setup in there so
now we were able to label our photos
let's take a look and see what that
looks like in another domain we have
photograph domain now let's look at it
in the airline ticket so let's predict
the airline ticket prices using machine
learning these are the factors based on
which we're going to make the
predictions and choosing your factors is
so important but for right here we'll
just go ahead and take a look what we
got we have airlines we have the origin
airport the destination airport the
departure date here are some historical
data of ticket prices to train the
machine so we pull in the old data this
is what's happened over the years now
that our machine is trained let's give
it new data for which it'll predict the
prices and you remember from our four
different kinds of machines we have
machines with memory well this is the
memory part it remembers all the old
data and then it compares what you put
in to produce the new data to predict
the new prices the price is 1 000 that's
an expensive flight of course if that is
uh us dollars if it's india i don't know
what the price range is on that
hopefully it's a good deal for wherever
you're going so we predict the prices
and this is kind of nice because if
you're looking way ahead it'd be nice to
know if you're planning a trip for next
year how much those tickets are going to
cost and they certainly fluctuate a lot
so let's take a look at the applications
of artificial intelligence
we're going to dive just a little deeper
because we talked about photos we've
talked about airline ticket prices kind
of very specific you get one specific
number but let's look at some more
things that are probably more in-home
more common right now speaking of in
home this young gentleman is entering
his room of course makes a comment like
we all do we walk into a room this room
is dark isn't it let's see what happens
when i enter it the sensors in my room
detect my presence and switch on the
lights this is an example of non-memory
machines okay you know it senses you it
doesn't have a memory whether you've
gone in or not some of the new models
start running a prediction as to whether
you're in the room or not when you show
up when you don't so they turn things on
before you come down the stairs in the
morning especially if you're trying to
save energy might have one of those
fancy thermostats which starts guessing
when you get up in the morning so it
doesn't start the heater until it knows
you're gonna get up so here he comes in
here and this is one of the examples of
smart machine and that is one of the
many applications of artificial
intelligence one of the things we're
developing here in our homes okay bye
abruptly he leaves leaving his nice
steaming cup of coffee there on the
table and when he leaves the sensors
detect he's gone and turn off the lights
let's watch some tv did someone say tv
the sound sensors on the tv detect my
voice and turn on the tv sounds kind of
strange but with the google dongle and a
google home mini you can actually do
just that you can ask it to play a movie
downstairs on your downstairs tv true
also with the amazon fire stick and all
the different artificial intelligent
home appliances that are coming out
pretty amazing time to be alive and in
this industry here you have one more
application of artificial intelligence
and you can probably think of dozens of
others that are right now on the cutting
edge of development so let's jump into
my favorite part which is a use case
predict if a person has diabetes and in
the medical domain i mean if you read
any of these they say predictive a
person has diabetes but in the medical
domain we would want to restate this as
what is the risk is a person a high risk
of diabetes should just be something on
their radar to be looking out for and
we'll be helping out with the use case
there we are with a cup of coffee again
i forgot to shave as you can see we'll
start with the problem statement the
problem statement is to predict if a
person has diabetes or not and we might
start with this prediction statement but
if you were actually using this in real
case again you would say your high risk
of diabetes would be the proper way to
present that to somebody if you ran
their test data through here but that's
very domain specific which is outside of
the problem statement as far as the
computer programmers involved so we have
a look at the features these are the
things that have been recorded and they
already have this data from the
hospitals one of them would be number of
times pregnant obviously if you're a guy
that'd be zero glucose concentration so
these are people who've had their
glucose measured blood pressure age age
is a big factor an easy thing to look at
insulin level so if someone's on insulin
they probably have diabetes otherwise
they wouldn't be taking insulin but that
would affect everything else and we add
that in there if they're if they're
using insulin let's start off with the
code so we're going to start off by
importing parts of our data set and if
we're going to do this let's jump into
one of our favorite tools we're going to
use the anaconda jupiter notebook so let
me flip over there and we'll talk just
briefly about that and then we'll look
over this code so here we are in the
jupiter notebook and this is an inline
editor which is just really cool for
messing with python on the fly you can
do demos in it it's very visual you can
add pieces of code it has cells so you
can run each cell individually you can
delete them but you can tell the cell to
be a comment so that instead of running
it it just skips over it there's all
kinds of cool things you can do with
jupiter notebook we're not going to go
into that we're actually going to go
with the tensorflow and you do have to
import all the different modules in your
python now if you're in a different
python ide that's fine it'll work in
just about any of your python ides and
i'll point out the one difference in
code when we get to that which is the
inline for doing our graph and in this
code we're going to go through we're
going to load our data up we're going to
explore it we're going to label it and
then we'll use the tensorflow and then
we'll get down to the end where we're
going to take a look at how good the
model is does it work so let's start
with the top part here and let me go
ahead and let's paste that code in there
i've added a line in at the top i've
added the folder because i didn't put it
in the same folder as the
program that's running you don't need to
worry too much about that but if you
have a folder issue or says file doesn't
exist you probably have it in the wrong
folder or you need to add the folder
path and then we're going to import
pandas and let me just one of the cool
things since it's in internet chrome we
can just do that control plus and zoom
right in there and we have the import
pandas as pd so go ahead and draw a line
up there you can see that the pandas as
pd add a little drawing thing in there
to make it easier to see pandas is a
data set it's a really nice package you
can add into your python usually it's
done as pandas as pd that's very common
to see the pd here let's circle that
it's basically like an excel spreadsheet
it adds columns it adds some headers it
adds a lot of functionality to look at
your data and the first thing we're
going to do with that is we're going to
come down here and we're going to read
and this is a csv it's a csv file you
can open up the file on your computer if
you want if you need access to the file
you can either search it and download it
from the main thing or type a note in
down below on the youtube video and
simply learn will help you get that file
also and that's true of any questions
you have on this you can add comments
down there and somebody at simplylearn
actually keeps an eye on that and we'll
try to answer those questions for you i
put in the full path you don't have to
if you have your data files saved in the
same folder you're running your program
in and this is just a csv file comma
separated variables and with the pandas
we can read it in there and we're going
to give it put it right in a variable
called diabetes and then finally we take
diabetes and you'll see diabetes.head
this is a pandas command and it's really
nice because it just displays the data
for us let me go ahead and erase that
and so we go up to the run button up
here in our jupyter notebook which runs
the script in this that's a cell we're
in and you can see with the
diabetes.head since it's a panda's data
frame it prints everything out nice and
neat for us and this is really great and
if i go ahead and do a control minus i
can get it all to fit on the same screen
and this is the first five lines when
you do the head of the data just prints
out the first five lines in programming
of course we start with zero so we have
zero one two three and four there we go
we have yeah here we go we start with
zero we have zero one two three and four
we have our titles going across the top
and of course the first column is number
of pregnancies glucose concentration for
the second one blood pressure
measurements of triceps as we keep going
you'll see you can guess what most of
these things are group i'm not sure this
is probably the test group i didn't look
it up to see specifically what that is
anytime you start exploring data and for
this example we don't really need to get
too much in detail you want to know the
domain what does this information mean
are we duplicating information going in
that's beyond the scope of this for
right now though we're just going to
look at this data and we're going to
take apart the different pieces of this
data so let's jump in there and take a
look at what the next set of code is so
in our next setup or our next step we
got to start looking at cleaning the
data we got to start looking at these
different columns and how are we going
to bring them in which columns are what
i'm going to jump ahead a little bit and
also as we look at the columns we're
going to do our import our tensorflow as
tf that's a common import that's our
tensorflow model tensorflow was
developed by google and then they put it
into open source so that it's free for
everybody to use which is always a nice
thing so let's take a look at what these
two steps look like in our jupyter
notebook so let's paste this code in
here and
this is something that happens when
you're messing with data is you'll
repeat yourself numerous times we
already have diabetes head so i'm going
to put the little pound sign which tells
python that this is just going to be a
comment we're not going to run it a
second time in here we have diabetes dot
columns and then diabetes columns to
norm equals diabetes columns to
norm.apply lambda x let's talk about
that but let me first run that and let's
see what that comes out with that and
then
let's put the next set of code in also
and i'm going to run that let me just
hit the run button it doesn't really
have an output but we did a lot of stuff
here so let's go over what we did on
this so i've turned on my drawing
implement to help go through all this
there's a lot going on here the first
thing is we have all of our columns up
here all of our column names let me just
highlight that and draw a circle around
that like we did earlier and we want to
look at just specific columns and we're
going to start let me change the color
on this so it really sticks out i'll use
like a blue i'm going to look at these
columns and we're not going to do age
class or group we're going to look at
those in a different way and i'll
explain in a little bit what that's
about so we're looking at number of
pregnancies
uh glu basically anything that can be
read as a float number and you might say
age could be read as a float number
we're going to address that differently
because when you're doing statistics we
usually take the ages and we group them
into buckets and we'll talk about that
and so we're going to take these columns
and we're going to do what they call
normalize them call them to normalize
what is normalize if you're using the sk
learn module one of their neural
networks they call it scaling or scalar
this is in all of these neural networks
what happens is if i have two pieces of
data and let's say
one of them is in this case zero to six
and one of them is in insulin level is
zero to maybe point two would be a very
high level i don't know what they
actually go to a neural network we'll
look at this six and it'll go 0 to 6 and
as you get into 0 6 here's an 8 even a
higher number it will weight those
heavier and so it'll skew the results
based more on the number of pregnancies
than based on the insulin or based on
the blood pressure so we want to level
the playing field we want these values
to all be in the same area we do that by
normalizing it here and we use a lambda
function this is always a kind of a fun
thing we take the diabetes it's a panda
set up and let me just erase all that so
we can go down here put it back to red
and we take our diabetes which is a
panda data set and we only want to look
at the columns to normalize because
that's what we built we built a list of
those columns and we're going to apply
a lambda function and you'll see lambda
and all kinds of python programming it
just means it's a function we put x in
and whatever is outside of the x over
here it then takes that and returns that
value so the new value is going to be
whatever x is minus x min again it's a
pandas data set so we can get by with
that which is really cool makes it easy
to read so we take x we look for the
minimum value of x and then we divide
that by the maximum value x minus the x
min or the width and what this
essentially does is if you're going from
to 15
it's going to divide by 15 and then we
subtract it let's make this 2 instead of
zero or 20 uh 20 to 115 there we go
first off we set this to zero so we
subtract x min so right off the bat the
minimal value is going to be zero and
then we divide it by the difference here
x min minus x max or x max minus x min
this basically sets all the values
between 0 to 1. and that's very
important if we want to make sure that
it's not going to be a skew in the
results if it's not going to weight the
values one direction or the other zero
to one that's what this is doing and
again there's like so many different
ways to scale our data this is the most
basic scale it's standard scaling and
it's the most common and we spelled it
out in the lambda you can there's actual
um modules that do that but lambda is
just such an easy thing to do and you
can see really see what we're doing here
so now we've taken these columns we've
scaled them all and changed them to a
zero to one value we now need to let the
program know the tensorflow model that
we're going to create we need to let it
know what these things are so to do that
i create a variable called number
pregnancy keep it simple and we've
imported the tensorflow as tf one line
of code brings our tensorflow in for us
awesome love python so you get number of
pregnancies and tf.feature
column.numeric column we're going to
tell it's a numeric column so it knows
that this is a float value zero to one
and then number underscore pregnant so
we're taking that column and we've
reshaped that column from zero to one
and no that doesn't mean you have a 0.1
pregnancy it just means 0.1 equals 1 or
something number pregnant so we're just
mapping this data so tensorflow knows
what to do with it and we go through all
of these we go through all the way up to
again we're not doing age let me just
separate h down here these have all been
adjusted age we're going to handle
differently we still put it as a
numerical column because it is so let me
just circle age and group we didn't even
touch group yet we're going to look at
group and age and we're going to do some
special stuff with that class we're
going to look at last why because this
is whether they have diabetes or not
that's what we're testing for so this is
our history we know these people have
diabetes or not and we want to find out
we want to create a model and then we
want to test that model predicting
whether somebody new has diabetes or not
so here i am still with my cup of coffee
working away refill number three let's
explore both the categorical group which
is going to be the a b c and d on the
end and also the age we're going to talk
about those a little bit more and then
we're going to combine all those
features and we'll jump into splitting
the data although that's kind of the
next step but we'll put that all
together what are we doing with the age
and what are we doing with the group
down there so let's flip on over and
take a look at our jupiter notebook so
the first thing is let's put this new
set of code in here and run it and let's
talk about what we're doing on this set
of code in um i actually want to go one
more step forward on the next set of
code or part of it there we go and i can
go and just run that while we have it
that's fine let's just scroll up a
little bit here and let's go through
what we just did with this set of code
if we go back up here to the top part we
have group b c b b c we learned from the
header so when i come down here we're
going to create a signed group and let
me get my drawing pad out so we're
looking at this first one up here
assigned group tf feature column
categorical column with vocabulary list
that is a mouthful this is saying that
this is a categorical list in this case
we have a b c d you see this a lot in
tensorflow a lot of times tensorflow is
used to analyze text or logs error logs
and they're just full of all this
information and they take these in this
case a b c d but in other cases it'd be
words and they create numbers out of
them so it has zero this is one column
this is another column this is another
column this is another column and it's
just this way of being able to look at
this in a different light and assigning
them different values you really don't
want to assign this a float value first
thought might be let's assign this 0 to
3 0 1 2 3 for a b c d but if you did
that it would try to add 1 plus 2 to get
3 as part of its math and functions and
that just isn't true c does not equal a
plus b c is just a categorical name it
could have been the frank group and
laura's group in a bids group but it's
not you know these are they're not float
numbers so very important you have that
distinction in your data the next step
we're looking at is our map plot and
we're going to do this this is a cool
useful tool we're going to import map
plot library dot pi plot as plt that's
standard import and this next line here
is really important we're doing the map
plot library we want it to be inline
that's because we're in a jupyter
notebook remember i told you before that
if you're running this in a different
ide you might get a different result
this is the line you need if you want to
see the graph on this page and then we
do diabetes we're going to look at just
the age and dot hist bins equals 20.
what the heck is that well it turns out
that because this is remember it's a
pandas there's our pd pandas as pd
because this is a pandas panda
automatically knows to look for the
matplot library and a hist just means
it's going to be a histogram and we're
going to separate it into 20 bins and
that's what this graph is here so when i
take the diabetes and i do a histogram
of it it produces this really nice graph
we can see that at 22 most of the
participants in this probably around
174 of the people that were
recorded were of this age bracket
they're right here in this this first
column here and as they get further and
further down they have less and less and
less until when you're at 80 you can
actually see down here there's almost
none in a couple of these categories and
this is important to know because when
you're doing census you know the older
the the group is the more the people
have passed away so you're going to have
this in any of your senses as you take
you're always going to have a much
larger group in the younger crowd and
then it gets lower and lower as they get
older and i mentioned the word buckets
here we go we're going to create an age
bucket we're going to put people in
buckets can you imagine people sitting
in buckets kind of a funny way of
looking at it this just makes it easier
for us to separate it when i go to the
doctor's office i don't want to be told
well your age 22 this is you know you'll
get a decent one at 22.
here we are back to my cup of coffee i
told you coffee was an underlying theme
these next couple steps are very
specific to tensorflow up until now we
had some tensorflow as we set the
categories up but you'd have to set that
up with any model you use to make sure
they're set correctly they'd be set up a
little differently but we run input
functions and in tensorflow this allows
for some really cool things to happen
and this is why tensorflow is so
predominant in a lot of areas so let's
take a look at these next couple lines
of code here we're going to create the
input function and we're going to go
ahead and create the model and let me go
ahead and put these codes in here i went
ahead and split it up so it's different
lines so we can talk a little bit about
that and then the actual model and let
me go ahead and run this so we can see
what that looks like and in my
particular environment it just prints
out a little bit of information about
the model not too worried about looking
at that but we do want to take a closer
look at what we did here so we've
created an input function and again this
is very specific to tensorflow with the
input function we have our train we have
our x equals x train and our y equals y
train because we want to train it with a
particular information but we have these
other settings in here these two
settings and the number of epics is how
many times it's going to go over our
training model epic means large that
means all the data so we're going to go
over it a thousand times that's actually
a huge overkill for this amount of data
usually it only needs probably about 200
but you know when we're putting it
together and you're trying things out
you just kind of throw the numbers in
there and then you go back and fine-tune
it sometimes the batch size is really
important this is where tensorflow does
some really cool things if you're
processing this over a huge amount of
data and you try to batch everything at
once you end up with a problem this
means we're only going to read 10 lines
at a time through our data so each one
of those rows of testing they've done
we're only going to look at 10 of them
at a time and put that through our model
and train it and then shuffle
self-explanatory we're just moving we're
just randomly selecting which data and
what order we go in that way if there's
like you know five in a row that are
kind of weighted one way and vice versa
it mixes them up and then finally we
create our model so the model goes in
there and goes okay i have a
tf.estimator.linearclassifier we're
going to put in the feature columns
equals feature columns we defined all
our columns up above and then we have in
classes equal 2. and that just means we
have our out result is zero or one you
have diabetes or you don't have diabetes
or in this case we actually call it high
risk of diabetes and then i put one more
line of code in there which i forgot
we've set up our model we set up our
feature columns now we need to actually
train it
model.train you'll see this so common in
so many different neural network models
this is like a standard what's different
though is we have to feed it the
function remember we created this
function with all this information on it
and then we have steps in uh steps
similar to number of batches and batch
size it's more like a individual lines
we step through a thousand is a lot more
common for steps than epics but steps is
used you probably leave this out in this
particular example and let's go ahead
and run this all together because it has
a site when we start training it we get
a different output so here we go i've
run it it's given me the information
from when i created the model and now it
just starts going through and we get
this information tensor loss equals
global step all kinds of stuff going on
here and if you're following this it's
just going through the steps and
training it it gives you information you
could dig deep into here but for this
particular setup we're not going to go
too deep on what's going on just know
that we've trained our model this model
now has the information we need in it to
start running predictions so as we sip
our next um take our next step of coffee
or maybe it's tea or if you're one of
those strange late night workers maybe
it's a sip of wine we go into the next
step we actually want to run some
predictions on here but we don't want to
run the training we want to run the test
on there we want to take our test data
and see what it did and so we're going
to do next is we're going to run the
test through and actually get some
answers so if you were actually
deploying it you would pull the answers
out of the data it's bringing back let's
take a look at that in our jupyter
notebook so here we go let's paste it in
there i'm going to go ahead and run it
and you'll see that as it goes it's
actually putting the answers out if you
remember correctly well we'll walk
through this here in just a second but
it goes through and it runs each line
and it gives you a prediction for each
line one at a time and prints them out
so let's take a look and see what that
actually looks like let's start with
this first part we've created another
function this is just like the other
function except for
x equals x test and there's no y why is
there no y because we don't know what
the answer is on this yet we don't want
to tell it the answer we wanted to guess
what the answer is so we can evaluate
that and see how good it did on that 33
of the data so this is our x test batch
size is 10 again so if we were watching
this roll down here we would see that it
actually processes it 10 lines at a time
it's only going to go through once it
goes through all the x test data one
time we don't need to have it predict
multiple times and shuffle equals false
very important we set the shuffle to
false because if we were tracking this
and actually giving people answers we'd
want to make sure it connects to the
right person so they get the right
results of course we're just doing this
to evaluate it so let's take a look down
here with a put out and as i scroll down
to my jupyter notebook we have some
information as far as the tensorflow
running and then the actual output and
if we look at the output we know by this
first bracket in python it's an array we
know
by this uh squiggly bracket that this is
a dictionary so that this is a label the
dictionary has logistic probabilities
class ids classes and so this whole
first part let me redo that this whole
first part is one output and we know
that because there is the bracket there
and there is this bracket here for the
dictionary and it's a dictionary of
terms so if i pulled this out and i
looked at object zero in here i would go
down to and let me just find it here it
is classes remember how we define
classes we define classes as our answer
and so it's guessing our tensorflow says
based on all the information you gave me
i'm guessing this first entry of our
first test data is high risk diabetes uh
oh go get tested change your diet watch
what you're eating you know high risk
one and if we go down far enough we can
see down here is another one where
classes equal zero i skipped a couple
because they're all ones up here the b
this particular output b
in front of the one means it's a binary
output it only comes out as 0 or 1. and
there's a lot of other information in
here you can dig deep into tensorflow
and explain these different numbers
that's way beyond the scope of what
we're working on today so the basics of
it though is you get an output we have
an output of whether the person has
diabetes or not well in this case it's
high risk of diabetes or not so now that
we've run our predictions take a sip of
coffee a little short break and we say
well what do we need to do well we need
to know how good was our predictions we
need to evaluate our model so if you're
going to publish this to a company or
something like that they want to know
how good you did let's take a look at
what that looks like in the code so
let's paste that in here and
just real quick go back over this by now
this function should look very uh this
is we're going to call it eval input
function it should be pretty straight
forward here we have our tf estimator
inputs pandas input function and then we
have our x test our y test so this time
we want to give it the answer so it has
something to uh see how good it did on
batch is 10 processing 10 at a time
we're only going once through the data
we're not shuffling it although it
doesn't really matter with this and then
we're going to do results equals
model.evalue
and we put our evaluation function in
there this should all look familiar
because we're repeating the same thing
it's very similar with a couple
different changes as far as what we're
feeding it and the fact that we're doing
an evaluation let's see what that looks
like when we run it
and we go up here to our run model
you'll see warnings on some of these
because i didn't install this on its own
install so a lot of it is just temporary
files because i'm using the jupiter
notebook instead of setting it up on a
regular machine and we get our output
and we'll go ahead and just look at this
output real quick and then we'll flip
over and from here you'll see that it
generates an accuracy a baseline average
loss the mean gives you a precision
prediction it gives you all kinds of
information on here so let's flip over
and see what's important and we'll look
at the slide here we are in this slide
and this should be exciting because we
just about wrapped up our whole tensor
flow and tensorflow is one of the more
complicated models out there so give
yourself a pat on the back for getting
all the way through this when we look at
this output we have an accuracy of
0.7165
that's really what we want to look at
that means that we have an accuracy if
you're just truncating it of 71
that's quite good for our model you know
given a small amount of data we came up
with a 71 percent of letting people know
they're high risk or not with diabetes
so we created a model that can predict
if a person has diabetes based on some
previous records of people who were
diagnosed with diabetes and we've
managed to have an accuracy of 71 which
is quite good the model was implemented
on python using tensorflow again pat
yourself on the back because tensorflow
is one of the more complicated scripts
out there it's also one of the more
diverse and useful ones let's look at
another example machine learning based
on the amount of rainfall how much would
be the crop yield so we here we have our
crops we have our rainfall and we want
to know how much we're going to get from
our crops this year so we're going to
introduce two variables independent and
dependent the independent variable is a
variable whose value does not change by
the effect of other variables and is
used to manipulate the dependent
variable it is often denoted as x in our
example rainfall is the independent
variable this is a wonderful example
because you can easily see that we can't
control the rain but the rain does
control the crop so we talk about the
independent variable controlling the
dependent variable let's define
dependent variable as a variable whose
value change when there is any
manipulation the values of the
independent variables it is often
denoted as y and you can see here our
crop yield is dependent variable and it
is dependent on the amount of rainfall
received now that we've taken a look at
a real life example let's go a little
bit into the theory and some definitions
on machine learning and see how that
fits together with linear regression
numerical and categorical values let's
take our data coming in this is kind of
random data from any kind of project we
want to divide it up into numerical and
categorical so numerical is numbers age
salary
height where categorical would be
a description the color a dog's breed
gender categorical is limited to very
specific items where numerical is a
range of information now that you've
seen the difference between numerical
and categorical data let's take a look
at some different machine learning
definitions we look at our different
machine learning algorithms we can
divide them into three areas supervised
unsupervised reinforcement we're only
going to look at supervised today
unsupervised means we don't have the
answers we're just grouping things
reinforcement is where we give positive
and negative feedback to our algorithm
to program it and it doesn't have the
information until after the fact but
today we're just looking at supervised
because that's where linear regression
fits in in supervised data we have our
data already there and our answers for a
group and then we use that to program
our model and come up with an answer the
two most common uses for that is through
the regression and classification now
we're doing linear regression so we're
just going to focus on the regression
side and in the regression we have
simple linear regression we have
multiple linear regression and we have
polynomial linear regression now on
these three simple linear regression is
the examples we've looked at so far we
have a lot of data and we draw a
straight line through it multiple linear
regression means we have multiple
variables remember where we had the
rainfall and the crops we might add
additional variables in there like how
much food do we give our crops when do
we harvest them those would be
additional information add in to our
model and that's why we multiple linear
regression and finally we have
polynomial linear regression that is
instead of drawing a line we can draw a
curved line through it now that you see
where regression model fits into the
machine learning algorithms and we're
specifically looking at linear
regression let's go ahead and take a
look at applications for linear
regression let's look at a few
applications of linear regression
economic growth used to determine the
economic growth of a country or a state
in the coming quarter can also be used
to predict the gdp of a country product
price can be used to predict what would
be the price of a product in the future
we can guess whether it's going to go up
or down or should i buy today housing
sales to estimate the number of houses a
builder would sell and what price in the
coming months score predictions cricket
fever to predict the number of runs a
player would score in the coming matches
based on the previous performance i'm
sure you can figure out other
applications you could use linear
regression for so let's jump in and
let's understand linear regression and
dig into the theory
understanding linear regression linear
regression is the statistical model used
to predict the relationship between
independent and dependent variables by
examining two factors
the first important one is which
variables in particular are significant
predictors of the outcome variable and
the second one that we need to look at
closely is how significant is the
regression line to make predictions with
the highest possible accuracy if it's
inaccurate we can't use it so it's very
important we find out the most accurate
line we can get
since linear regression is based on
drawing a line through data we're going
to jump back and take a look at some
euclidean geometry the simplest form of
a simple linear regression equation with
one dependent and one independent
variable is represented by y equals
m times x plus c and if you look at our
model here we plotted two points on here
x1 and y1 x2 and y2
y being the dependent variable remember
that from before and x being the
independent variable so y depends on
whatever x is m in this case is the
slope of the line where m equals the
difference in the y2 minus y1 and x2
minus x1 and finally we have c which is
the coefficient of the line or where it
happens to cross the zero axes
let's go back and look at an example we
used earlier of linear regression we're
going to go back to plotting the amount
of crop yield based on the amount of
rainfall and here we have our rainfall
remember we cannot change rainfall and
we have our crop yield which is
dependent on the rainfall so we have our
independent and our dependent variables
we're going to take this and draw a line
through it as best we can through the
middle of the data and then we look at
that we put the red point on the y axis
is the amount of crop yield you can
expect for the amount of rainfall
represented by the green dot so if we
have an idea what the rainfall is for
this year and what's going on then we
can guess how good our crops are going
to be and we've created a nice line
right through the middle to give us a
nice mathematical formula let's take a
look and see what the math looks like
behind this
let's look at the intuition behind the
regression line now before we dive into
the math and the formulas that go behind
this and what's going on behind the
scenes
i want you to note that when we get into
the case study and we actually apply
some python script that this math you're
going to see here is already done
automatically for you you don't have to
have it memorized it is however good to
have an idea what's going on so if
people reference the different terms
you'll know what they're talking about
let's consider a sample data set with
five rows and find out how to draw the
regression line we're only going to do
five rows because if we did like the
rainfall with hundreds of points of data
that would be very hard to see what's
going on with the mathematics so we'll
go ahead and create our own two sets of
data and we have our independent
variable x and our dependent variable y
and when x was 1 we got y equals 2 when
x was
2 y was 4 and so on and so on if we go
ahead and plot this data on a graph we
can see how it forms a nice line through
the middle you can see where it's kind
of grouped going upwards to the right
the next thing we want to know is what
the means is of each of the data coming
in the x and the y the means doesn't
mean anything other than the average so
we add up all the numbers and divide by
the total so 1 plus 2 plus 3 plus 4 plus
5 over 5 equals 3 and the same for y we
get 4. if we go ahead and plot the means
on the graph we'll see we get 3 comma 4
which draws a nice line down the middle
a good estimate
here we're going to dig deeper into the
math behind the regression line now
remember before i said you don't have to
have all these formulas memorized or
fully understand them even though we're
going to go into a little more detail of
how it works and if you're not a math
wiz and you don't know if you've never
seen the sigma character before which
looks a little bit like an e that's
opened up that just means summation
that's all that is so when you see the
sigma character it just means we're
adding everything in that row and for
computers this is great because as a
programmer you can easily iterate
through each of the xy points and create
all the information you need so in the
top half you can see where we've broken
that down into pieces and as it goes
through the first two points it computes
the squared value of x the squared value
of y and x times y and then it takes all
of x and adds them up all of y adds them
up all of x squared adds them up and so
on and so on and you can see we have the
sum of equal to 15 the sum is equal to
20 all the way up to x times y where the
sum equals 66. this all comes from our
formula for calculating a straight line
where y equals the slope times x plus
the coefficient c so we go down below
and we're going to compute more like the
averages of these and we'll explain
exactly what that is in just a minute
and where that information comes from is
called the square means error but we'll
go into that in detail in a few minutes
all you need to do is look at the
formula and see how we've gone about
computing it line by line instead of
trying to have a huge
set of numbers pushed into it and down
here you'll see where the slope m equals
and then the top part if you read
through the brackets you have the number
of data points times the sum
of x times y which we computed one line
at a time there and that's just the 66
and take all that and you subtract it
from the sum of x times the sum of y and
those have both been computed so you
have 15 times 20. and on the bottom we
have the number of lines times the sum
of x squared easily computed as 86 for
the sum minus i'll take all that and
subtract the sum of x squared and we end
up as we come across with our formula
you can plug in all those numbers which
is very easy to do on the computer you
don't have to do the math on a piece of
paper or calculator and you'll get a
slope of 0.6 and you'll get your c
coefficient if you continue to follow
through that formula you'll see it comes
out as equal to 2.2 continuing deeper
into what's going behind the scenes
let's find out the predicted values of y
for corresponding values of x using the
linear equation where m equals 0.6 and c
equals 2.2 we're going to take these
values and we're going to go ahead and
plot them we're going to predict them so
y equals 0.6 times where x equals 1 plus
2.2 equals 2.8 so on and so on and here
the blue points represent the actual y
values and the brown points represent
the predicted y values based on the
model we created the distance between
the actual and predicted values is known
as residuals or errors
the best fit lines should have the least
sum of squares of these errors also
known as e-square if we put these into a
nice chart where you can see x
and you can see why what we actual
values were and you can see why i
predict it you can easily see where we
take y minus y predicted and we get an
answer what is the difference between
those two and if we square that y minus
y prediction squared we can then sum
those squared values that's where we get
the 0.64 plus the 0.36 plus 1 all the
way down until we have a summation
equals 2.4 so the sum of squared errors
for this regression line is 2.4 we check
this error for each line and include the
best fit line having the least e square
value in a nice graphical representation
we can see here where we keep moving
this line through the data points to
make sure the best fit line has the
least square distance between the data
points and the regression line now we
only looked at the most commonly used
formula for minimizing the distance
there are lots of ways to minimize the
distance between the line and the data
points like sum of squared errors sum of
absolute errors root mean square error
etc what you want to take away from this
is whatever formula is being used you
can easily using a computer programming
and iterating through the data calculate
the different parts of it that way these
complicated formulas you see with the
different summations and absolute values
are easily computed one piece at a time
up until this point we've only been
looking at two values x and y well in
the real world it's very rare that you
only have two values when you're
figuring out a solution so let's move on
to the next topic multiple linear
regression let's take a brief look at
what happens when you have multiple
inputs so in multiple linear regression
we have well we'll start with the simple
linear regression where we had y equals
m plus x plus c and we're trying to find
the value of y now with multiple linear
regression we have multiple variables
coming in so instead of having just x we
have x1 x2 x3 and instead of having just
one slope each variable has its own
slope attached to it as you can see here
we have m1 m2 m3 and we still just have
the single coefficient so when you're
dealing with multiple linear regression
you basically take your single linear
regression and you spread it out so you
have y equals m1 times x1 plus m2 times
x2
so on all the way to m to the nth x to
the nth and then you add your
coefficient on there implementation of
linear regression now we get into my
favorite part let's understand how
multiple linear regression works by
implementing it in python if you
remember before we were looking at a
company and just based on its rnd trying
to figure out its profit we're going to
start looking at the expenditure of the
company we're going to go back to that
we're going to predict his profit but
instead of predicting it just on the r d
we're going to look at other factors
like administration costs marketing
costs and so on and from there we're
going to see if we can figure out what
the profit of that company is going to
be to start our coding we're going to
begin by importing some basic libraries
and we're going to be looking through
the data before we do any kind of linear
regression we're going to take a look at
the data to see what we're playing with
then we'll go ahead and format the data
to the format we need to be able to run
it in the linear regression model and
then from there we'll go ahead and solve
it and just see how valid our solution
is so let's start with importing the
basic libraries now i'm going to be
doing this in anaconda jupiter notebook
a very popular ide i enjoy it's such a
visual to look at and so easy to use
just any id for python will work just
fine for this so break out your favorite
python ide so here we are in our jupyter
notebook let me go ahead and paste our
first piece of code in there and let's
walk through what libraries we're
importing first we're going to import
numpy as np and then i want you to skip
one line and look at import pandas as pd
these are very common tools that you
need with most of your linear regression
the numpy which stands for number python
is usually denoted as np and you have to
almost have that for your sk learn
toolbox you always import that right off
the beginning pandas although you don't
have to have it for your sklearn
libraries it does such a wonderful job
of importing data setting it up into a
data frame so we can manipulate it
rather easily and it has a lot of tools
also in addition to that so we usually
like to use the pandas when we can and
i'll show you what that looks like the
other three lines are for us to get a
visual of this data and take a look at
it so we're going to import
matplotlibrary.pipelot as plt and then
seaborn as sns seaborn works with the
matplot library so you have to always
import matplot library and then seaborn
sits on top of it and we'll take a look
at what that looks like you could use
any of your own plotting libraries you
want there's all kinds of ways to look
at the data these are just very common
ones and the seaborne is so easy to use
it just looks beautiful it's a nice
representation that you can actually
take and show somebody and the final
line is the amber scion map plot library
inline that is only because i'm doing an
inline ide my interface in the anaconda
jupiter notebook requires i put that in
there or you're not going to see the
graph when it comes up let's go ahead
and run this it's not going to be that
interesting so we're just setting up
variables in fact it's not going to do
anything that we can see but it is
importing these different libraries and
setup the next step is load the data set
and extract independent and dependent
variables now here in the slide you'll
see companies equals pd.read csv and it
has a long line there with the file at
the end 1000 companies dot csv you're
going to have to change this to fit
whatever setup you have and the file
itself you can request just go down to
the commentary below this video and put
a note in there and simply learn we'll
try to get in contact with you and
supply you with that file so you can try
this coding yourself so we're going to
add this code in here and we're going to
see that i have companies equals
pd.reader underscore csv and i've
changed this path to match my computer c
colon slash simply learn slash 1000
underscore companies.csv and then below
there we're going to set the x equals to
companies under the i location and
because this is companies as a pd data
set i can use this nice notation that
says take every row that's what the
colon the first colon is comma except
for the last column that's what the
second part is where we have a colon
minus one and we want the values set
into there so x is no longer a data set
a pandas data set but we can easily
extract the data from our pandas data
set with this notation and then y we're
going to set equal to the last row well
the question is going to be what are we
actually looking at so let's go ahead
and take a look at that and we're going
to look at the companies dot head which
lists the first five rows of data and
i'll open up the file in just a second
so you can see where that's coming from
but let's look at the data in here as
far as the way the pandas sees it when i
hit run you'll see it breaks it out into
a nice setup this is what panda is one
of the things pandas is really good
about is it looks just like an excel
spreadsheet you have your rows and
remember when we're programming we
always start with zero we don't start
with one so it shows the first five rows
zero one two three four and then it
shows your different columns r d spend
administration marketing spend state
profit it even notes that the top are
column names it was never told that but
pandas is able to recognize a lot of
things that they're not the same as the
data rows why don't we go ahead and open
this file up in a csv so you can
actually see the raw data so here i've
opened it up as a text editor and you
can see at the top we have rnd spend
comma administration comma marketing
spin comma state comma profit carries
return i don't know about you but i go
crazy trying to read files like this
that's why we use the pandas you could
also open this up in an excel and it
would separate it since it is a comma
separated variable file but we don't
want to look at this one we want to look
at something we can read rather easily
so let's flip back and take a look at
that top part the first five row now as
nice as this format is where i can see
the data to me it doesn't mean a whole
lot maybe you're an expert in business
and investments and you understand what
uh 165
349.20
compared to the administration cost of a
hundred and thirty six thousand eight
hundred ninety seven dollars and eighty
cents so on so on it helps to create the
profit of 192 261 and 83 cents that
makes no sense to me whatsoever no pun
intended so let's flip back here and
take a look at our next set of code
where we're going to graph it so we can
get a better understanding of our data
and what it means so at this point we're
going to use a single line of code to
get a lot of information so we can see
where we're going with this let's go
ahead and paste that into our
notebook and see what we got going and
so we have the visualization and again
we're using sns which is pandas as you
can see we imported the map plot library
dot pi plot as plt which then the
seaborn uses and we imported the seaborn
as sns and then that final line of code
helps us show this in our inline coding
without this it wouldn't display and you
could display it to a file and other
means and that's the matplot library in
line with the amber sign at the
beginning so here we come down to the
single line of code seaborn is great
because it actually recognizes the panda
data frame so i can just take the
companies dot core for coordinates and i
can put that right into the seaborn and
when we run this we get this beautiful
plot and let's just take a look at what
this plot means if you look at this plot
on mine the colors are probably a little
bit more purplish and blue than the
original one we have the columns and the
rows we have r and d spending we have
administration we have marketing
spending and profit and if you cross
index any two of these since we're
interested in profit if you cross index
profit with profit it's going to show up
if you look at the scale on the right
way up in the dark why because those are
the same data they have an exact
correspondence so r d spending is going
to be the same as r d spending and the
same thing with administration costs
right down the middle you get this dark
row or dark
diagonal row that shows that this is the
highest corresponding data that's
exactly the same and as it becomes
lighter there's less connections between
the data so we can see with profit
obviously profit is the same as profit
and next it has a very high correlation
with r d spending which we looked at
earlier and it has a slightly less
connection to marketing spending and
even less to how much money we put into
the administration so now that we have a
nice look at the data let's go ahead and
dig in and create some actual useful
linear regression models so that we can
predict values and have a better profit
now that we've taken a look at the
visualization of this data we're going
to move on to the next step instead of
just having a pretty picture we need to
generate some hard data some hard values
so let's see what that looks like we're
going to set up our linear regression
model in two steps the first one is we
need to prepare some of our data so it
fits correctly and let's go ahead and
paste this code into our jupyter
notebook and what we're bringing in is
we're going to bring in the sklearn
pre-processing where we're going to
import the label encoder and the one hot
encoder to use the label encoder we're
going to create a variable called label
encoder and set it equal to capital l
label capital e encoder this creates a
class that we can reuse for transferring
the labels back and forth now about now
you should ask what labels are we
talking about let's go take a look at
the data we processed before and see
what i'm talking about here if you
remember when we did the companies dot
head and we printed the top five rows of
data we have our columns going across we
have column zero which is r and d
spending column one which is
administration
column two which is marketing spending
and column three is state
and you'll see under state we have new
york california florida now to do a
linear regression model it doesn't know
how to process new york it knows how to
process a number so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to
change that new york california and
florida and we're going to change those
to numbers that's what this line of code
does here x equals and then it has the
colon comma 3 in brackets the first part
the colon comma means that we're going
to look at all the different rows so
we're going to keep them all together
but the only row we're going to edit is
the third row and in there we're going
to take the label coder and we're going
to fit and transform the x also the
third row so we're going to take that
third row we're going to set it equal to
a transformation and that transformation
basically tells it that instead of
having a
new york it has a zero or a one or a two
and then finally we need to do a one hot
encoder which equals one hot inc or
categorical features equals three and
then we take the x and we go ahead and
do that equal to one hot encoder fit
transform x to array this final
transformation preps our data for us so
it's completely set the way we need it
is just a row of numbers even though
it's not in here let's go ahead and
print x and just take a look what this
data is doing you'll see you have an
array of arrays and then each array is a
row of numbers and if i go ahead and
just do row 0 you'll see i have a nice
organized row of numbers that the
computer now understands we'll go ahead
and take this out there because it
doesn't mean a whole lot to us it's just
a row of numbers
next on setting up our data we have
avoiding dummy variable trap this is
very important why because the computer
has automatically transformed our header
into the setup and it's automatically
transferring all these different
variables so when we did the encoder the
encoder created two columns and what we
need to do is just have the one because
it has both the variable and the name
that's what this piece of code does here
let's go ahead and paste this in here
and we have x equals x colon comma one
colon all this is doing is removing that
one extra column we put in there when we
did our one hot encoder and our label
encoding let's go ahead and run that and
now we get to create our linear
regression model and let's see what that
looks like here and we're going to do
that in two steps the first step is
going to be in splitting the data now
whenever we create a predictive model of
data we always want to split it up so we
have a training set and we have a
testing set that's very important
otherwise we'd be very unethical without
testing it to see how good our fit is
and then we'll go ahead and create our
multiple linear regression model and
train it and set it up let's go ahead
and paste this next piece of code in
here and i'll go ahead and shrink it
down a size or two so it all fits on one
line so from the sklearn module
selection we're going to import train
test split and you'll see that we've
created four completely different
variables we have capital x train
capital x test smaller case y train
smaller case y test
that is the standard way that they
usually reference these when we're doing
different uh models you usually see that
a capital x and you see the train and
the test and the lowercase y what this
is is x is our data going in that's our
rnd spin our administration our
marketing and then y which we're
training is the answer that's the profit
because we want to know the profit of an
unknown entity that's what we're going
to shoot for in this tutorial the next
part train test split we take x and we
take y we've already created those x has
the columns with the data in it and y
has a column with profit in it and then
we're going to set the test size equals
point two that basically means twenty
percent
so twenty percent of the rows are going
to be tested we're gonna put them off to
the side so since we're using a thousand
lines of data that means that 200 of
those lines we're going to hold off to
the side to test for later and then the
random state equals zero we're going to
randomize which ones it picks to hold
off to the side we'll go ahead and run
this it's not overly exciting so setting
up our variables but the next step is
the next step we actually create our
linear regression model now that we got
to the linear regression model we get
that next piece of the puzzle let's go
ahead and put that code in there and
walk through it so here we go we're
going to paste it in there and let's go
ahead and since this is a shorter line
of code let's zoom up there so we can
get a good look and we have from the
sklearn the linear underscore model
we're going to import linear regression
now i don't know if you recall from
earlier when we were doing all the math
let's go ahead and flip back there and
take a look at that do you remember this
where we had this long formula on the
bottom and we were doing all this
summarization and then we also looked at
uh setting it up with the different
lines and then we also looked all the
way down to multiple linear regression
where we're adding all those formulas
together all of that is wrapped up in
this one section so what's going on here
is i'm going to create a variable called
regressor and the regressor equals the
linear regression that's a linear
regression model that has all that math
built in so we don't have to have it all
memorized or have to compute it
individually and then we do the
regressor dot fit in this case we do x
train and y train because we're using
the training data x being the data in
and y being profit what we're looking at
and this does all that math for us so
within one click and one line we've
created the whole linear regression
model and we fit the data to the linear
regression model and you can see that
when i run the regressor it gives an
output linear regression it says copy x
equals true fit intercept equals true in
jobs equal one normalize equals false
it's just giving you some general
information on what's going on with that
regressor model now that we've created
our linear regression model let's go
ahead and use it and if you remember we
kept a bunch of data aside so we're
going to do a y predict variable and
we're going to put in the x test and
let's see what that looks like scroll up
a little bit paste that in here
predicting the test set results so here
we have y predict
equals regressor dot predict x test
going in and this gives us y predict now
because i'm in jupiter inline i can just
put the variable up there and when i hit
the run button it'll print that array
out i could have just as easily done
print
why predict so if you're in a different
ide that's not an inline setup like the
jupiter notebook you can do it this way
print y predict and you'll see that for
the 200 different test variables we kept
off to the side is going to produce 200
answers this is what it says the profit
are for those 200 predictions but let's
don't stop there let's keep going and
take a couple look we're going to take
just a short detail here and calculating
the coefficients and the intercepts this
gives us a quick flash at what's going
on behind the line we're going to take a
short detour here and we're going to be
calculating the coefficient and
intercepts so you can see what those
look like what's really nice about our
regressor we created is it already has a
coefficients for us we can simply just
print regressor dot coefficient
underscore when i run this you'll see
our coefficients here and if we can do
the regressor coefficient we can also do
the regressor intercept and let's run
that and take a look at that this all
came from the multiple regression model
and we'll flip over so you can remember
where this is going into where it's
coming from you can see the formula down
here where y equals m1 times x1 plus m2
times x2 and so on and so on plus c the
coefficient so these variables fit right
into this formula y equals slope 1 times
column 1 variable plus slope 2 times
column 2 variable all the way to the m
and to the n and x to the n plus c the
coefficient or in this case you have
minus 8.89
to the power of 2 etc etc times the
first column and the second column and
the third column and then our intercept
is the minus one zero three zero zero
nine point boy it gets kind of
complicated when you look at it this is
why we don't do this by hand anymore
this is why we have the computer to make
these calculations easy to understand
and calculate now i told you that was a
short detour and we're coming towards
the end of our script as you remember
from the beginning i said if we're going
to divide this information we have to
make sure it's a valid model that this
model works and understand how good it
works so calculating the r squared value
that's what we're going to use to
predict how good our prediction is and
let's take a look what that looks like
in code and so we're going to use this
from
sklearn.metrics we're going to import r2
score that's the r squared value we're
looking at the error so in the r2 score
we take our y test versus our y predict
y test is the actual values we're
testing that was the one that was given
to us so we know are true the y predict
of those 200 values is what we think it
was true and when we go ahead and run
this we see we get a 0.9352
that's the r2 score now it's not exactly
a straight percentage so it's not saying
it's 93 percent correct but you do want
that in the upper 90s o and higher shows
that this is a very valid prediction
based on the r2 score and if r squared
value of 0.91 or 92 as we got on our
model remember it does have a random
generation involved this proves the
model is a good model which means
success yay we successfully trained our
model with certain predictors and
estimated the profit of the companies
using linear regression what is a
decision tree let's go through a very
simple example before we dig in deep
decision tree is a tree shape diagram
used to determine a course of action
each branch of the tree represents a
possible decision or currents or
reaction let's start with a simple
question how to identify a random
vegetable from a shopping bag so we have
this group of vegetables in here and we
can start off by asking a simple
question is it red and if it's not then
it's going to be the purple fruit to the
left probably an eggplant if it's true
it's going to be one of the red fruits
is the diameter greater than 2 if false
is going to be a what looks to be a red
chili and if it's true it's going to be
a bell pepper from the capsicum family
so it's a capsicum
problems that decision tree can solve so
let's look at the two different
categories the decision tree can be used
on it can be used on the classification
the true false yes no and it can be used
on regression where we figure out what
the next value is in a series of numbers
or a group of data in classification the
classification tree will determine a set
of logical if-then conditions to
classify problems for example
discriminating between three types of
flowers based on certain features in
regression a regression tree is used
when the target variable is numerical or
continuous in nature we fit the
regression model to the target variable
using each of the independent variables
each split is made based on the sum of
squared error
before we dig deeper into the mechanics
of the decision tree let's take a look
at the advantages of using a decision
tree and we'll also take a glimpse at
the disadvantages the first thing you'll
notice is that it's simple to understand
interpret and visualize it really shines
here because you can see exactly what's
going on in a decision tree little
effort is required for data preparation
so you don't have to do special scaling
there's a lot of things you don't have
to worry about when using a decision
tree it can handle both numerical and
categorical data as we discovered
earlier and non-linear parameters don't
affect its performance so even if the
data doesn't fit an easy curved graph
you can still use it to create an
effective decision or prediction
if we're going to look at the advantages
of a decision tree we also need to
understand the disadvantages of a
decision tree the first disadvantage is
overfitting overfitting occurs when the
algorithm captures noise in the data
that means you're solving for one
specific instance instead of a general
solution for all the data high variance
the model can get unstable due to small
variation in data low bias tree a highly
complicated decision tree tends to have
a low bias which makes it difficult for
the model to work with new data
decision tree important terms before we
dive in further we need to look at some
basic terms we need to have some
definitions to go with our decision tree
and the different parts we're going to
be using we'll start with entropy
entropy is a measure of randomness or
unpredictability in the data set for
example we have a group of animals in
this picture there's four different
kinds of animals and this data set is
considered to have a high entropy you
really can't pick out what kind of
animal it is based on looking at just
the four animals as a big clump of uh
entities so as we start splitting it
into subgroups we come up with our
second definition which is information
gain information gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split so in this case based on the
color yellow we've split one group of
animals on one side as true and those
who aren't yellow as false as we
continue down the yellow side we split
based on the height true or false equals
10 and on the other side height is less
than 10 true or false and as you see as
we split it the entropy continues to be
less and less and less and so our
information gain is simply the entropy
e1 from the top and how it's changed to
e2 in the bottom and we'll look at the
deeper math although you really don't
need to know a huge amount of math when
you actually do the programming in
python because it'll do it for you but
we'll look on the actual math of how
they compute entropy finally we went to
the different parts of our tree and they
call the leaf node leaf node carries the
classification or the decision so it's
the final end at the bottom the decision
node has two or more branches this is
where we're breaking the group up into
different parts and finally you have the
root note the topmost decision node is
known as the root node
how does a decision tree work wonder
what kind of animals i'll get the jungle
today maybe you're the hunter with a gun
or if you're more into photography
you're a photographer with a camera so
let's look at this group of animals and
let's try to classify different types of
animals based on their features using a
decision tree so the problem statement
is to classify the different types of
animals based on their features using a
decision tree the data set is looking
quite messy and the entropy is high in
this case so let's look at a training
set or a training data set and we're
looking at color we're looking at height
and then we have our different animals
we have our elephants our giraffes our
monkeys and our tigers and there of
different colors and shapes let's see
what that looks like and how do we split
the data we have to frame the conditions
that split the data in such a way that
the information gain is the highest note
gain is a measure of decrease in entropy
after splitting so the formula for
entropy is the sum that's what this
symbol looks like that looks like kind
of like a e funky e of k where i equals
1 to k k would represent the number of
animals the different animals in there
where value or p
value of i would be the percentage of
that animal times the log base 2 of the
same the percentage of that animal let's
try to calculate the entropy for the
current data set and take a look at what
that looks like and don't be afraid of
the math you don't really have to
memorize this math just be aware that
it's there and this is what's going on
in the background and so we have three
giraffes two tigers one monkey two
elephants a total of eight animals
gathered and if we plug that into the
formula we get an entropy that equals
three over eight so we have three
giraffes a total of eight times the log
usually they use base two on the log so
log base two of three over eight plus in
this case it says yellow fence two over
eight two elephants over total of eight
times log base two two over eight plus
one monkey over total of eight log base
two one over eight and plus two over
eight of the tigers log base two over
eight and if we plug that into our
computer our calculator i obviously
can't do logs in my head we get an
entropy equal to .57
the program will actually calculate the
entropy of the data set similarly after
every split to calculate the gain now
we're not going to go through each set
one at a time to see what those numbers
are we just want you to be aware that
this is a formula or the mathematics
behind it gain can be calculated by
finding the difference of the subsequent
entropy values after a split now we will
try to choose a condition that gives us
the highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking that the gain we get out of
them the condition that gives us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split can you guess what that
first split will be just by looking at
this image as a human is probably pretty
easy to split it let's see if you're
right if you guessed the color yellow
you're correct let's say the condition
that gives us the maximum gain is yellow
so we will split the data based on the
color yellow if it's true that group of
animals goes to the left if it's false
it goes to the right the entropy after
the splitting has
decreased considerably however we still
need some splitting of both the branches
to attain an entropy value equal to zero
so we decide to split both the nodes
using height as the condition since
every branch now contains single label
type we can say that entropy in this
case has reached the least value and
here you see we have the giraffes the
tigers the monkey and the elephants all
separated into their own groups this
tree can now predict all the classes of
animals present in the dataset with 100
accuracy that was easy
use case loan repayment prediction let's
get into my favorite part and open up
some python and see what the programming
code in the scripting looks like in here
we're going to want to do a prediction
and we start with this individual here
who's requesting to find out how good
his customers are going to be whether
they're going to be paid their loan or
not for his bank and from that we want
to generate a problem statement to
predict if a customer will repay loan
amount or not and then we're going to be
using the decision tree algorithm in
python let's see what that looks like
and let's dive into the code in our
first few steps of implementation we're
going to start by importing the
necessary packages that we need from
python and we're going to load up our
data and take a look at what the data
looks like so the first thing i need is
i need something to edit my python and
run it in so let's flip on over and here
i'm using the anaconda jupiter notebook
now you can use any python ide you like
to run it in but i find the jupiter
notebook's really nice for doing things
on the fly and let's go ahead and just
paste that code in the beginning and
before we start let's talk a little bit
about what we're bringing in and then
we're going to do a couple things in
here we have to make a couple changes as
we go through this first part of the
import the first thing we bring in is
numpy as np that's very standard when
we're dealing with mathematics
especially with uh very complicated
machine learning tools you almost always
see the numpy come in for your num your
number it's called number python it has
your mathematics in there in this case
we actually could take it out but
generally you'll need it for most of
your different things you work with and
then we're going to use pandas as pd
that's also a standard the pandas is a
data frame setup and you can liken this
to
taking your basic data and storing it in
a way that looks like an excel
spreadsheet so as we come back to this
when you see np or pd those are very
standard uses you'll know that that's
the pandas and i'll show you a little
bit more we explore the data in just a
minute then we're going to need to split
the data so i'm going to bring in our
train test and split and this is coming
from the sk learn package cross
validation in just a minute we're going
to change that and we'll go over that
too and then there's also the sk.tree
import decision tree classifier that's
the actual tool we're using remember i
told you don't be afraid of the
mathematics it's going to be done for
you well the decision tree classifier
has all that mathematics in there for
you so you don't have to figure it back
out again and then we have
sklearn.metrics for accuracy score we
need to score our setup that's the whole
reason we're splitting it between the
training and testing data and finally we
still need the sklearn import tree and
that's just the basic tree function is
needed for the decision tree classifier
and finally we're going to load our data
down here and i'm going to run this and
we're going to get two things on here
one we're going to get an error and two
we're going to get a warning let's see
what that looks like so the first thing
we had is we have an error why is this
error here well it's looking at this it
says i need to read a file and when this
was written
the person who wrote it
this is their path where they stored the
file
so let's go ahead and fix that
and i'm going to put in here my file
path i'm just going to call it full file
name
and you'll see it's on my c drive and
this very lengthy setup on here where i
stored the data2.csv file
don't worry too much about the full path
because on your computer will be
different
the data.2 csv file was generated by
simplylearn
if you want a copy of that you can
comment down below and request it here
in the
youtube and then if i'm going to give it
a name full file name
i'm going to go ahead and change it here
to full
file name so let's go ahead and run it
now and see what happens
and we get a warning
when you're coding
understanding these different warnings
and these different errors that come up
is probably the hardest lesson to learn
so let's just go ahead and take a look
at this and use this as a opportunity to
understand what's going on here
if you read the warning it says the
cross validation is depreciated so it's
a warning on it's being removed and it's
going to be moved in favor of the model
selection
so if we go up here we have sklearn dot
cross validation and if you research
this and go to the sklearn site you'll
find out that you can actually just swap
it right in there with
model selection
and so when i come in here and i run it
again
that removes a warning
what they've done is they've had two
different developers develop it in two
different branches
and then they decided to keep one of
those and eventually get rid of the
other one that's all that is and very
easy and quick to fix
before we go any further i went ahead
and opened up the data
from this file remember the the data
file we just loaded on here the data
underscore2.csv
let's talk a little bit more about that
and see what that looks like both as a
text file because it's a comma separated
variable file and in a spreadsheet this
is what it looks like as a basic text
file you can see at the top they've
created a header and it's got one two
three four five columns and each column
has data in it and let me flip this over
because we're also going to look at this
uh in an actual spreadsheet so you can
see what that looks like and here i've
opened it up in the open office calc
which is pretty much the same as excel
and zoomed in and you can see we've got
our columns and our rows of data a
little easier to read in here we have a
result yes yes no we have initial
payment last payment credit score
house number
if we scroll way down
we'll see that this occupies a thousand
and one lines of code or lines of data
with the first one being a column and
then one thousand lines of data
now as a programmer
if you're looking at a small amount of
data i usually start by pulling it up in
different sources so i can see what i'm
working with
but in larger data you won't have that
option it'll just be too too large so
you need to either bring in a small
amount that you can look at it like
we're doing right now or we can start
looking at it through the python code so
let's go ahead and move on and take the
next couple steps to explore the data
using python let's go ahead and see what
it looks like in python to print the
length and the shape of the data so
let's start by printing the length of
the database we can use a simple lin
function from python
and when i run this
you'll see that it's a thousand long and
that's what we expected there's a
thousand lines of data in there if you
subtract the column head this is one of
the nice things when we did the
balance data from the panda read csv
you'll see that the header is row 0 so
it automatically removes a row
and then shows the data separate it does
a good job sorting that data out for us
and then we can use a different function
and let's take a look at that
and again we're going to utilize the
tools in panda
and since the balance underscored data
was loaded as a panda data frame
we can do a shape on it and let's go
ahead and run the shape and see what
that looks like
what's nice about this shape is not only
does it give me the length of the data
we have a thousand lines it also tells
me there's five columns so we were
looking at the data we had five columns
of data and then let's take one more
step to explore the data using python
and now that we've taken a look at the
length and the shape let's go ahead and
use the pandas module for head another
beautiful thing in the data set that we
can utilize so let's put that on our
sheet here and we have print data set
and balance data dot head and this is a
pandas print statement of its own so it
has its own print feature in there and
then we went ahead and gave a label for
a print job here of dataset just a
simple print statement
and when we run that
let's just take a closer look at that
let me zoom in here
there we go
pandas do such a wonderful job of making
this a very clean
readable data set so you can look at the
data you can look at the column headers
you can have it when you put it as the
head it prints the first five lines of
the data
and we always start with zero so we have
five lines we have zero one two three
four instead of one two three four five
that's a standard scripting and
programming set as you wanna start with
the zero position and that is what the
data head does it pulls the first five
rows of data puts in a nice format that
you can look at and view very powerful
tool to view the data so instead of
having to flip and open up an excel
spreadsheet or open office cal or trying
to look at a word doc where it's all
scrunched together and hard to read you
can now get a nice open view of what
you're working with we're working with a
shape of a thousand long five wide so we
have five columns and we do the full
data head you can actually see what this
data looks like the initial payment last
payment credit scores house number so
let's take this now that we've explored
the data and let's start digging into
the decision tree so in our next step
we're going to train and build our data
tree and to do that we need to first
separate the data out we're going to
separate into two groups so that we have
something to actually train the data
with and then we have some data on the
side to test it to see how good our
model is remember with any of the
machine learning you always want to have
some kind of test set to weigh it
against so you know how good your model
is when you distribute it let's go ahead
and break this code down and look at it
in pieces
so first we have our x and y
where do x and y come from well x is
going to be our data
and y is going to be the answer or the
target you can look at source and target
in this case we're using x and y to
denote the data in and the data that
we're actually trying to guess what the
answer is going to be and so to separate
it we can simply put in x equals the
balance of the data.values the first
brackets
means that we're going to select all the
lines
in the database so it's all the data
and the second one says we're only going
to look at columns 1 through 5. remember
i always start with zero zero is a yes
or no and that's whether the loan went
default or not so we want to start with
one if we go back up here that's the
initial payment and it goes all the way
through the house number
well if we want to look at one through
five we can do the same thing for y
which is the answers and we're going to
set that just equal to the zero row so
it's just the zero row and then it's all
rows going in there so now we've divided
this into two different data sets
one of them with the
data going in and one with the answers
next we need to split the data
and here you'll see that we have it
split into four different parts
the first one is your x training your x
test your y train your y test
simply put we have x going in where
we're going to train it and we have to
know the answer to train it with
and then we have x test where we're
going to test that data
and we have to know in the end what the
y was supposed to be
and that's where this train test split
comes in that we loaded earlier in the
modules this does it all for us and you
can see they set the test size equal to
0.3 so that's roughly 30 percent will be
used in the test and then we use a
random state so it's completely random
which rows it takes out of there and
then finally we get to actually build
our decision tree and they've called it
here clf underscore entropy that's the
actual decision tree or decision tree
classifier and in here they've added a
couple variables which we'll explore in
just a minute and then finally we need
to fit the data to that so we take our
clf entropy that we created and we fit
the x train and since we know the
answers for x trade or the y train we go
ahead and put those in and let's go
ahead and run this and what most of
these sklearn modules do is when you set
up the variable in this case we set the
clf entropal decision tree classifier it
automatically prints out what's in that
decision tree there's a lot of variables
you can play within here and it's quite
beyond the scope of this
tutorial to go through all of these and
how they work but we're working on
entropy that's one of the options we've
added that is completely a random state
of 100 so 100 percent and we have a max
depth of three now the max depth if you
remember above when we were doing the
different graphs of animals means it's
only going to go down three layers
before it stops and then we have minimal
samples of leaves is five so it's going
to have at least five leaves at the end
so i'll have at least three splits i'll
have no more than three layers and at
least five end leaves with the final
result at the bottom now that we've
created
our decision tree classifier not only
created it but trained it let's go ahead
and apply it and see what that looks
like so let's go ahead and make a
prediction and see what that looks like
we're going to paste our predict code in
here
and before we run it let's just take a
quick look at what's it's doing here
we have a variable why predict that
we're going to do
and we're going to use our
variable clf entropy that we created
and then you'll see dot predict and it's
very common in the sk learn modules
that they're different tools have the
predict when you're actually running a
prediction
in this case we're going to put our x
test data in here
now if you delivered this for use in
actual commercial use and distributed it
this would be the new loans you're
putting in here to guess
whether the person is going to be pay
them back or not
in this case though we need to test out
the data and just see how good our
sample is how good of our tree does at
predicting the loan payments and finally
since anaconda jupiter notebook works as
a command line for python we can simply
put the y predict e n to print it i
could just as easily put the print
and put brackets around y predict e in
to print it out we'll go ahead and do
that it doesn't matter which way you do
it
and you'll see right here that runs a
prediction this is roughly 300 in here
remember it's 30 percent of a thousand
so you should have about 300 answers in
here
and this tells you which each one of
those lines of our test went in there
and this is what our y predict came out
so let's move on to the next step we're
going to take this data and try to
figure out just how good a model we have
so here we go since sklearn does all the
heavy lifting for you and all the math
we have a simple line of code to let us
know what the accuracy is and let's go
ahead and go through that and see what
that means and what that looks like
let's go ahead and paste this in and let
me zoom in a little bit
there we go
so you have a nice full picture
and we'll see here we're just going to
do a print accuracy is
and then we do the accuracy score
and this was something we imported
earlier if you remember at the very
beginning let me just scroll up there
real quick so you can see where that's
coming from
that's coming from here down here from
sklearn.metrics import accuracy score
and you could probably run a script make
your own script to do this very easily
how accurate is it how many out of 300
do we get right and so we put in our y
test that's the one we ran the predict
on and then we put in our y predict e n
that's the answers we got and we're just
going to multiply that by a hundred
because this is just going to give us an
answer as a decimal and we want to see
it as a percentage
and let's run that and see what it looks
like
and if you see here we got an accuracy
of 93.66667
so when we look at the number of loans
and we look at how good our model fit we
can tell people it has about a 93.6
fitting to it so just a quick recap on
that we now have accuracy set up on here
and so we have created a model that uses
the decision tree algorithm to predict
whether a customer will repay the loan
or not the accuracy of the model is
about 94.6 percent the bank can now use
this model to decide whether it should
approve the loan request from a
particular customer or not and so this
information is really powerful we may
not be able to as individuals understand
all these numbers because they have
thousands of numbers that come in but
you can see that this is a smart
decision for the bank to use a tool like
this to help them to predict how good
their profit is going to be off of the
loan balances and how many are going to
default or not so why random forest it's
always important to understand
why we use this tool over the other ones
what are the benefits here and so with
the random forest the first one is
there's no overfitting if you use of
multiple trees reduce the risk of
overfitting training time is less
overfitting means that we have fit the
data so close to what we have as our
sample that we pick up on all the weird
parts and instead of predicting the
overall data you're predicting the weird
stuff which you don't want
high accuracy runs efficiently in large
database for large data it produces
highly accurate predictions
in today's world of big data this is
really important and this is probably
where it really shines this is where why
random forest really comes in it
estimates missing data data in today's
world is very messy so when you have a
random forest it can maintain the
accuracy when a large proportion of the
data is missing what that means is if
you have data that comes in from five or
six different areas and maybe they took
one set of statistics in one area
and they took a slightly different set
of statistics in the other so they have
some of the same same shared data but
one is missing like the number of
children in the house if you're doing
something over demographics and the
other one is missing the size of the
house it will look at both of those
separately and build two different trees
and then it can do a very good job of
guessing which one fits better even
though it's missing that data let us dig
deep into the theory of exactly how it
works
and let's look at what is a random
forest
random forest or random decision forest
is a method that operates by
constructing multiple decision trees the
decision of the majority of the trees is
chosen by the random forest as a final
decision and this uh we have some nice
graphics here we have a decision tree
and they actually use a real tree to
denote the decision tree which i love
and given a random some kind of picture
of a fruit this decision tree decides
that the output is it's an apple and we
have a decision tree two where we have
that picture of the fruit goes in and
this one decides that it's a lemon and
the decision three tree gets another
image and it decides it's an apple and
then this all comes together in what
they call the random forest and this
random forest then looks at it and says
okay i got two votes for apple one vote
for lemon the majority is apples so the
final decision is apples to understand
how the random forest works we first
need to dig a little deeper and take a
look at the random forest and the actual
decision tree and how it builds that
decision tree in looking closer at how
the individual decision trees work we'll
go ahead and continue to use the fruit
example since we're talking about trees
and forests a decision tree is a tree
shaped diagram used to determine a
course of action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction so in here we
have a bowl of fruit and if you look at
that it looks like they switched from
lemons to oranges we have oranges
cherries and apples and the first
decision of the decision tree might be
is a diameter greater than or equal to
three and if it says false it knows that
they're cherries because everything else
is bigger than that so all the cherries
fall into that decision so we have all
that data we're training we can look at
that we know that that's what's going to
come up
is the color orange well goes hmm orange
or red well if it's true
then it comes out as the orange and if
it's false that leaves apples
so in this example it sorts out the
fruit in the bowl or the images of the
fruit a decision tree these are very
important terms to know because these
are very central to understanding the
decision tree when working with them the
first is entropy
everything on the decision tree and how
it makes the decision is based on
entropy entropy is a measure of
randomness or unpredictability in the
data set
then they also have information gain
the leaf node the decision node and the
root node we'll cover these other four
terms as we go down the tree but let's
start with entropy
so starting with entropy we have here a
high amount of randomness what that
means is that whatever is coming out of
this decision if it was going to guess
based on this data
it wouldn't be able to tell you whether
it's a lemon or an apple it would just
say it's a fruit
so the first thing we want to do is we
want to split this apart and we take the
initial data set we're going to create a
data set 1 and a data set 2 we just
split it into and if you look at these
new
data sets after splitting them the
entropy of each of those sets is much
less
so for the first one whatever comes in
there it's going to sort that data and
it's going to say okay if this data goes
this direction it's probably an apple
and if it goes into the other direction
it's probably a lemon so that brings us
up to information gain it is the measure
of decrease in the entropy after the
data set is split what that means in
here is that we've gone from
one set which has a very high entropy to
two lower sets of entropy and we've
added in the values of e1 for the first
one and e2 for the second two which are
much lower and so that information gain
is increased greatly in this example and
so you can find that the information
grain simply equals
decision e1
minus e2 as we're going down our list of
definitions we'll look at the leaf node
and the leaf node
carries the classification or the
decision
so we look down here to the leaf node we
finally get to our set one or our set
two
when it comes down there and it says
okay this object's gone into set one
if it's gone into set one
it's going to be split by some means and
we'll either end up with apples on the
leaf node or a lemon on the leaf node
and on the right it'll either be an
apple or lemons those leaf nodes are
those final decisions or classifications
that's the definition of leaf node in
here if we're going to have a final leaf
where we make the decision
we should have a name for the nodes
above it and they call those decision
nodes
a decision node decision node has two or
more branches and you can see here where
we have the
five apples and one lemon and in the
other case the five lemons and one apple
they have to make a choice of which tree
it goes down
based on some kind of measurement or
information given to the tree
and that brings us to our last
definition
the root node the top most decision node
is known as the root node and this is
where you have all of your data and you
have your first decision it has to make
or the first split in information
so far we've looked at a very general
image
with the fruit being split let's look
and see exactly what that means to split
the data and how do we make those
decisions on there let's go in there and
find out how does a decision tree work
so let's try to understand this and
let's use a simple example and we'll
stay with the fruit we have a bowl of
fruit and so let's create a problem
statement and the problem is we want to
classify the different types of fruits
in the bowl based on different features
the data set in the bowl is looking
quite messy and the entropy is high in
this case so if this ball was our
decision maker it wouldn't know what
choice to make it has so many choices
which one do you pick apple
grapes or lemons and so we look in here
we're going to start with the dra a
training set
so this is our data that we're training
our data with and we have a number of
options here we have the color and under
the color we have red yellow purple
we have a diameter
three three one three three one and we
have a label apple lemon grapes apple
lemon grapes and how do we split the
data we have to frame the conditions to
split the data in such a way that the
information gain is the highest
it's very key to note that we're looking
for the best gain we don't want to just
start sorting out the smallest piece in
there we want to split it the biggest
way we can and so we measure this
decrease in entropy that's what they
call it entropy there's our entropy
after splitting and now we'll try to
choose a condition that gives us the
highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking the gain that we get out of
them the conditions that give us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split so let's take a look at
these different conditions we have color
we have diameter and if we look
underneath that we have a couple
different values we have diameter equals
3 color equals yellow red diameter
equals one and when we look at that
you'll see over here we have one two
three four threes that's a pretty hearty
selection so let's say the condition
gives us a maximum gain of three so we
have the most pieces fall into
that range so our first split from our
decision node is we split the data based
on the diameter is it greater than or
equal to three if it's not that's false
it goes into the grape bowl and if it's
true it goes into a bowl fold of lemon
and apples the entropy after splitting
has decreased considerably so now we can
make two decisions if you look at
they're very
much less chaos going on there this node
has already attained an entropy value of
0 as you can see there's only one kind
of label left for this branch so no
further splitting is required for this
node however this node on the right is
still requires a split to decrease the
entropy further so we split the right
node further based on color if you look
at this if i split it on color that
pretty much cuts it right down the
middle it's the only thing we have left
in our choices of color and diameter too
and if the color is yellow it's going to
go to the ripe bowl and if it's false
it's going to go to the left bowl so the
entropy in this case is now zero so now
we have three bowls with zero entropy
there's only one type of data in each
one of those bowls
so we can predict a lemon with a hundred
percent accuracy and we can predict the
apple also with 100 accuracy along with
our grapes up there so we've looked at
kind of a basic tree in our forest but
what we really want to know is how does
a random forest work as a whole so to
begin our
random forest classifier let's say we
already have built three trees and we're
going to start with the first tree that
looks like this
just like we did in the example this
tree looks at the diameter if it's
greater than or equal to three
it's true otherwise it's false so one
side goes to the smaller diameter one
side goes to larger diameter and if the
color is orange
it's going to go to the right true we're
using oranges now instead of lemons and
if it's red it's going to go to the left
false we build a second tree very
similar but split differently instead of
the first one being split by a diameter
this one when they created it if you
look at that first bowl it has a lot of
red objects so it says is the color red
because that's going to bring our
entropy down the fastest and so of
course if it's true it goes to the left
if it's false it goes to the right and
then it looks at the shape false or true
and so on and so on and tree three is
the diameter equal to one and it came up
with this because there's a lot of
cherries in this bowl so that would be
the biggest split on there is is the
diameter equal to one that's going to
drop the entropy the quickest and as you
can see it splits it into true if it
goes false and they've added another
category does it grow in the summer and
if it's false
it goes off to the left if it's true it
goes off to the right let's go ahead and
bring these three trees you can see them
all in one image so this would be three
completely different trees categorizing
a fruit and let's take a fruit now let's
try this and this fruit if you look at
it we've blackened it out you can't see
the color on it so it's missing data
remember one of the things we talked
about earlier is that a random forest
works really good if you're missing data
if you're missing pieces so this fruit
has an image but maybe as a person had a
black and white camera when they took
the picture and we're going to take a
look at this and it's going to have they
put the color in there so ignore the
color down there but the diameter equals
3 we find out it grows in the summer
equals yes and the shape is a circle and
if you go to the right you can look at
what one of the decision trees did this
is the third one
is the diameter greater than equal to
three is the color orange well it
doesn't really know on this one but if
you look at the value it'd say true and
go to the right tree two classifies it
as cherries is the color equal red
is the shape of circle true it is a
circle so this would look at it and say
oh that's a cherry and then we go to the
other classifier and it says is the
diameter equal one well that's false
does it grow in the summer true so it
goes down and looks at as oranges so how
does this random forest work the first
one says it's an orange
the second one said it was a cherry and
the third one says it's an orange
and you can guess that if you have two
oranges and one says it's a cherry when
you add that all together the majority
of the vote says orange so the answer is
it's classified as an orange even though
we didn't know the color and we're
missing data on it i don't know about
you but i'm getting tired of fruit so
let's switch and i did promise you we'd
start looking at a case example and get
into some python coding today we're
going to use the case the iris flower
analysis
this is the exciting part as we roll up
our sleeves and actually look at some
python coding before we start the python
coding we need to go ahead and create a
problem statement wonder what species of
iris do these flowers belong to let's
try to predict the species of the
flowers using machine learning in python
let's see how it can be done so here we
begin to go ahead and implement our
python code and you'll find that the
first half of our implementation is all
about organizing and exploring the data
coming in let's go ahead and take this
first step which is loading the
different modules into python and let's
go ahead and put that in our favorite
editor whatever your favorite editor is
in this case i'm going to be using the
anaconda jupiter notebook which is one
of my favorites certainly there's
notepad plus plus and eclipse and dozens
of others or just even using the python
terminal window any of those will work
just fine to go ahead and explore this
python coding so here we go let's go
ahead and flip over to our jupiter
notebook and i've already opened up a
new page for python 3 code and i'm just
going to paste this right in there and
let's take a look and see what we're
bringing into our python the first thing
we're going to do is from the
sklearn.datasets
import load iris now this isn't the
actual data this is just the module that
allows us to bring in the data the load
iris and the iris is so popular it's
been around since 1936 when ronald
fisher published a paper on it and
they're measuring the different parts of
the flower and based on those
measurements predicting what kind of
flower it is and then if we're going to
do a random forest classifier we need to
go ahead and import a random forest
classifier from the sk learn module so
sklearn dot ensemble import random force
classifier and then we want to bring in
two more modules
and these are probably the most commonly
used modules in python and data science
with any of the
other modules that we bring in and one
is going to be pandas we're going to
import pandas as pd pd is a common term
used for pandas and pandas is basically
creates a data format for us
where when you create a pandas data
frame it looks like an excel spreadsheet
and you'll see that in a minute when we
start digging deeper into the code panda
is just wonderful because it plays nice
with all the other modules in there and
then we have numpy which is our numbers
python and the numbers python allows us
to do different mathematical sets on
here we'll see right off the bat we're
going to take our np and we're going to
go ahead and seed the randomness with it
with 0. so
np.random.seed is seating that is 0.
this code doesn't actually show anything
we're going to go ahead and run it
because i need to make sure i have all
those loaded and then let's take a look
at the next module on here the next six
slides including this one are all about
exploring the data remember i told you
half of this is about looking at the
data and getting it all set so let's go
ahead and take this code right here the
script and let's get that over into our
jupyter notebook and here we go we've
gone ahead and run the imports
and i'm going to paste the code down
here
and let's take a look and see what's
going on the first thing we're doing is
we're actually loading the iris data and
if you remember up here we loaded the
module that tells it how to get the iris
data now we're actually assigning that
data to the variable iris and then we're
going to go ahead and use the df to
define data frame
and that's going to equal pd and if you
remember that's pandas as pd so that's
our pandas and panda data frame and then
we're looking at iris data
and columns equals iris feature names
and we're going to do the df head and
let's run this you can understand what's
going on here
the first thing you want to notice is
that our df has created what looks like
an excel spreadsheet
and in this excel spreadsheet we have
set the columns so up on the top you can
see the four different columns and then
we have the data iris.data down below
it's a little confusing without knowing
where this data is coming from so let's
look at
the bigger picture and i'm going to go
print i'm just going to change this for
a moment and we're going to print all of
iris and see what that looks like so
when i print all of iris i get this long
list of information
and you can scroll through here and see
all the different titles on there
what's important to notice is that first
off there's a brackets at the beginning
so this is a python dictionary
and in a python dictionary
you'll have a key or a label and this
label pulls up whatever information
comes after it so feature names which we
actually used over here under columns is
equal to an array of sepal length sepal
width petal length petal width these are
the different names they have for the
four different columns and if you scroll
down far enough you'll also see data
down here oh goodness it came up right
towards the top and data is equal to the
different data we're looking at
now there's a lot of other things in
here like target we're going to be
pulling that up in a minute and there's
also the names the target names which is
further down and we'll show you that
also in a minute
let's go ahead and set that back
to the head
and this is one of the neat features of
pandas and panda data frames
is when you do df.head or the
pandadataframe.head it'll print the
first five lines of the dataset in there
along with the headers if you have it in
this case we have the column header set
to iris features and in here you'll see
that we have 01234
in python most arrays always start at
zero so when you look at the first five
it's going to be zero one two three four
not one two three four five so now we've
got our iris data imported into a data
frame let's take a look at the next
piece of code in here and so in this
section here of the code
we're going to take a look at the target
and let's go ahead and get this into our
notebook this piece of code so we can
discuss it a little bit more in detail
so here we are in our jupyter notebook
i'm going to put the code in here and
before i run it
i want to look at a couple things going
on so we have df species
and this is interesting because right
here you'll see where i have df species
in brackets which is uh the key code for
creating another column and here we have
iris.target now these are both in the
pandas setup on here so in pandas we can
do either one i could have just as
easily done iris and then in brackets
target depending on what i'm working on
both are acceptable
let's go ahead and run this code and see
how this changes and what we've done is
we've added the target from the iris
data set
as another column on the end
now what species is this is what we're
trying to predict so we have our data
which tells us the answer for all these
different pieces and then we've added a
column with the answer that way when we
do our final setup we'll have the
ability to program our neural network to
look for these this different data and
know what a setosa is or a vera color
which we'll see in just a minute or
virginica those are the three that are
in there and now we're going to add one
more column i know we're organizing all
this data over and over again it's kind
of fun there's a lot of ways to organize
it what's nice about putting everything
onto one
data frame is i can then do a printout
and it shows me exactly what i'm looking
at and i'll show you where you where
that's different where you can alter
that and do it slightly differently but
let's go ahead and put this into our
script up to that now and here we go
we're going to put that down here
and we're going to run that and let's
talk a little bit about what we're doing
now we're exploring data
and
one of the challenges is knowing how
good your model is did your model work
and to do this we need to split the data
and we split it into two different parts
they usually call it the training and
the testing and so in here we're going
to go ahead and put that in our database
so you can see it clearly and we've set
it df remember you can put brackets this
is creating another column is train so
we're going to use part of it for
training and this equals np remember
that stands for numpy.random.uniform
so we're generating a random number
between 0 and 1. and we're going to do
it for each of the rows that's where the
length df comes from so each row gets a
generated number and if it's less than
0.75 it's true and if it's greater than
0.75 it's false this means we're going
to take
75 percent of the data roughly because
there's a randomness involved and we're
going to use that to train it and then
the other 25 we're going to hold off to
the side and use that to test it later
on so let's flip back on over and see
what the next step is so now that we've
labeled our database for which is
training and which is testing
let's go ahead and sort that into two
different variables train and test and
let's take this code and let's bring it
into our project and here we go let's
paste it on down here and before i run
this let's just take a quick look at
what's going on here is we have up above
we created remember there's our def dot
head which prints the first five rows
and we've added a column is train at the
end and so we're going to take that
we're going to create two variables
we're going to create two new data
frames one's called train
one's called test 75 and train 25
percent in test
and then to sort that out
we're going to do that by doing df our
main original data frame with the iris
data in it
and if df is trained equals true
that's going to go in the train and if
df is train equals false it goes in the
test
and so when i run this we're going to
print out the number in each one let's
see what that looks like and you'll see
that it puts 118 in the training module
and it puts 32 in the testing module
which lets us know that there was 150
lines of data in here so if you went and
looked at the original data you could
see that there's 150 lines and that's
roughly 75 percent in one and 25 percent
for us to test our model on afterward so
let's jump back to our code and see
where this goes in the next two steps
we want to do one more thing with our
data and that's make it readable to
humans
i don't know about you but i hate
looking at zeros and ones
so let's start with the features and
let's go ahead and
take those and make those readable to
humans and let's put that in our code
let's see here we go paste it in and
you'll see here we've done a couple very
basic things we know that the columns in
our data frame again this is a panda
thing the df columns
and we know the first four of them zero
one two three that'd be the first four
are going to be the features or the
titles of those columns and so when i
run this you'll see down here that it
creates an index sepa length sepa width
pedal length and pedal width and this
should be familiar because if you look
up here here's our column titles going
across and here's the first four
one thing i want you to notice here is
that when you're in a command line
whether it's jupiter notebook or you're
running command line in the terminal
window if you just put the name of it
it'll print it out this is the same as
doing print
features
and the shorthand is you just put
features in here if you're actually
writing a code
and saving the script and running it by
remote you really need to put the print
in there but for this when i run it
you'll see it gives me the same thing
but for this we want to go ahead and
we'll just leave it as features because
it doesn't really matter and this is one
of the fun thing about jupiter notebooks
is i'm just building the code as we go
and then we need to go ahead and create
the labels for the other part so let's
take a look and see what that
for our final step in prepping our data
before we actually start running the
training and the testing is we're going
to go ahead and convert the species on
here into something the computer
understands so let's put this code into
our script and see where that takes us
all right here we go we've set y equal
to pd dot factorize
train species of zero
so let's break this down just a little
bit we have our pandas right here pd
factorize what's factorized doing i'm
going to come back to that in just a
second
let's look at what train species is
and why we're looking at the group 0 on
there and let's go up here and here is
our species
remember this on that we created this
whole column here for species
and then it has setosa setosa setosa
setosa and if you scroll down enough
you'd also see virginica and veracolor
we need to convert that into something
the computer understands zeros and ones
so the train species
of zero because this is in the format of
a of an array of arrays so you have to
have the zero on the end and then
species is just that column factorize
goes in there looks at the fact that
there's only three of them so when i run
this you'll see that y generates an
array that's equal to in this case it's
the training set and it's zeros ones and
twos representing the three different
kinds of flowers we have
so now we have something the computer
understands and we have a nice table
that we can read and understand and now
finally we get to actually start doing
the predicting so here we go
we have
two lines of code oh my goodness that
was a lot of work to get to two lines of
code but there is a lot in these two
lines of code so let's take a look and
see what's going on here and put this
into our full script that we're running
and let's paste this in here and let's
take a look and see what this is we have
we're creating a variable clf and we're
going to set this equal to the random
forest classifier and we're passing two
variables in here and there's a lot of
variables you can play with as far as
these two are concerned they're very
standard
in jobs all that does is to prioritize
it not something to really worry about
usually when you're doing this on your
own computer you do in jobs equals two
if you're working in a larger or big
data and you need to prioritize it
differently this is what that number
does is it changes your priorities and
how it's going to run across the system
and things like that and then the random
state is just how it starts
zero is fine for here
but let's go ahead and run this
we also have clf.fit train features
comma y and before we run it let's talk
about this a little bit more clf
dot fit so we're fitting we're training
it we are actually creating our random
forest classifier right here this is a
code that does everything and we're
going to take our training set remember
we kept our test off to the side and
we're going to take our training set
with the features and then we're going
to go ahead and put that in and here's
our target the y
so the y is 0 1 and 2 that we just
created and the features is the actual
data going in that we put into the
training set let's go ahead and run that
and this is kind of an interesting thing
because it printed out the random force
classifier
and everything around it
and so when you're running this in your
terminal window or in a script like this
this automatically treats this like just
like when we were up here and i typed in
y and printed out y instead of print y
this does the same thing it treats this
as a variable and prints it out but if
you're actually running your code that
wouldn't be the case and what is printed
out is it shows us all the different
variables we can change and if we go
down here you can actually see in jobs
equals two
you can see the random state equals zero
those are the two that we sent in there
you would really have to dig deep to
find out all these the different
meanings of all these different settings
on here some of them are
self-explanatory if you kind of think
about it a little bit like max features
as auto so all the features that we're
putting in there is just gonna
automatically take all four of them
whatever we send it it'll take some of
them might have so many features because
you're processing words there might be
like 1.4 million features in there
because you're doing legal documents and
that's how many different words are in
there at that point you probably want to
limit the maximum features that you're
going to process and leaf nodes that's
the end nodes remember we had the fruit
and we're talking about the leaf nodes
like i said there's a lot in this we're
looking at a lot of stuff here so you
might have in this case there's probably
only think three leaf nodes maybe four
you might have thousands of leaf nodes
at which point you do need to put a cap
on that and say okay it can only go so
far and then we're going to use all of
our resources on processing this
and that really is what most of these
are about is limiting the process and
making sure we don't overwhelm a system
and there's some other settings in here
again we're not going to go over all of
them warm start equals false form start
is if you're programming it one piece at
a time externally since we're not we're
not going to have like we're not going
to continually train this particular
learning tree and again like i said
there's a lot of things in here that
you'll want to look up more detail from
the sk learn and if you're digging in
deep and running a major project on here
for today though all we need to do is
fit our train our features and our
target y so now we have our training
model what's next if we're going to
create a model
we now need to test it remember we set
aside the test feature test group 25 of
the data so let's go ahead and take this
code and let's put it into our script
and see what that looks like okay here
we go
and we're going to run this
and it's going to come out with a bunch
of zeros ones and twos which represents
the three type of flowers the setosa the
virginica and the versa color and what
we're putting into our predict is the
test features
and i always kind of like to know what
it is i am looking at
so real quick we're going to do test
features and remember features is an
array
of sepal length simple width pedal
length pedal width so when we put it in
this way it actually loads all these
different columns that we loaded into
features so if we did just features let
me just do features in here seeing what
features looks like
this is just playing with the with
pandas data frames you'll see that it's
an index so when you put an index in
like this
into test features into test
it then takes those columns and creates
a panda data frames from those columns
and in this case
we're going to go ahead and put those
into our predict
so we're going to put each one of these
lines of data
the 5.0 3.4 1.5.2
and we're going to put those in and
we're going to predict
what our
new
forest classifier is going to come up
with and this is what it predicts it
predicts
zero zero zero one two one one two two
two and and uh again this is the
flower type setosa virginica and
versacolor so now that we've taken our
test features
let's explore that let's see exactly
what that data means to us so the first
thing we can do with our predicts is we
can actually generate a different
prediction model when i say different
we're going to view it differently it's
not that the data itself is different so
let's take this next piece of code and
put it into our script
so we're pasting it in here and you'll
see that we're doing uh predict and
we've added underscore proba for
probability so there's our clf dot
predict probability so we're running it
just like we ran it up here but this
time with this we're going to get a
slightly different result and we're only
going to look at the first 10.
so you'll see down here instead of
looking at all of them
which was what 27 you'll see right down
here that this generates a much larger
field on the probability and let's take
a look and see what that looks like
and what that means
so when we do the predict underscore
prabha
for probability it generates three
numbers so we had three leaf nodes at
the end and if you remember from all the
theory we did
this is the predictors the first one is
predicting a one for setosa it predicts
a 0 for virginica and it predicts a 0
for versa color and so on and so on and
so on and let's um you know what i'm
going to change this just a little bit
let's look at 10
to 20 just because we can
and we start to get a little different
of data and you'll see right down here
it gets to this one this line right here
and this line has 0 0.5 0.5
and so if we're going to vote and we
have two equal votes it's going to go
with the first one so it says uh setosa
gets zero votes virginica gets .5 votes
versus color gets 0.5 votes but let's
just go with the virginica since these
two are equal and so on and so on down
the list you can see how they vary on
here so now we've looked at both how to
do a basic predict of the features and
we've looked at the predict probability
let's see what's next on here so now we
want to go ahead and start mapping names
for the plants we want to attach names
so that it makes a little more sense for
us and this we're going to do in these
next two steps we're going to start by
setting up our predictions and mapping
them to the name so let's see what that
looks like
and let's go ahead and paste that code
in here and run it and this goes along
with the next piece of code so we'll
skip through this quickly and then come
back to a little bit so here's iris
dot target names
and uh if you remember correctly this
was the the names that we've been
talking about this whole time the setosa
virginica versus color and then we're
going to go ahead and do the prediction
again we've run that we could have just
set a variable equal to this instead of
re-running it each time but we'll go
ahead and run it again clf dot predict
test features remember that returns the
zeros the ones and the twos and then
we're going to set that equal to
predictions so this time we're actually
putting it in a variable and when i run
this
it distributes it it comes out as an
array and the array is setosa satosa
satoshi satosa setosa we're only looking
at the first five we could actually do
let's do the first 25 just so we can see
a little bit more on there and you'll
see that it starts mapping it to all the
different flower types the versa color
and the virginica in there and let's see
how this goes with the next one so let's
take a look at the top part of our
species in here and we'll take this code
and put it in our script
and let's put that down here and paste
it there we go and we'll go ahead and
run it
and let's talk about both these sections
of code here
and how they go together
the first one is our predictions and i
went ahead and did uh predictions
through 25 let's just do five
and so we have setosa satoshi satosa
satoshi that's what we're predicting
from our test model
and then we come down here we look at
test species i remember i could have
just done test dot species dot head and
you'll see it says satoshi satosa
satoshi satosa and they match
so the first one is what our
forest is doing
and the second one is what the actual
data is now is we need to combine these
so that we can understand what that
means we need to know how good our
forest is how good it is at predicting
the features so that's where we come up
to the next step which is lots of fun
we're going to use a single line of code
to combine our predictions and our
actuals so we have a nice chart to look
at and let's go ahead and put that in
our script in our jupyter notebook here
let's see let's go ahead and paste that
in and then i'm going to because i'm on
the jupiter notebook i can do a control
minus so you can see the whole line
there
there we go resize it
and let's take a look and see what's
going on here we're going to create in
pandas remember pd stands for pandas
and we're doing a cross tab this
function takes two sets of data
and creates a chart out of them so when
i run it you'll get a nice chart down
here
and we have the predicted species
so across the top you'll see the setosa
versus color virginica and the actual
species setosa versacolor virginica and
so the way to read this chart and let's
go ahead and take a look on how to read
this chart here when you read this chart
you have setosa where they meet you have
versus color where they meet and you
have virginica where they meet and
they're meeting where the actual and the
predicted agree
so this is the number of accurate
predictions so in this case it equals
30. if you add 13 plus 5 plus 12 you get
30. and then we notice here where it
says virginica but it was supposed to be
versacolor this is inaccurate so now we
have two two inaccurate predictions and
30 accurate predictions so we'll say
that the model accuracy is 93 that's
just 30 divided by 32 and if we multiply
it by a hundred we can say that it is 93
accurate so we have a 93 accuracy with
our model i did want to add one more
quick thing in here on our scripting
before we wrap it up so let's flip back
on over to my script in here we're going
to take this line of code from up above
i don't know if you remember it but
predicts equals the iris dot target
underscore names
so we're going to map it to the names
and we're going to run the prediction
and we read it on test features but you
know we're not just testing it we want
to actually deploy it so at this point i
would go ahead and change this
and this is an array of arrays this is
really important when you're running
these to know that
so you need the double brackets and i
could actually create data maybe let's
just do two flowers so maybe i'm
processing more data coming in and we'll
put two flowers in here
and then i actually want to see what the
answer are is so let's go ahead and type
in preds and print that out and when i
run this you'll see that i've now
predicted two flowers that maybe i
measured in my front yard as versacolor
and versacolor
not surprising since i put the same data
in for each one
this would be the actual
end product going out to be used on data
that you don't know the answer for
let's take a detour and see if we can
connect us to the human experience and
find out why support vector machine so
in this example last week my son and i
visited a fruit shop dad is that an
apple or a strawberry so the question
comes up what fruit do they just pick up
from the fruit stand after a couple of
seconds you could figure out that it was
a strawberry so let's take this model a
step further and let's uh why not build
a model which can predict an unknown
data and in this we're going to be
looking at some sweet strawberries or
crispy apples we want to be able to
label those two and decide what the
fruit is and we do that by having data
already put in so we already have a
bunch of strawberries we know our
strawberries and they're already labeled
as such we already have a bunch of
apples we know our apples and are
labeled as such then once we train our
model that model then can be given the
new data and the new data is this image
in this case you can see a question mark
on it and it comes through and goes it's
a strawberry in this case we're using
the support vector machine model svm is
a supervised learning method that looks
at data and sorts it into one of two
categories and in this case we're
sorting the strawberry into the
strawberry site at this point you should
be asking the question how does the
prediction work before we dig into an
example with numbers let's apply this to
our fruit scenario we have our support
vector machine we've taken it and we've
taken labeled sample of data
strawberries and apples and we draw on a
line down the middle between the two
groups this split now allows us to take
new data in this case an apple and a
strawberry and place them in the
appropriate group based on which side of
the line they fall in and that way we
can predict the unknown as colorful and
tasty as the fruit example is let's take
a look at another example with some
numbers involved and we can take a
closer look at how the math works in
this example we're going to be
classifying men and women and we're
going to start with a set of people with
a different height and a different
weight and to make this work we'll have
to have a sample data set of female
where you have their height and weight
174 65 174 88 and so on and we'll need a
sample data set of the male they have a
height 179 90 180 to 80 and so on let's
go ahead and put this on a graph so we
have a nice visual so you can see here
we have two groups based on the height
versus the weight and on the left side
we're going to have the women on the
right side we're going to have the men
now if we're going to create a
classifier let's add a new data point
and figure out if it's male or female so
before we can do that we need to split
our data first we can split our data by
choosing any of these lines in this case
we draw on two lines through the data in
the middle that separates them in from
the women but to predict the gender of a
new data point we should split the data
in the best possible way and we say the
best possible way because this line has
a maximum space that separates the two
classes here you can see there's a clear
split between the two different classes
and in this one there's not so much a
clear split this doesn't have the
maximum space that separates the two
that is why this line best splits the
data we don't want to just do this by
eyeballing it and before we go further
we need to add some technical terms to
this we can also say that the distance
between the points in the line should be
as far as possible in technical terms we
can say the distance between the support
vector and the hyperplane should be as
far as possible and this is where the
support vectors are the extreme points
in the data set and if you look at this
data set they have circled two points
which seem to be right on the outskirts
of the woman and one on the outskirts of
the men and hyperplane has a maximum
distance to the support vectors of any
class now you'll see the line down the
middle and we call this the hyperplane
because when you're dealing with
multiple dimensions it's really not just
a line but a plane of intersections and
you can see here where the support
vectors have been drawn in dashed lines
the math behind this is very simple we
take d plus the shortest distance to the
closest positive point which would be on
the min side and d minus is the shortest
distance to the closest negative point
which is on the women's side the sum of
d plus and d minus is called the
distance margin or the distance between
the two support vectors that are shown
in the dashed lines and then by finding
the largest distance margin we can get
the optimal hyperplane once we've
created an optimal hyperplane we can
easily see which side the new data fits
in and based on the hyperplane we can
say the new data point belongs to the
male gender hopefully that's clear how
that works on a visual level as a data
scientist you should also be asking what
happens if the hyperplane is not optimal
if we select a hyperplane having low
margin then there is a high chance of
misclassification this particular svm
model the one we discussed so far is
also called referred to as the ls vm so
far so clear but a question should be
coming up we have our sample data set
but instead of looking like this what if
it looked like this where we have two
sets of data but one of them occurs in
the middle of another set you can see
here where we have the blue and the
yellow and then blue again on the other
side of our data line in this data set
we can't use a hyperplane so when you
see data like this it's necessary to
move away from a 1d view of the data to
a two dimensional view of the data and
for the transformation we use what's
called a kernel function the kernel
function will take the 1d input and
transfer it to a two dimensional output
as you can see in this picture here the
1d when transferred to a 2-dimensional
makes it very easy to draw a line
between the two data sets what if we
make it even more complicated how do we
perform an svm for this type of data set
here you can see we have a two
dimensional data set where the data is
in the middle surrounded by the green
data on the outside in this case we're
going to segregate the two classes we
have our sample data set and if you draw
a line through it's obviously not an
optimal hyperplane in there so to do
that we need to transfer the 2d to a 3d
array and when you translate it into a
three-dimensional array using the kernel
you can see where you can place a
hyperplane right through it and easily
split the data before we start looking
at a programming example and dive into
the script let's look at the advantage
of the support vector machine we'll
start with high dimensional input space
or sometimes referred to as the curse of
dimensionality we looked at earlier one
dimension two dimension three dimension
when you get to a thousand dimensions a
lot of problems start occurring with
both algorithms that have to be adjusted
for the svm automatically does that in
high dimensional space one of the high
dimensional space one high dimensional
space that we work on is sparse document
vectors this is where we tokenize the
words and document so we can run our
machine learning algorithms over them
i've seen ones get as high as 2.4
million different tokens that's a lot of
vectors to look at and finally we have
regularization parameter the realization
parameter or lambda is a parameter that
helps figure out whether we're going to
have a bias or overfitting of the data
whether it's going to be overfitted to a
very specific instance or is going to be
biased to a high or low value with the
svm it naturally avoids the overfitting
and bias problems that we see in many
other algorithms these three advantages
of the support vector machine make it a
very powerful tool to add to your
repertoire of machine learning tools now
we did promise you a used case study
we're actually going to dive into some
python programming and so we're going to
go into a problem statement and start
off with the zoo so in the zoo example
we have family members going to the zoo
we have the young child going dead is
that a group of crocodiles or alligators
well that's hard to differentiate and
zoos are a great place to start looking
at science and understanding how things
work especially as a young child and so
we can see the parents sitting here
thinking well what is the difference
between a crocodile and an alligator
well one crocodiles are larger in size
alligators are smaller in size snout
width the crocodiles have a narrow snout
and alligators have a wider snout and of
course in the modern day and age the
father is sitting here thinking how can
i turn this into a lesson for my son and
he goes let a support vector machine
segregate the two groups i don't know if
my dad ever told me that but that would
be funny now in this example we're not
going to use actual measurements and
data we're just using that for imagery
and that's very common in a lot of
machine learning algorithms and setting
them up but let's roll up our sleeves
we'll talk about that more in just a
moment as we break into our python
script so here we arrive in our actual
coding and i'm going to move this into a
python editor in just a moment but let's
talk a little bit about what we're going
to cover first we're going to cover in
the code the setup how to actually
create our svm and you're going to find
that there's only two lines of code that
actually create it and the rest of it is
done so quick and fast that it's all
here in the first page and we'll show
you what that looks like as far as our
data because we're going to create some
data i talked about creating data just a
minute ago and so we'll get into the
creating data here and you'll see this
nice correction of our two blobs and
we'll go through that in just a second
and then the second part is we're going
to take this and we're going to bump it
up a notch we're going to show you what
it looks like behind the scenes but
let's start with actually creating our
setup i like to use the anaconda jupiter
notebook because it's very easy to use
but you can use any of your favorite
python editors or setups and go in there
but let's go ahead and switch over there
and see what that looks like so here we
are in the anaconda python notebook or
anaconda jupiter notebook with python
we're using python 3. i believe this is
in any of your 3x versions and
you'd have to look at the sklearn and
make sure if you're using a 2x version
an earlier version let's go and put our
code in there and one of the things i
like about the jupyter notebook is i go
up to view and i'm going to go ahead and
toggle the line numbers on to make it a
little bit easier to talk about and we
can even increase the size because this
is edited in this case i'm using google
chrome explorer and that's how it opens
up for the editor although anyone any
like i said any editor will work now the
first step is going to be our imports
and we're going to import four different
parts the first two i want you to look
at our line one and line two are numpy
as np and matplotlife p and matplot
library dot pi plot as plt now these are
very standardized imports when you're
doing work the first one is the numbers
python we need that because part of the
platform we're using uses that for the
numpy array and i'll talk about that in
a minute so you can understand why we
want to use a numpy array versus the
standard python array and normally it's
pretty standard setup to use np for
numpy the map plot library is how we're
going to view our data so this has uh
you do need the np for the sk learn
module but the map plot library is
purely for our use for visualization and
so you really don't need that for the
svm but we're going to put it there so
you have a nice visual aid and we can
show you what it looks like that's
really important at the end when you
finish everything so you have a nice
display for everybody to look at and
then finally we're going to i'm going to
jump one ahead to line number four
that's the sklearn.datasets
import and make blobs and i told you
that we were going to make up data and
this is a tool that's in the sk learning
to makeup data i personally don't want
to go to the zoo get in trouble for
jumping over the fence and probably get
eaten by the crocodiles or alligators as
i work on measuring their snouts and
width and length
instead we're just going to make up some
data and that's what that make blobs is
it's a wonderful tool if you're ready to
test your
setup and you're not sure about what
data you're going to put in there you
can create this blob and it makes it
real easy to use and finally we have our
actual svm the sklearn import svm on
line three so that covers all our
imports we're going to create remember i
use the make blobs to create data and
we're going to create a capital x and a
lowercase y equals make blobs in samples
equals 40. so we're going to make 40
lines of data it's going to have two
centers with a random state equals 20.
so each each each group is going to have
20 different pieces of data in it and
the way that it looks is that we'll have
under x
an x y plane so i have two numbers under
x and y will be 0 1. that's the two
different centers so we have yes or no
in this case alligator or crocodile
that's what that represents and then i
told you that the actual sk learner the
svm is in two lines of code and we see
it right here with clf equals
svm.svc kernel equals linear and i set
sql to one although in this example
since we are not regularizing the data
because we want it to be very clear and
easy to see i went ahead you can set it
to a thousand a lot of times when you're
not doing that but for this thing linear
because it's a very simple linear
example we only have the two dimensions
and it'll be a nice linear hyperplane
it'll be a nice linear line instead of a
full plane so we're not dealing with a
huge amount of data and then all we have
to do is do clf dot fit x comma y and
that's it clf has been created and then
we're going to go ahead and display it
and i'm going to talk about this display
here in just a second but let me go
ahead and run this code and this is what
we've done is we've created two blobs
you'll see the blue on the side and then
kind of an orangish
on the other side that's our two sets of
data they represent one represents
crocodiles and one represents alligators
and then we have our measurements in
this case we have like the width and
length of the snout and i did say i was
going to come up here and talk just a
little bit about our plot and you'll see
plt that's what we imported we're going
to do a scatter plot that means we're
just putting dots on there and then look
at this notation i have the capital x
and then in brackets i have a colon
comma 0. that's from numpy if you did
that in a regular array you'll get an
error in a python array you have to have
that in a numpy array it turns out that
our make blobs returns a numpy array and
this notation is great because what it
means is the first part is the colon
means we're going to do all the rows
that's all the data in our blob we
created under capital x and then the
second part has a comma 0. we're only
going to take the first value and then
if you notice we do the same thing but
we're going to take the second value
remember we always start with zero and
then one so we have column zero and
column one and you can look at this as
our x y plots the first one is the x
plot and the second one is the y plot so
the first one is on the bottom 0 2 4 6 8
and 10 and then the second one x of the
one is the 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 going up the
left hand side s equals 30 is just the
size of the dot so we can see them and
said real tiny dots and then the c map
equals plt.cm.paired
and you'll also see the c equals y
that's the color we're using two colors
zero one and that's why we get the nice
blue and the two different colors for
the alligator and the crocodile now you
can see here that we did this the actual
uh fit was done in two lines of code a
lot of times it'll be a third line where
we regularize the data we set it between
like minus one and one and we reshape it
but for this it's not necessary and it's
also kind of nice because you can
actually see what's going on and then if
we wanted to we wanted to actually run a
prediction let's take a look and see
what that looks like and to predict some
new data and we'll show this again as we
get towards the end of digging in deep
you can simply assign your new data in
this case i am giving it a width and
length 3 4 and a width and length 5 6.
and note that i put the data as a set of
brackets and then i have the brackets
inside and the reason i do that is
because when we're looking at data it's
designed to process a large amount of
data coming in we don't want to just
process one line at a time and so in
this case i'm processing two lines and
then i'm just going to print and you'll
see clf.predict new data so the clf and
the dot predict part is going to give us
an answer and let's see what that looks
like and you'll see 0 1 so predicted the
first one the 3 4 is going to be on the
one side and the 5 6 is going to be on
the other side so one came out as an
alligator and one came out as a
crocodile now that's pretty short
explanation for the setup but really we
want to dug in and see what it's going
on behind the scenes and let's see what
that looks like
so the next step is to dig in deep and
find out what's going on behind the
scenes and also put that in a nice
pretty graph
we're going to spend more work on this
and we did actually generating the
original model and you'll see here that
we go through a few steps and i'll move
this over to our editor in just a second
we come in we create our original data
it's exactly identical to the first part
and i'll explain why we redid that and
show you how not to redo that and then
we're going to go in there and add in
those lines we're going to see what
those lines look like and how to set
those up and finally we're going to plot
all that on here and show it and you'll
get a nice graph with the what we saw
earlier when we were going through the
theory behind this where it shows the
support vectors and the hyperplane and
those are done where you can see the
support vectors as the dashed lines and
the solid line which is the hyperplane
let's get that into our jupiter notebook
before i scroll down to a new line i
want you to notice line 13 has plot show
and we're going to talk about that here
in just a second but let's scroll down
to a new line down here and i'm going to
paste that code in and you'll see that
the plot show has moved down below let's
scroll up a little bit and if you look
at the top here of our new section one
two three and four is the same code we
had before and let's go back up here and
take a look at that we're going to fit
the values on our svm and then we're
going to plot scatter it and then we're
going to do a plot show so you should be
asking why are we redoing the same code
well when you do the plot show that
blanks out what's in the plot so once
i've done this plot show i have to
reload that data now we could do this
simply by removing it up here re-running
it and then coming down here and then we
wouldn't have to rerun these first four
lines of code now in this it doesn't
matter too much and you'll see the plot
show was down here and then removed
right there on line five i'll go ahead
and just delete that out of there
because we don't want to blank out our
screen we want to move on to the next
setup so we can go ahead and just skip
the first four lines because we did that
before and let's take a look at the ax
equals plt.gca
now right now we're actually spending a
lot of time just graphing that's all
we're doing here okay so this is how we
display a nice graph with our results in
our data ax is very standard used
variable when you talk about plt and
it's just setting it to that axis the
last axis in the plt it can get very
confusing if you're working with many
different layers of data on the same
graph and this makes it very easy to
reference the ax so this reference is
looking at the plt that we created and
we already mapped out our two blobs on
and then we want to know the limits so
we want to know how big the graph is we
can find out the x limit and the y limit
simply with the get x limit and get y
limit commands which is part of our
metplot library and then we're going to
create a grid and you'll see down here
we have we've set the variable xx equal
to np.line space x limit 0 x limit 1
comma 30 and we've done the same thing
for the y space and then we're going to
go in here and we create a mesh grid and
this is a numpy command so we're back to
our numbers python let's go through what
these numpy commands mean with the line
space and the mesh grid we've taken x x
small s x x equals n p line space and we
have our x limit 0 and our x limit 1 and
we're going to create 30 points on it
and we're going to do the same thing for
the y axis now this has nothing to do
with our evaluation it's all we're doing
is we're creating a grid of data and so
we're creating a set of points between 0
and the x limit we're creating 30 points
and the same thing with the y and then
the mesh grid loops those all together
so it forms a nice grid so if we were
going to do this say between the limit 0
and 10 and do 10 points we would have a
0 0 1 1 0 1 0 2 0 3 0 4 to 10 and so on
you can just imagine a point at each
corner one of those boxes and the mesh
grid combines them all so we take the yy
and the xx we created and creates the
full grid and we've set that grid into
the yy coordinates and the xx
coordinates now remember we're working
with numbi and python we like to
separate those we like to have instead
of it being x comma 1 you know x comma y
and then
x2 comma y2 and this in the next set of
data it would be a column of x's and a
column of y's and that's what we have
here is we have a column of y's and we
put it as a capital yy and a column of
x's capital xx with all those different
points being listed and finally we get
down to the numpy v stack just as we
created those in the mesh grid we're now
going to put them all into one array x y
array now that we've created the stack
of data points we're going to do
something interesting here we're going
to create a value z and the z equals the
clf that's our that's our support vector
machine we created and we've already
trained and we have a dot decision
function and we're going to put the x y
in there so here we have all this data
we're going to put that x y in there
that data and we're going to reshape it
and you'll see that we have the xx dot
shape in here this literally takes the
xx resets it up connected to the y and
the z value lets us know whether it is
the left hand side is going to generate
three different values the z value does
and it'll tell us whether that data is a
support vector to the left the
hyperplane in the middle or the support
vector to the right so it generates
three different values for each of those
points and those points have been
reshaped so they're right on a line on
those three different lines so we've set
all of our data up we've labeled it the
three different areas and we've reshaped
it and we've just taken 30 points in
each direction if you do the math you
have 30 times 30 so that's 900 points of
data and we separated between the three
lines and reshaped it to fit those three
lines we can then go back to our map
plot library we've created the ax and
we're going to create a contour and
you'll see here we have contour capital
xx capital yy these have been reshaped
to fit those lines z is the labels so
now we have the three different points
with the labels in there and we can set
the colors equals k and i told you we
had three different labels but we have
three levels of data the alphas just
makes it kind of see through so it's
only 0.5 of the value in there so when
we graph it the data will show up from
behind it wherever the lines go and
finally the line styles this is where we
set the two support vectors to be dash
dash lines and then a single one is just
a straight line that's what all that
setup does and then finally we take our
ax dot scatter we're going to go ahead
and plot the support vectors but we've
programmed it in there so that they look
nice like the dash dash line and the
dashed line on that grid and you can see
here when we do the clf dot support
vectors we are looking at column zero
and column one and then again we have
the s equals 100 so we're going to make
them larger and the line width equals
one face colors equals none let's take a
look and see what that looks like when
we show it and you can see we get down
to our end result it creates a really
nice graph we have our two support
vectors and dashed lines and they have
the near data so you can see those two
points or in this case the four points
where those lines nicely cleave the data
and then you have your hyperplane down
the middle which is as far from the two
different points as possible creating
the maximum distance so you can see that
we have our nice output for the size of
the body and the width of the snout and
we've easily separated the two groups of
crocodile and alligator congratulations
you've done it we've made it of course
these are pretend data for our
crocodiles and alligators but this
hands-on example will help you to
encounter any support vector machine
projects in the future and you can see
how easy they are to set up and look at
in-depth knn is really a fundamental
place to start in the machine learning
it's the basis of a lot of other things
and just the logic behind it is easy to
understand and incorporated in other
forms of machine learning so today
what's in it for you why do we need k n
n
what is k n
how do we choose the factor k
when do we use k n n
how does k n algorithm work and then
we'll dive in to my favorite part the
use case predict whether a person will
have diabetes or not that is a very
common and popular used data set as far
as testing out models and learning how
to use the different models in machine
learning by now we all know machine
learning models make predictions by
learning from the past data available so
we have our input values our machine
learning model builds on those inputs of
what we already know and then we use
that to create a predicted output
is that a dog a little kid looking over
there
watching the black cat cross their path
no dear you can differentiate between a
cat and a dog based on their
characteristics
cats
cats have sharp claws uses to climb
smaller lengths of ears meows and purrs
doesn't love to play around dogs they
have dull claws bigger length of ears
barks loves to run around you usually
don't see a cat running around people
although i do have a cat that does that
where dogs do and we can look at these
we can say we can evaluate the sharpness
of the claws how sharp are their claws
and we can evaluate the length of the
ears and we can usually sort out cats
from dogs based on even those two
characteristics
now tell me if it is a cat or a dog not
question usually little kids know cats
and dogs by now unless they live a place
where there's not many cats or dogs so
if we look at the sharpness of the claws
the length of the ears and we can see
that the cat has smaller ears and
sharper claws than the other animals its
features are more like cats it must be a
cat sharp claws length of ears and it
goes in the cat group because knn is
based on feature similarity we can do
classification using knn classifier so
we have our input value the picture of
the black cat it goes into our trained
model and it predicts that this is a cat
coming out so what is knn what is the k
n algorithm
k nearest neighbors is what that stands
for is one of the simplest supervised
machine learning algorithms mostly used
for classification so we want to know is
this a dog or is not a dog is it a cat
or not a cat it classifies a data point
based on how its neighbors are
classified knn stores all available
cases and classifies new cases based on
a similarity measure and here we gone
from cats and dogs right into wine
another favorite of mine k n stores all
available cases and classifies new cases
based on a similarity measure and here
you see we have a measurement of sulfur
dioxide versus the chloride level and
then the different wines they've tested
and where they fall on that graph based
on how much sulfur dioxide and how much
chloride k and k n is a perimeter that
refers to the number of nearest
neighbors to include in the majority of
the voting process and so if we add a
new glass of wine there red or white we
want to know what the neighbors are in
this case we're going to put k equals 5.
we'll talk about k in just a minute a
data point is classified by the majority
of votes from its five nearest neighbors
here the unknown point would be
classified as red since four out of five
neighbors are red so how do we choose k
how do we know k equals five i mean
that's what's the value we put in there
so we're going to talk about it how do
we choose a factor k k n algorithm is
based on feature similarity choosing the
right value of k
is a process called parameter tuning and
is important for better accuracy so at k
equals three we can classify we have a
question mark in the middle as either a
as a square or not is it a square or is
it in this case a triangle and so if we
set k equals to three we're going to
look at the three nearest neighbors
we're going to say this is a square and
if we put k equals a seven we classify
as a triangle depending on what the
other data is around and you can see as
the k changes depending on where that
point is that drastically changes your
answer and we jump here we go how do we
choose the factor of k you'll find this
in all machine learning choosing these
factors that's the face you get he's
like oh my gosh did i choose the right k
did i set it right my values in whatever
machine learning tool you're looking at
so that you don't have a huge bias in
one direction or the other and in terms
of k n n the number of k if you choose
it too low the bias is based on it's
just two noises it's right next to a
couple things and it's going to pick
those things and you might get a skewed
answer and if your k is too big then
it's going to take forever to process so
you're going to run into processing
issues and resource issues so what we do
the most common use and there's other
options for choosing k is to use the
square root of n so it is a total number
of values you have you take the square
root of it in most cases you also if
it's an even number so if you're using
like in this case squares and triangles
if it's even you want to make your k
value odd that helps it select better so
in other words you're not going to have
a balance between two different factors
that are equal so usually take the
square root of n and if it's even you
add one to it or subtract one from it
and that's where you get the k value
from that is the most common use and
it's pretty solid it works very well
when do we use knn we can use k n when
data is labeled so you need a label on
it we know we have a group of pictures
with dogs dogs cats cats data is noise
free and so you can see here when we
have a class and we have like
underweight 140 23 hello kitty normal
that's pretty confusing we have a high
variety of data coming in so it's very
noisy and that would cause an issue data
set is small so we're usually working
with smaller data sets where you might
get into a gig of data if it's really
clean doesn't have a lot of noise
because k n is a lazy learner i.e it
doesn't learn a discriminative function
from the training set so it's very lazy
so if you have very complicated data and
you have a large amount of it you're not
going to use the knn but it's really
great to get a place to start even with
large data you can sort out a small
sample and get an idea of what that
looks like using the knn and also just
using for smaller data sets k n works
really good how does a k n algorithm
work consider a data set having two
variables height in centimeters and
weight in kilograms and each point is
classified as normal or underweight so
we see right here we have two variables
you know true false they're either
normal or they're not they're
underweight on the basis of the given
data we have to classify the below set
as normal or underweight using knn so if
we have new data coming in that says 57
kilograms and 177 centimeters is that
going to be normal or underweight to
find the nearest neighbors we'll
calculate the euclidean distance
according to the euclidean distance
formula the distance between two points
in the plane with the coordinates x y
and a b is given by distance d equals
the square root of x minus a squared
plus y minus b squared and you can
remember that from the two edges of a
triangle we're computing the third edge
since we know
the x side and the y side let's
calculate it to understand clearly so we
have our unknown point and we placed it
there in red and we have our other
points where the data is scattered
around the distance d1 is the square
root of 170 minus 167 squared plus 57
minus 51 squared which is about 6.7 and
distance 2 is about 13. and distance 3
is about 13.4 similarly we will
calculate the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
in the data set and because we're
dealing with small amount of data that's
not that hard to do it's actually pretty
quick for a computer and it's not a
really complicated mass you can just see
how close is the data based on the
euclidean distance hence we have
calculated the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
as shown where x1 and y1 equal 57 and
170 whose class we have to classify so
now we're looking at that we're saying
well here's the euclidean distance who's
going to be their closest neighbors now
let's calculate the nearest neighbor at
k equals three and we can see the three
closest neighbors puts them at normal
and that's pretty self-evident when you
look at this graph it's pretty easy to
say okay what you know we're just voting
normal normal normal three votes for
normal this is going to be a normal
weight so majority of neighbors are
pointing towards normal hence as per k n
algorithm the class of 57 170 should be
normal so a recap of k n n positive
integer k is specified along with a new
sample we select the k entries in our
database which are closest to the new
sample we find the most common
classification of these entries this is
the classification we give to the new
sample so as you can see it's pretty
straightforward we're just looking for
the closest things that match what we
got so let's take a look and see what
that looks like in a use case in python
so let's dive into the predict diabetes
use case so use case predict diabetes
the objective predict whether a person
will be diagnosed with diabetes or not
we have a data set of 768 people who
were or were not diagnosed with diabetes
and let's go ahead and open that file
and just take a look at that data and
this is in a simple
spreadsheet format the data itself is
comma separated very common set of data
and it's also a very common way to get
the data and you can see here we have
columns a through i that's what one two
three four five six seven eight eight
columns with a particular attribute and
then the ninth column which is the
outcome is whether they have diabetes as
a data scientist the first thing you
should be looking at is insulin well you
know if someone has insulin they have
diabetes because that's why they're
taking it and that could cause issue in
some of the machine learning packages
but for a very basic setup this works
fine for doing the k n n and the next
thing you notice is it didn't take very
much to open it up i can scroll down to
the bottom of the data there's 768
it's pretty much a small data set you
know at 769 i can easily fit this into
my ram on my computer i can look at it i
can manipulate it and it's not going to
really tax just a regular desktop
computer you don't even need an
enterprise version to run a lot of this
so let's start with importing all the
tools we need and before that of course
we need to discuss what ide i'm using
certainly can use any particular editor
for python but i like to use for doing
very basic visual stuff the anaconda
which is great for doing demos with the
jupiter notebook and just a quick view
of the anaconda navigator which is the
new release out there which is really
nice you can see under home i can choose
my application we're going to be using
python36 i have a couple different
versions on this particular machine if i
go under environments i can create a
unique environment for each one which is
nice and there's even a little button
there where i can install different
packages so if i click on that button
and open the terminal i can use a simple
pip install to install different
packages i'm working with let's go ahead
and go back under home and we're going
to launch our notebook and i've already
you know kind of like
the old cooking shows i've already
prepared a lot of my stuff so we don't
have to wait for it to launch because it
takes a few minutes for it to open up a
browser window in this case it's going
to open up chrome because that's my
default that i use and since the script
is pre-done you'll see i have a number
of windows open up at the top the one
we're working in and since we're working
on the k n predict whether a person will
have diabetes or not let's go and put
that title in there
and i'm also going to go up here and
click on cell actually we want to go
ahead and first insert a cell below and
then i'm going to go back up to the top
cell and i'm going to change the cell
type to markdown that means this is not
going to run as python it's a markdown
language so if i run this first one it
comes up in nice big letters which is
kind of nice remind us what we're
working on and by now you should be
familiar with doing all of our imports
we're gonna import the pandas as pd
import numpy is np pandas is the pandas
data frame a numpy is a number array
very powerful tools to use in here so we
have our imports so we've brought in our
pandas our numpy our two general python
tools and then you can see over here we
have our train test split by now you
should be familiar with splitting the
data we want to split part of it for
training our thing and then training our
particular model and then we want to go
ahead and test the remaining data to see
how good it is pre-processing a standard
scalar preprocessor so we don't have a
bias of really large numbers remember in
the data we had like number of
pregnancies isn't going to get very
large where the amount of insulin they
take can get up to 256 so 256 versus 6
that will skew results so we want to go
ahead and change that so they're all
uniform between -1 and 1. and then the
actual tool this is the k neighbors
classifier we're gonna use
and finally the last three are three
tools to test all about testing our
model how good is it we just put down
test on there and we have our confusion
matrix our f1 score and our accuracy so
we have our two general python modules
we're importing and then we have our six
modules specific from the sk learn setup
and then we do need to go ahead and run
this so these are actually imported
there we go and then move on to the next
step and so in this set we're going to
go ahead and load the database we're
going to use pandas remember pandas is
pd and we'll take a look at the data in
python we looked at it in a simple
spreadsheet but usually i like to also
pull it up so we can see what we're
doing so here's our data set equals
pd.read csv that's a pandas command and
the diabetes folder i just put in the
same folder where my ipython script is
if you put in a different folder you
need the full length on there we can
also do a quick length of the data set
that is a simple python command len for
length we might even let's go ahead and
print that we'll go print and if you do
it on its own line link that data set in
the jupyter notebook it'll automatically
print it but when you're in most of your
different setups you want to do the
print in front of there and then we want
to take a look at the actual data set
and since we're in pandas we can simply
do data set head and again let's go
ahead and add the print in there
if you put a bunch of these in a row you
know the data set one head data set two
head it only prints out the last one so
i usually always like to keep the print
statement in there but because most
projects only use one data frame pandas
data frame doing it this way doesn't
really matter the other way works just
fine and you can see when we hit the run
button we have the 768 lines which we
knew and we have our pregnancies it's
automatically given a label on the left
remember the head only shows the first
five lines so we have zero through four
and just a quick look at the data you
can see it matches what we looked at
before we have pregnancy glucose blood
pressure all the way to age and then the
outcome on the end and we're going to do
a couple things in this next step we're
going to create a list of columns where
we can't have zero there's no such thing
as zero skin thickness or zero blood
pressure zero glucose
any of those you'd be dead so not a
really good factor if they don't if they
have a zero in there because they didn't
have the data and we'll take a look at
that because we're going to start
replacing that information with a couple
of different things and let's see what
that looks like so first we create a
nice list as you can see we have the
values talked about glucose blood
pressure skin thickness
and this is a nice way when you're
working with columns is to list the
columns you need to do some kind of
transformation on a very common thing to
do and then for this particular setup we
certainly could use the there's some
panda tools that will do a lot of this
where we can replace the n a but we're
going to go ahead and do it as a data
set column equals dataset column.replace
this is this is still pandas you can do
a direct there's also one that's that
you look for your nan a lot of different
options in here but the nan in numpy nan
is what that stands for is none it
doesn't exist so the first thing we're
doing here is we're replacing the zero
with a numpy none there's no data there
that's what that says that's what this
is saying right here so put the zero in
and we're going to play zeros with no
data so if it's a zero that means the
person's well hopefully not dead
hopefully they just didn't get the data
the next thing we want to do is we're
going to create the mean which is the
integer from the data set from the
column dot mean where we skip nas we can
do that that is a pandas command there
the skip n a so we're going to figure
out the mean of that data set and then
we're going to take that data set column
and we're going to replace all the npn
with the means why did we do that and we
could have actually just taken this step
and gone right down here and just
replaced zero and skip anything were
except you could actually there's a way
to skip zeros and then just replace all
the zeros but in this case we want to go
ahead and do it this way so you could
see that we're switching this to a
non-existent value then we're going to
create the mean well this is the average
person so if we don't know what it is if
they did not get the data and the data
is missing one of the tricks is you
replace it with the average what is the
most common data for that this way you
can still use the rest of those values
to do your computation and it kind of
just brings that particular value of
those missing values out of the equation
let's go ahead and take this and we'll
go ahead and run it doesn't actually do
anything so we're still preparing our
data if you want to see what that looks
like we don't have anything in the first
few lines just not going to show up but
we certainly could look at a row let's
do that let's go into our data set with
printed data set
and let's pick in this case let's just
do
glucose
and if i run this this is going to print
all the different glucose levels going
down and we thankfully don't see
anything in here that looks like missing
data at least on the ones it shows you
can see it skipped a bunch in the middle
that's what it does if you have too many
lines in jupiter notebook he'll skip a
few and go on to the next in a data set
let me go and remove this
and we'll just zero out that
and of course before we do any
processing before proceeding any further
we need to split the data set into our
train and testing data that way we have
something to train it with and something
to test it on and you're going to notice
we did a little something here with the
pandas database code there we go my
drawing tool we've added in this right
here
off the data set and what this says is
that the first one in pandas this is
from the pd pandas it's going to say
within the data set we want to look at
the eye location and it is all rows
that's what that says so we're going to
keep all the rows but we're only looking
at 0 column zero to eight remember
column nine here it is right up here we
put it in here is outcome well that's
not part of the training data that's
part of the answer yes column nine but
it's listed as eight number eight so
zero to eight is nine columns so uh
eight is the value and when you see it
in here 0 this is actually 0 to 7 it
doesn't include the last one and then we
go down here to y which is our answer
and we want just the last one just
column 8 and you can do it this way with
this particular notation and then if you
remember we imported the train test
split
that's part of the sk learn right there
and we simply put in our x and our y
we're going to do random state equals 0.
you don't have to necessarily see it
that's a seed number i think the default
is one when you seed it i'd have to look
that up and then the test size test size
is 0.2 that simply means we're going to
take 20 of the data and put it aside so
that we can test it later that's all
that is and again we're going to run it
not very exciting so far we haven't had
any print out other than to look at the
data but that is a lot of this is
prepping this data once you prep it the
actual lines of code are quick and easy
and we're almost there with the actual
writing of our knn we need to go ahead
and do a scale the data if you remember
correctly we're fitting the data in a
standard scalar which means instead of
the data being from you know 5 to 303 in
one column and the next column is 1 to 6
we're going to set that all so that all
the data is between -1 and 1. that's
what that standard scalar does keeps it
standardized and we only want to fit the
scalar with the training set but we want
to make sure the testing set is the x
test going in is also transformed so
it's processing it the same so here we
go with our standard scalar we're going
to call it sc underscore x for the
scalar and we're going to import the
standard scalar into this variable and
then our x train equals sc underscore x
dot fit transform so we're creating the
scalar on the x train variable and then
our x test we're also going to transform
it so
we've trained and transformed the x
train and then the x test
isn't part of that training it isn't
part of that of training the transformer
it just gets transformed that's all it
does and again we're going to go and run
this if you look at this we've now gone
through these steps all three of them
we've taken care of replacing our zeros
for key columns that shouldn't be zero
and we replace that with the means of
those columns that way that they fit
right in with our data models we've come
down here we split the data so now we
have our test data and our training data
and then we've taken and we've scaled
the data so all of our data going in no
no we don't tr we don't train the y part
the y train and y test that never has to
be trained it's only the data going in
that's what we want to train in there
then define the model using k neighbors
classifier and fit the train data in the
model so we do all that data prep and
you can see down here we're only going
to have a couple lines of code where
we're actually building our model and
training it that's one of the cool
things about python and how far we've
come it's such an exciting time to be in
machine learning because there's so many
automated tools let's see before we do
this let's do a quick length of and
let's do y we want let's just do length
of y
and we get 768 and if we import math we
do math dot square root let's do y
train there we go it's actually supposed
to be x train
before we do this let's go ahead and do
import math and do math square root
length of y test and when i run that we
get 12.409
i want to show you where this number
comes from we're about to use 12 is an
even number so if you know if you're
ever voting on things remember the
neighbors all vote don't want to have an
even number of neighbors voting so we
want to do something odd and let's just
take one away we'll make it 11. let me
delete this out of here this one the
reasons i love jupiter notebook is you
can flip around and do all kinds of
things on the fly so we'll go ahead and
put in our classifier we're creating our
classifier now and it's going to be the
k neighbors classifier n neighbors equal
11. remember we did 12 minus 1 for 11.
so we have an odd number of neighbors p
equals 2 because we're looking for is it
are they diabetic or not and we're using
the euclidean metric there are other
means of measuring the distance you
could do like square square means values
all kinds of measure this but the
euclidean is the most common one and it
works quite well it's important to
evaluate the model let's use the
confusion matrix to do that and we're
going to use the confusion matrix
wonderful tool and then we'll jump into
the f1 score
and finally accuracy score which is
probably the most commonly used quoted
number when you go into a meeting or
something like that so let's go ahead
and paste that in there and we'll set
the cm equal to confusion matrix why
test y predict so those are the two
values we're going to put in there and
let me go ahead and run that and print
it out and the way you interpret this is
you have the y predicted which would be
your title up here you could do let's
just do p-r-e-d
predict it across the top
and actual going down actual
it's always hard to write in here actual
that means that this column here down
the middle that's the important column
and it means that our prediction said 94
and prediction in the actual agreed on
94 and 32. this number here
the 13 and the 15 those are what was
wrong so you could have like three
different if you're looking at this
across three different variables instead
of just two you'd end up with the third
row down here in that column going down
the middle so in the first case we have
the the and i believe the zero is at 94
people who don't have diabetes the
prediction said that 13 of those people
did have diabetes and were at high risk
and the 32 that had diabetes it had
correct but our prediction said another
15 out of that 15 it classified as
incorrect so you can see where that
classification comes in and how that
works on the confusion matrix then we're
going to go ahead and print the f1 score
let me just run that and you see we get
a 0.69 in our f1 score
the f1 takes into account both sides of
the balance of false positives where if
we go ahead and just do the accuracy
account and that's what most people
think of is it looks at just how many we
got right out of how many we got wrong
so a lot of people when you're a data
scientist and you're talking to other
data scientists they're going to ask you
what the f1 score the f score is if
you're talking to the general public or
the decision makers in the business
they're going to ask what the accuracy
is and the accuracy is always better
than the f1 score but the f1 score is
more telling it lets us know that
there's more false positives than we
would like on here but 82 percent not
too bad for a quick flash look at
people's different statistics and
running an sk learn and running the knn
the k nearest neighbor on it so we have
created a model using knn which can
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not or at the very least
whether they should go get a checkup and
have their glucose checked regularly or
not the print accuracy score we got the
0.818
was pretty close to what we got and we
can pretty much round that off and just
say we have an accuracy of 80 percent
tells us it is a pretty fair fit in the
model welcome to the session on k-means
clustering so what is k-means clustering
k-means clustering is an unsupervised
learning algorithm in this case you
don't have labeled data unlike in
supervised learning so you have a set of
data and you want to group them and as
the name suggests you want to put them
into clusters which means objects that
are similar in nature similar in
characteristics need to be put together
so that's what k means clustering is all
about the term k is basically is a
number so we need to tell the system how
many clusters we need to perform so if k
is equal to two there will be two
clusters if k is equal to three three
clusters and so on and so forth that's
what the k stands for and of course
there is a way of finding out what is
the best or optimum value of k for a
given data we will look at that so that
is k means clustering so
let's take an example k-means clustering
is used in many many scenarios but let's
take an example of cricket the game of
cricket let's say you received
data of a lot of players from maybe all
over the country or all over the world
and this data has information about the
runs scored by the people ordered by the
player and the wickets taken by the
player and based on this information we
need to cluster this data into two
clusters batsman and bowlers so this is
an interesting example let's see how we
can perform this so we have the data
which consists of primarily two
characteristics which is the runs and
the wickets so the bowlers basically
take wickets and the batsmen score runs
there will be of course a few bowlers
who can
score some runs and similarly there will
be some batsmen who will who would have
taken a few wickets but with this
information we want to cluster those
players into batsmen and bowlers so how
does this work let's say this is how the
data is
so there are information there is
information on the y-axis about the run
scored and on the x-axis about the
wickets taken by the players so if we do
a quick plot this is how it would look
and
when we do the clustering we need to
have the clusters like shown in the
third diagram rtms we need to have a
cluster which consists of people who
have scored high runs which is basically
the batsman and then we need a cluster
with people who have taken a lot of
wickets which is typically the bowlers
there may be a certain amount of overlap
but we will not talk about it right now
so with k-means clustering we will have
here that means k is equal to two and we
will have two clusters which is batsman
and bowlers so how does this work the
way it works is the first step in
k-means clustering is the allocation of
two centroids randomly so two points are
assigned as so-called centroids so in
this case we want two clusters which
means k is equal to two so two points
have been randomly assigned as centroids
keep in mind
these points can be anywhere there are
random points they are not initially
they are not really the centroids
centroid means it's a central point of a
given data set but in this case when it
starts off it's not really the centroid
okay so these points though in our
presentation here we have shown them one
point closer to these data points and
another closer to these data points they
can be assigned randomly anywhere okay
so that's the first step the next step
is to determine the distance of each of
the data points
from each of the
randomly assigned centroids so for
example we take this point and find the
distance from the centroid and the
distance from this centroid this point
is taken and the distance is found from
this centroid and the center and so on
and so forth so
for every point the distance is measured
from both the centroids
and then
whichever distance is less that point is
assigned to that centroid so for example
in this case visually it is very obvious
that all these data points are assigned
to this centroid and all these data
points are assigned to this centroid and
that's what is represented here in blue
color and in this yellow color the next
step is to actually determine the
central point or the actual centroid for
these two clusters so we have this one
initial cluster this one initial cluster
but as you can see these points are not
really the centroid centroid means it
should be the central position of this
data set central position of this data
set so that is what needs to be
determined as the next step so the
central point of the actual centroid is
determined and the original randomly
allocated centroid is repositioned to
the actual centroid of these new
clusters and this process is actually
repeated now what might happen is some
of these points may get reallocated in
our example that is not happening
probably but it may so happen that the
distance is found between each of these
data points once again with these
centroids and if there is if it is
required some points may be reallocated
we will see that in a later example but
for now we will keep it simple so this
process is continued till the centroid
repositioning stops and that is our
final cluster so this is our so after
iteration we come to this position this
situation where the centroid doesn't
need any more repositioning and that
means our algorithm has converged
convergence has occurred and we have the
cluster two clusters we have the
clusters with a centroid so this process
is
repeated the process of calculating the
distance and repositioning the centroid
is repeated till the repositioning stops
which means that the algorithm has
converged and we have the final cluster
with the data points and the centroids
so this is what you're going to learn
from this session we will talk about the
types of clustering what is k-means
clustering application of k-means
clustering k-means clustering is done
using distance measure so we will talk
about the common distance measures and
then we will talk about how k-means
clustering works and go into the details
of k-means clustering algorithm and then
we will end with a demo and a use case
for k-means clustering so let's begin
first of all what are the types of
clustering there are primarily two
categories of clustering hierarchical
clustering and then partitional
clustering and each of these categories
are further subdivided into
agglomerative and divisive clustering
and k-means and fuzzy c means clustering
let's take a quick look at what each of
these types of clustering are
in hierarchical clustering the clusters
have a tree-like structure and
hierarchical clustering is further
divided into agglomerative and divisive
agglomerative clustering is a bottom-up
approach we begin with each element as a
separate cluster and merge them into
successively larger clusters so for
example we have a b c d e f we start by
combining b and c form one cluster d e
and e form one more then we combine d e
and f one more bigger cluster and then
add bc to that and then finally a to it
compared to that divisive clustering or
divisive clustering is a top down
approach we begin with the whole set and
proceed to divide it into successively
smaller clusters so we have abcdef we
first take that as a single cluster and
then break it down
into a b c d
e and f
then we have partitional clustering
split into two subtypes k means
clustering and fuzzy c means in k means
clustering the objects are divided into
the number of clusters mentioned by the
number k that's where the k comes from
so if we say k is equal to 2 the objects
are divided into two clusters c1 and c2
and the way it is done is the features
or characteristics
are compared and all objects having
similar characteristics are clubbed
together so that's how k means
clustering is done we will see it in
more detail as we move forward and fuzzy
c means is very similar to k means in
the sense that it clubs objects that
have similar characteristics together
but while in k means clustering two
objects cannot belong to or any object a
single object cannot belong to two
different clusters in c means objects
can belong to more than one cluster so
that is the primary difference between
k-means and fuzzy c means
so what are some of the applications of
k-means clustering k-means clustering is
used in a variety of examples or variety
of business cases in real life starting
from academic performance diagnostic
systems search engines and wireless
sensor networks and many more so let us
take a little deeper look at each of
these examples academic performance so
based on the scores of the students
students are categorized into a b c and
so on clustering forms a backbone of
search engines when a search is
performed the search results need to be
grouped together the search engines very
often use clustering to do this and
similarly in case of
wireless sensor networks the clustering
algorithm plays the role of finding the
cluster heads which collects all the
data in its respective cluster so
clustering especially k means clustering
uses distance measure so let's take a
look at what is distance measure so
while these are the different types of
clustering in this video we will focus
on k-means clustering so distance
measure tells
how similar some objects are so the
similarity is measured using what is
known as distance measure and what are
the various types of distance measures
there is euclidean distance there is
manhattan distance then we have squared
euclidean distance measure and cosine
distance measure these are some of the
distance measures supported by k-means
clustering let's take a look at each of
these
what is euclidean distance measure this
is nothing but the distance between two
points so we have learnt in high school
how to find the distance between two
points this is a little sophisticated
formula for that but we know a simpler
one is square root of y 2 minus y 1
whole square plus x 2 minus x 1 whole
square so this is an extension of that
formula so that is the euclidean
distance between two points what is the
squared euclidean distance measure it's
nothing but the square of the euclidean
distance as the name suggests so instead
of taking the square root we leave the
square as it is and then we have
manhattan distance measure in case of
manhattan distance it is the sum of the
distances across the x-axis and the
y-axis
and note that we are taking the absolute
value so that the negative values don't
come into play so that is the manhattan
distance measure then we have cosine
distance measure in this case we take
the angle between the two vectors formed
by joining the points from the origin so
that is the cosine distance measure okay
so that was a quick overview about the
various distance measures that are
supported by k-means now let's go and
check how exactly k-means clustering
works okay so this is how k means
clustering works this is like a
flowchart of the whole process there is
a starting point and then we specify the
number of clusters that we want now
there are a couple of ways of doing this
we can do by trial and error so we
specify a certain number maybe k is
equal to 3 or 4 or 5 to start with and
then as we progress we keep changing
until we get the best clusters or there
is a technique called elbow technique
whereby we can determine the value of k
what should be the best value of k how
many clusters should be formed so once
we have the value of k we specify that
and then the system will assign
that many centroids so it picks randomly
that to start with randomly that many
points that are considered to be the
centroids of these clusters and then it
measures the distance of each of the
data points from these centroids and
assigns those points to the
corresponding centroid from which the
distance is minimum so each data point
will be assigned to the centroid which
is closest to it and thereby we have k
number of initial clusters however this
is not the final clusters the next step
it does is
for the new groups for the clusters that
have been formed it calculates the main
position thereby calculates the new
centroid position the position of the
centroid moves compared to the randomly
allocated one so it's an iterative
process once again the distance of each
point is measured from this new centroid
point and if required the data points
are reallocated to the new centroids and
the mean position or the new centroid is
calculated once again if the centroid
moves then the iteration continues which
means the convergence has not happened
the clustering has not converged so as
long as there is a movement of the
centroid this iteration keeps happening
but once the centroid stops moving which
means that the cluster has converged or
the clustering process has converged
that will be the end result so now we
have the final position of the centroid
and the data points are allocated
accordingly to the closest centroid i
know it's a little difficult to
understand from this simple flowchart so
let's do a little bit of visualization
and see if we can explain it better
let's take an example if we have a data
set for a grocery shop so let's say we
have a data set for a grocery shop and
now we want to find out how many
clusters this has to be spread across
so how do we find the optimum number of
clusters there is a technique called the
elbow method so when these clusters are
formed there is a parameter called
within sum of squares
and the lower this value is the better
the cluster is that means
all these points are very close to each
other so we use this within sum of
squares as a measure to find the optimum
number of clusters that can be formed
for a given data set so we create
clusters or we let the system create
clusters of a variety of numbers maybe
of 10
10 clusters and for each value of k
the within ss is measured and the value
of k which has the least amount of
within ss or wss that is taken as the
optimum value of k so this is the
diagrammatic representation so we have
on the y axis the within sum of squares
or wss and on the x-axis we have the
number of clusters so as you can imagine
if you have k is equal to 1 which means
all the data points are in a single
cluster the within s value will be very
high because they are probably scattered
all over the moment you split it into
two there will be a drastic fall in the
within ss value that's what is
represented here but then as the value
of k increases
the decrease the rate of decrease
will not be so high it will continue to
decrease but probably the rate of
decrease will not be high so that gives
us an idea so from here we get an idea
for example the optimum value of k
should be either two or three or at the
most four but beyond that
increasing the number of clusters is not
dramatically changing the value in wss
because that pretty much gets stabilized
okay now that we have got the value of k
and let's assume that these are our
delivery points the next step is
basically
to assign two centroids randomly so
let's say c1 and c2 are the centroids
assigned randomly now the distance of
each
location from the centroid is measured
and each point is assigned to the
centroid which is closest to it so for
example
these points are very obvious that these
are closest to c1 whereas this point is
far away from c2 so these points will be
assigned which are close to c1 will be
assigned to c1 and these points or
locations which are close to c2 will be
assigned to c2 and then so this is the
how the initial grouping is done this is
part of c1 and this is part of c2 then
the next step is to calculate the actual
centroid of this data because remember
c1 and c2 are not the centroids they
have been
randomly assigned points and only thing
that has been done was the data points
which are closest to them have been
assigned
but now in this step the actual centroid
will be calculated which may be for each
of these data sets somewhere in the
middle so that's like the main point
that will be calculated and the centroid
will actually be positioned or
repositioned there
same with c2
so the new centroid for this group is c2
in this new position and c1 is in this
new position
once again the distance of each of the
data points is calculated from these
centroids now remember it's not
necessary that the distance still
remains the or each of these data points
still remain in the same group by
recalculating the distance it may be
possible that some points get
reallocated like so you see this
so this point earlier was closer to c2
because c2 was here
but after recalculating repositioning it
is observed that this is closer to c1
than c2 so this is the new grouping so
some points will be reassigned and again
the centroid will be calculated and if
the centroid doesn't change so that is a
repetitive process iterative process and
if the centroid doesn't change once the
centroid stops changing that means the
algorithm has converged and this is our
final cluster with this as the centroid
c1 and c2 as the centroids these data
points as a part of each cluster so i
hope this helps in understanding the
whole process iterative process of
k-means clustering so let's take a look
at
the k-means clustering algorithm let's
say we have x1 x2 x3 n number of points
as our inputs and we want to split this
into k clusters or we want to create k
clusters so the first step is to
randomly pick k points and call them
centroids they are not real centroids
because centroid is supposed to be a
center point but they are just called
centroids and we calculate the distance
of each and every input point from each
of the centroids so the distance of x1
from c1 from c2 c3 each of the distances
we calculate and then find out which
distance is the lowest and assign x1 to
that particular random centroid repeat
that process for x2 calculate its
distance from each of the centroids c1
c2 c3 up to ck and find which is the
lowest distance and assign x2 to that
particular centroid same with x3 and so
on so that is the first round of
assignment that is done now
we have k
groups because there are we have
assigned the value of k so there are k
centroids
and so there are k groups all these
inputs have been split into k groups
however remember we picked the centroids
randomly so they are not real centroids
so now what we have to do we have to
calculate the actual centroids for each
of these groups which is like the mean
position which means that the position
of the randomly selected
centroids will now change
and they will be
the main positions of this newly formed
k groups and once that is done we once
again repeat this process of calculating
the distance right so this is what we
are doing as a part of step four we
repeat step two and three so we again
calculate the distance of x1
from the centroid c1
c2 c3 and then c which is the lowest
value and assign x1 to that
calculate the distance of x2 from c1 c2
c3 or whatever up to c k and find
whichever is the lowest distance and
assign x 2 to that centroid and so on in
this process there may be some
reassignment x 1 was probably assigned
to cluster c2 and after doing this
calculation maybe now x1 is assigned to
c1 so that kind of reallocation may
happen so we repeat the steps 2 and 3
till the position of the centroids don't
change or stop changing and that's when
we have convergence so let's take a
detailed look at each of these steps so
we randomly pick k cluster centers we
call them centroids because they are not
initially they are not really the
centroids so we let us name them c1 c2
up to ck and then step two we assign
each data point to the closest center so
what we do we calculate the distance of
each x value from each c value so the
distance between
x1 c1 distance between x1 c2 x1 c3 and
then we find which is the lowest value
right that's the minimum value we find
and assign x1 to that particular
centroid then we go next to x2 find the
distance of x2 from c1 x2 from c2 x2
from c3 and so on up to ck and then
assign it to the point or to the
centroid which has the lowest value and
so on so that is step number two in step
number three we now find the actual
centroid for each group so what has
happened as a part of step number two
we now have all the points all the data
points grouped into k groups because we
we wanted to create k clusters right so
we have k groups each one may be having
a certain number of input values they
need not be equally distributed by the
way based on the distance we will have k
groups but remember the initial values
of the c1 c2 were not really the
centroids of these groups right we
assigned them randomly so now in step 3
we actually calculate the centroid of
each group which means the original
point which we thought was the centroid
will shift to the new position which is
the actual centroid for each of these
groups okay and we again calculate the
distance so we go back to step two which
is what we calculate again the distance
of each of these points from the newly
positioned centroids and if required we
reassign these points to the new
centroids so as i said earlier
there may be a reallocation so we now
have a new set or a new group we still
have k groups
but the number of items and the actual
assignment may be different from what
was in step
two here okay so that might change then
we perform step three once again to find
the new centroid of this new group so we
have again a new set of clusters new
centroids and new assignments
we repeat this step two again once again
we find and then it is possible that
after iterating through three or four or
five times the centroid will stop moving
in the sense that when you calculate the
new value of the centroid that will be
same as the original value or there will
be very marginal change so that is when
we say convergence has occurred and that
is our final cluster that's the
formation of the final cluster
all right so let's see a couple of demos
of k-means clustering we will actually
see some live demos in python notebook
using python notebook but before that
let's find out what's the problem that
we are trying to solve the problem
statement is let's say walmart wants to
open a chain of stores across the state
of florida and
it wants to find the optimal store
locations now the issue here is if they
open too many stores close to each other
obviously they will not make profit but
if they if the stores are too far apart
then they will not have enough sales so
how do they optimize this now
for an organization like walmart which
is an e-commerce giant
they already have the addresses of their
customers in their database so they can
actually use this information or this
data and use k-means clustering to find
the optimal location now before we go
into the
python notebook and show you the live
code
i wanted to take you through very
quickly a summary of the code in the
slides and then we will go into the
python notebook so in this
block we are basically
importing all the required libraries
like numpy
matplotlib and so on
and we are loading the data that is
available in the form of let's say the
addresses
for simplicity's sake we will just take
them as some data points then the next
thing we do is quickly do a scatter plot
to see how they are
related to each other with respect to
each other so in the scatter plot we see
that there are a few distinct groups
already being formed so you can actually
get an idea about how the cluster would
look and how many clusters what is the
optimal number of clusters and then
starts the actual
k-means clustering process
so we will assign each of these points
to the centroids and then check whether
they are the optimal distance which is
the shortest distance and assign each of
the points data points to the centroids
and then go through this iterative
process till the whole process converges
and finally we get an output like this
so we have four distinct clusters
and
which is if we can say that this is how
the population is probably distributed
across florida state and
these centroids are like the location
where the store should be the optimum
location where the store should be so
that's the way we determine the best
locations for the store and that's how
we can help walmart find the best
locations for their stores in florida so
now let's
take this into python notebook let's see
how this looks when we are running
running the code live all right so this
is the code for k-means clustering in
jupiter notebook we have a few examples
here which we will demonstrate how
k-means clustering is used and even
there is a small implementation of
k-means clustering as well okay so let's
get started okay so this block is
basically importing the various
libraries that are required like
matplotlib and numpy and so on and so
forth which would be used as a part of
the code then we are going and creating
blobs which are similar to clusters now
this is a very neat feature which is
available in scikit learn make blobs is
a nice feature which creates clusters of
data sets so that's a wonderful
functionality that is readily available
for us to create some test data kind of
thing okay so that's exactly what we are
doing here we are using make blobs and
we can specify how many
clusters we want so centers we are
mentioning here so it will go ahead and
so we just mentioned four so it will go
ahead and create some test data for us
and this is how it looks as you can see
visually also we can figure out that
there are four distinct classes or
clusters in this data set and that is
what make blobs actually provides
now from
here onwards we will basically
run the standard k-means functionality
that is readily available so we really
don't have to implement k-means itself
the k-means functionality or the
function is readily available you just
need to feed the data and will create
the clusters so this is the code for
that
we import k-means and then we create an
instance of k-means and we specify the
value of k this n underscore clusters is
the value of k remember k means in k
means k is basically the number of
clusters that you want to create and it
is a
integer value so this is where we are
specifying that so we have k is equal to
and so that instance is created we take
that instance and as with any other
machine learning functionality fit is
what we use the function or the method
rather fit is what we use to train the
model here there is no real training
kind of thing but that's the call okay
so we are calling fit and what we are
doing here we are just passing the data
so x has these values the data that has
been created
right so that is what we are passing
here
and
this will go ahead and create the
clusters and
then we are using
after doing
fit we run the predict which basically
assigns for each of these observations
which cluster where it belongs to all
right so it will name the clusters maybe
this is cluster 1 this is 2 3 and so on
or i will actually start from 0 cluster
0 1 2 and 3 maybe and then for each of
the observations it will assign based on
which cluster it belongs to it will
assign a value so that is stored in y
underscore k means when we call predict
that is what it does
and we can take a quick look at these uh
y underscore k means or with the cluster
numbers that have been assigned for each
observation so this is the cluster
number assigned for observation 1 maybe
this is for observation 2 observation 3
and so on so we have how many about i
think 300 samples right so all the 300
samples there are 300 values here each
of them the cluster number is given and
the cluster number goes from zero to
three so there are four clusters so the
numbers go from zero one two three so
that's what is seen here okay now so
this was a quick example of generating
some dummy data and then clustering that
okay and this can be applied if you have
proper data you can just load it up into
x for example here and then run the game
so this is the central part of the
k-means clustering program example so
you basically create an instance and you
mention how many clusters you want by
specifying this parameter and underscore
clusters and that is also the value of k
and then pass the data to get the values
now the next section of this code is the
implementation of a k-means now this is
kind of a rough implementation of the
k-means algorithm so we will just walk
you through i will walk you through the
code uh at each step what it is doing
and then we will see a couple of more
examples of how k-means clustering uh
can be used in maybe some real-life
examples real-life use cases all right
so in this case here what we are doing
is basically implementing the k means
clustering
and there is a function for a library
calculates for a given two pairs of
points it will calculate the the
distance between them and see which one
is the closest and so on so this is like
this is pretty much like what k means
does right so it calculates the distance
of each point or each data set from
predefined centroid and then based on
whichever is the lowest this particular
data point is assigned to that centroid
so that is basically available as a
standard function and we will be using
that here so as explained in the slides
the first step that is done in case of
k-means clustering is to randomly assign
some centroids so as a first step we
randomly allocate a couple of centroids
which we call here we are calling as
centers
and then we put this in a loop and we
take it through an iterative process
for each of the data points we first
find out using this function pairwise
distance argument for each of the points
we find out which one which center or
which randomly selected centroid is the
closest and accordingly we assign the
data or the data point to that
particular centroid or cluster and once
that is done for all the data points we
calculate the new centroid by finding
out the mean position which is the
center position right so we calculate
the new centroid and then we check if
the new centroid is the coordinates or
the position is the same as the previous
centroid
the positions we will compare
and if it is the same that means the
process has converged so remember we do
this process till the centroids or the
centroid doesn't move anymore right so
the centroid gets relocated each time
this reallocation is done so the moment
it doesn't change anymore the position
of the centroid doesn't change anymore
we know that convergence has occurred so
till then so you see here this is like
an infinite loop while true is an
infinite loop it only breaks when the
centers are the same the new center and
the old center positions are the same
and once that is uh done we return the
centers and the labels now of course as
explained this is not a very
sophisticated and advanced
implementation very basic implementation
because one of the flaws in this is that
sometimes what happens is the centroid
the position
will
keep moving but in the change will be
very minor so in that case also with
that is actually convergence right so
for example the change is point zero
zero zero one we can consider that as
convergence otherwise what will happen
is this will either take forever or it
will be never ending so that's a small
flaw here so that is something
additional checks may have to be added
here but again as mentioned this is not
the most sophisticated implementation uh
this is like a kind of a rough
implementation of the k-means clustering
okay so if we execute this code this is
what we get as the output so this is the
definition of this particular function
and then we call that find underscore
clusters and we pass our data x and the
number of clusters which is 4
and if we run that and plot it this is
the output that we get so this is of
course each cluster is represented by a
different color so we have a cluster in
green color yellow color and so on and
so forth and these big points here these
are the centroids this is the final
position of the centroids and as you can
see visually also this appears like a
kind of a center of all these points
here right similarly this is like the
center of all these points here and so
on so this is the example or this is an
example of an implementation of k-means
clustering and
next we will move on to see a couple of
examples of how k-means clustering is
used in maybe some real life scenarios
or use cases in the next example or demo
we are going to see how we can use
k-means clustering to perform color
compression we will take a couple of
images so there will be two examples and
we will try to use k-means clustering to
compress the colors this is a common
situation
in image processing when you have an
image with millions of
colors but then you cannot render it on
some devices which may not have enough
memory so that is the
scenario where where something like this
can be used
so
before again we go into the python
notebook let's take a look at quickly
the the code
as usual we import the libraries and
then we import the image and
then we will flatten it so the reshaping
is basically we have the image
information is stored in the form of
pixels and if the image is like for
example 427 by 640 and it has three
colors so that's the overall dimension
of the of the initial image we just
reshape it and
then feed this to our algorithm
and this will then create clusters of
only 16 clusters so this this colors
there are millions of colors and now we
need to bring it down to 16 colors so we
use k is equal to 16
and
this is how when we visualize this is
how it looks there are these are all
about 16 million possible colors the
input color space has 16 million
possible colors and we just
sub compress it to 16 colors so this is
how it would look when we compress it to
16 colors and this is how the original
image looks and
after compression to 16 colors this is
how the new image looks as you can see
there is not a lot of information that
has been lost
though the image quality is definitely
reduced a little bit
so this is an example which we are going
to now see in python notebook let's go
into the python node and once again as
always we will import some libraries and
load this image called
flower dot jpg okay so let we'll load
that and this is how it looks this is
the original image which has i think 16
million colors and
this is the shape of this image which is
basically what is the shape is nothing
but the overall size right so this is
427 pixel by 640 pixel and then there
are three layers which is this three
basically is for rgb which is red green
blue so color image will have that right
so that is the shape of this now what we
need to do is data let's take a look at
how data is looking so let me just
create a new cell and show you
what is in data basically we have
captured this information
so data is what let me just show you
here
all right so
let's take a look at
china what are the values in china and
if we see here this is how the data is
stored this is nothing but the pixel
values okay so this is like a matrix
and each one has about for this 427 by
640 pixels all right so this is how it
looks now the issue here is these values
are large the numbers are a large so we
need to normalize them to between zero
and one right so that's why we will
basically create one more variable which
is data which will contain the values
between zero and one and the way to do
that is divide by 255 so we divide china
by 255 and we get the new values in data
so let's just run this piece of code and
this is the shape so we now have also
yeah what we have done is we changed
using reshape we converted into the
three-dimensional into a two-dimensional
data set and let us also take a look at
how
let me just insert
uh probably a cell here and take a look
at how data is looking all right so this
is how data is looking and now you see
this is
the values are between zero and one
right so if you earlier noticed in case
of china the values were large numbers
now everything is between 0 and 1. this
is one of the things we need to do all
right so after that the next thing that
we need to do is to visualize this and
we can take random set of maybe 10 000
points and plot it and check and see how
this looks let us just plot this
and so this is how the original the
color the pixel distribution is these
are two plots one is red against green
and another is red against blue and this
is the original distribution of the
color so then what we will do is we will
use k means clustering to create just 16
clusters for the various colors and then
apply that to the image now
what will happen is since the data is
large because there are millions of
colors using regular k-means may be a
little time consuming so there is
another version of k-means which is
called mini batch in so we will use that
which is which processes in the overall
concept remains the same but this
basically processes it in smaller
batches that's the only thing okay so
the results will pretty much be the same
so let's go ahead and execute this piece
of code and also visualize this so that
we can see that there are these this is
how the 16 colors
would look so this is red against green
and this is red against blue there is
quite a bit of similarity between this
original color schema and the new one
right so it doesn't look very very
completely different or anything like
that now we apply this the newly created
colors to the image and we can take a
look uh how this is uh looking now we
can compare both the images so this is
our original image and this is our new
image so as you can see there is not a
lot of information that has been
lost
it pretty much looks like the original
image yes we can see that for example
here there is a little bit uh it appears
a little dullish compared to this one
right because we kind of took off some
of the finer details of the color but
overall the high level information has
been maintained at the same time the
main advantage is that now this can be
this is an image which can be rendered
on a device which may not be that very
sophisticated now let's take one more
example with a different image in the
second example we will take an image of
the summer palace in china and we repeat
the same process this is a
high definition
color image with millions of colors and
also
three-dimensional
now we will reduce that to 16 colors
using k-means clustering
and
we do the same process like before we
reshape it and then we cluster the
colors to 16
and then we render the image once again
and we will see that the color the
quality of the image
slightly deteriorates as you can see
here this has much finer details in this
which are probably missing here but then
that's the compromise because there are
some devices which may not be able to
handle
this kind of high density images
so let's run this chord in python
notebook all right so let's apply the
same technique for another picture which
is uh even more intricate and has
probably much complicated color schema
so this is the image now once again we
can take a look at the shape which is
427 by 640 by 3
and this is the new data would look
somewhat like this compared to the
flower image so we have some new values
here
and we will
also bring this as you can see the
numbers are much big so we will much
bigger so we will now have to scale them
down to values between 0 and 1 and that
is done by
dividing by 255 so let's go ahead and do
that
and reshape it okay so we get a two
dimensional matrix
and we will then as a next step we will
go ahead and visualize this how it looks
does the 16 colors
and this is basically how it would look
16 million colors and
now we can
create the clusters
out of this the 16
k means clusters we will create so this
is how the distribution of the pixels
would look with 16 colors
and then we go ahead and
apply this
and visualize how it is looking for
with the new just the 16 color so once
again as you can see this looks much
richer in color but at the same time and
this probably doesn't have as we can see
it doesn't look as rich as this one but
nevertheless the information is not lost
the shape and all that stuff and this
can be also rendered on a slightly a
device which is probably not that
sophisticated okay so that's pretty much
it so we have seen two examples of how
color compression can be done
using k-means clustering
and we have also seen in the previous
examples of how to implement k-means the
code to roughly how to implement k-means
clustering and we use some sample data
using blob
to just execute the k-means clustering
ever wondered how google translates an
entire web page to a different language
in a matter of seconds or your phone
gallery groups images based on their
location all of this is a product of
deep learning but what exactly is deep
learning deep learning is a subset of
machine learning which in turn is a
subset of artificial intelligence
artificial intelligence is a technique
that enables a machine to mimic human
behavior machine learning is a technique
to achieve ai through algorithms trained
with data and finally deep learning is a
type of machine learning inspired by the
structure of the human brain in terms of
deep learning this structure is called
an artificial neural network let's
understand deep learning better and how
it's different from machine learning say
we create a machine that could
differentiate between tomatoes and
cherries if done using machine learning
we'd have to tell the machine the
features based on which the two can be
differentiated these features could be
the size and the type of stem on them
with deep learning on the other hand the
features are picked out by the neural
network without human intervention of
course that kind of independence comes
at the cost of having a much higher
volume of data to train our machine
now let's dive into the working of
neural networks
here we have three students each of them
write down the digit nine on a piece of
paper
notably they don't all write it
identically the human brain can easily
recognize the digits
but what if a computer had to recognize
them
that's where deep learning comes in
here's a neural network trained to
identify handwritten digits
each number is present as an image of 28
times 28 pixels
now that amounts to a total of 784
pixels
neurons the core entity of a neural
network is where the information
processing takes place
each of the 784 pixels is fed to a
neuron in the first layer of our neural
network
this forms the input layer
on the other end we have the output
layer with each neuron representing a
digit with the hidden layers existing
between them
the information is transferred from one
layer to another over connecting
channels
each of these has a value attached to it
and hence is called a weighted channel
all neurons have a unique number
associated with it called bias
this bias is added to the weighted sum
of inputs reaching the neuron
which is then applied to a function
known as the activation function
the result of the activation function
determines if the neuron gets activated
every activated neuron passes on
information to the following layers
this continues up till the second last
layer
the one neuron activated in the output
layer corresponds to the input digit the
weights and bias are continuously
adjusted to produce a well-trained
network so where is deep learning
applied in customer support when most
people converse with customer support
agents the conversation seems so real
they don't even realize that it's
actually a bot on the other side in
medical care neural networks detect
cancer cells and analyze mri images to
give detailed results self-driving cars
what seem like science fiction is now a
reality apple tesla and nissan are only
a few of the companies working on
self-driving cars so deep learning has a
vast scope but it too faces some
limitations the first as we discussed
earlier is data while deep learning is
the most efficient way to deal with
unstructured data a neural network
requires a massive volume of data to
train let's assume we always have access
to the necessary amount of data
processing this is not within the
capability of every machine and that
brings us to our second limitation
computational power training a neural
network requires graphical processing
units which have thousands of cores as
compared to cpus and gpus are of course
more expensive and finally we come down
to training time deep neural networks
take hours or even months to train the
time increases with the amount of data
and number of layers in the network so
here's a short quiz for you arrange the
following statements in order to
describe the working of a neural network
a the bias is added b the weighted sum
of the inputs is calculated c specific
neuron is activated d the result is fed
to an activation function leave your
answers in the comments section below
some of the popular deep learning
frameworks include tensorflow pytorch
keras deep learning 4j cafe and
microsoft cognitive toolkit considering
the future predictions for deep learning
and ai we seem to have only scratched
the surface in fact horus technology is
working on a device for the blind that
uses deep learning with computer vision
to describe the world to the users
replicating the human mind at the
entirety may be not just an episode of
science fiction for too long the future
is indeed full of surprises and that is
deep learning for you in short welcome
to this tutorial on deep learning now
there are several applications of deep
learning really very interesting and
innovative applications and one of them
is identifying the geographic location
based on a picture and how does this
work the way it works is pretty much we
train an artificial neural network with
millions of images which are tagged
their geolocation is tagged and then
when we feed a new picture it will be
able to identify the geolocation of this
new image for example you have all these
images especially with maybe some
significant monuments or
significant locations and you train with
millions of such images and then when
you feed another image it need not be
exactly one of those that you have
claimed it can be completely different
that is the whole idea of training it
will be able to recognize for example
that this is a picture from paris
because it is able to recognize the
eiffel tower so the way it works
internally if we have to look a little
bit under the heart as these images are
nothing but this is digital information
in the form of pixels so each image
could be a certain size it can be 256 by
256 pixel kind of a resolution and then
each pixel is either having a certain
grade of color and all that is fed into
the neural network and it then gets
trained in and it's able to based on
these pixels pixel information it is
able to get trained and able to
recognize the features and extract the
features and thereby it is able to
identify these images and the location
of these images and then when you feed a
new image it kind of based on the
training it will be able to figure out
where this image is from so that's the
way a little bit under the hood how it
works so what are we going to do in this
tutorial we will see what is deep
learning and what do we need for deep
learning and one of the main components
of deep learning is neural network so we
will see what is neural network what is
a perceptron and how to implement logic
gates like and or nor and so on using
perceptrons the different types of
neural networks and then applications of
deep learning and we will also see how
neural networks
works so how do we do the training of
and at the end we will end up with a
small demo code
which will take you through in
tensorflow now in order to implement
deep learning code there are multiple
libraries or development environments
that are available and tensorflow is one
of them so the focus at the end of this
would be on how to use tensorflow to
write a piece of code using python as a
programming language and we will take up
an example which is a very common one
which is like the hello world of deep
learning the handwriting number
recognition which is a mnist commonly
known as mnist database so we will take
a look at mnist database and how we can
train a neural network to recognize
handwritten numbers so that's what you
will see
in this particular
video so let's get started what is deep
learning deep learning is like a subset
of what is known as a high level concept
called artificial intelligence you must
be already familiar must have heard
about this term artificial intelligence
so artificial intelligence is like the
high level concept if you will and in
order to implement artificial
intelligence applications we
use what is known as machine learning
and within machine learning a subset of
machine learning is deep learning
machine learning is a little bit more
generic concept and deep learning is one
type of machine learning if you will and
we will see a little later in maybe the
following slides a little bit more in
detail how deep learning is different
from traditional machine learning but to
start with we can mention here that deep
learning uses one of the differentiators
between deep learning and traditional
machine learning is that deep learning
uses neural networks and we will talk
about what are neural networks and how
we can implement neural networks and so
on and so forth as a part of this
tutorial so a little deeper into deep
learning deep learning primarily
involves working with complicated
unstructured data compared to
traditional machine learning with where
we normally use structured data in deep
learning the data would be primarily
images or voice or maybe text files so
and it is large amount of data as well
and deep learning can handle complex
operations it involves complex
operations and the other difference
between traditional machine learning and
deep learning is that the feature
extraction happens pretty much
automatically in traditional machine
learning feature engineering is done
manually the data scientists we data
scientists have to do feature
engineering feature extraction but in
deep learning that happens automatically
and of course deep learning for large
amounts of data complicated unstructured
data deep learning gives very good
performance now as i mentioned one of
the secret
sources of deep learning is neural
networks let's see what neural networks
is neural networks is based on our
biological
neurons the whole concept of deep
learning and artificial intelligence is
based on human brain and human brain
consists of billions of tiny stuff
called neurons and this is how a
biological neuron looks and this is how
an artificial neuron looks so neural
networks is like a simulation of our
human brain human brain has billions of
biological neurons and we are trying to
simulate the human brain using
artificial neurons this is how a
biological neuron looks it has dendrites
and the corresponding component with an
artificial neural network is or an
artificial neuron are the inputs they
receive the inputs through dendrites and
then there is the cell nucleus which is
basically the processing unit in a way
so in artificial neuron also there is a
piece which is an equivalent of this
cell nucleus and based on the weights
and biases we will see what exactly
weights in biases are as we move the
input gets processed and that results in
an output in a biological neuron the
output is sent through a synapse and in
an artificial neuron there is an
equivalent of that in the form of an
output and biological neurons are also
interconnected so there are billions of
neurons which are interconnected in the
same way artificial neurons are also
interconnected so this output of this
neuron will be fed as an input to
another neuron and so on now in neural
network one of the very basic
units is a perceptron so what is a
perceptron a perceptron can be
considered as one of the fundamental
units of neural networks it can consist
at least one neuron but sometimes it can
be more than one neuron but you can
create a perceptron with a single neuron
and it can be used to perform certain
functions it can be used as a basic
binary classifier it can be trained to
do some basic binary classification and
this is how a basic perceptron looks
like and this is nothing but a neuron
you have inputs x 1 x 2 x 2 x n and
there is a summation function and then
there is what is known as an activation
function and based on this input what is
known as the weighted sum the activation
function either gets gives an output
like a zero or a one so we say the
neuron is either activated or not so
that's the way it works so you get the
inputs these inputs are each of the
inputs are multiplied by a weight and
there is a bias that gets added and that
whole thing is fed to an activation
function and then that results in an
output and if the output is correct it
is accepted if it is wrong if there is
an error then that error is fed back and
the neuron then adjusts the weights and
biases to give a new output and so on
and so forth so that's what is known as
the training process of a neuron or a
neural network there's a concept called
perceptron learning so perceptron
learning is again one of the very basic
learning processes the way it works is
somewhat like this so you have all these
inputs like x1 to xn and each of these
inputs is multiplied by a weight and
then that sum this is the formula of the
equation so that sum w i x i
sigma of that which is a sum of all
these product of x and w is added up and
then a bias is added to that the bias is
not dependent on the input but are the
input values but the bias is common for
one neuron however the bias value keeps
changing during the training process
once the training is completed the
values of these weights w1 w2 and so on
and the value of the bias gets fixed so
that is basically the whole training
process and that is what is known as the
perceptron training so the weights and
biases keep changing till you get the
accurate output and the summation is of
course passed through the activation
function as you see here this w i x i
summation plus b is passed through
activation function and then the neuron
gets either fired or not and based on
that there will be an output that output
is compared with the actual or expected
value which is also known as labeled
information this is the process of
supervised learning so the output is
already known and
that is compared and thereby we know if
there is an error or not and if there is
an error the error is fed back and the
weights and biases are updated
accordingly till the error is reduced to
the minimum so this iterative process
is
known as perceptron learning or
perceptron learning rule and this error
needs to be minimized so till the error
is minimized this iteratively the
weights and biases keep changing and
that is what is the training process so
the whole idea is to update the weights
and the bias of the perceptron till the
error is minimized the error need not be
zero the error may not ever reach zero
but the idea is to keep changing these
weights and bias so that the error is
minimum the minimum possible that it can
have so this whole process is an
iterative process and this is the
iteration continues till either the
error is zero which is uh unlikely
situation or it is the minimum possible
within these given conditions now in
1943 two scientists warren mcculloch and
walter pitts came up with an experiment
where they were able to implement the
logical functions like and or and nor
using neurons and that was a significant
breakthrough in a sense so they were
able to come up with the most common
logical gates they were able to
implement some of the most common
logical gates which could take two
inputs like a and b and then give a
corresponding result so for example in
case of an and gate a
and b and then the output is a b in case
of an or gate it is a plus b and so on
and so forth and they were able to do
this using a single
layer perceptron now most of these kits
it was possible to use single layer
perceptron except for xor and we will
see why that is in a little bit so this
is how an and gate works the inputs a
and b the output should be fired or the
neuron should be fired only when both
the inputs are one so if you have zero
zero the output should be zero for zero
1 it is again 0 1 0 again 0 and 1 1 the
output should be
1. so how do we implement this with the
neuron so it was found that by changing
the values of weights it is possible to
achieve this
logic so for example if we have equal
weights like 0.7 0.7 and then if we take
the sum of the weighted products so for
example 0.7 into 0 and then 0.7 into 0
will give you 0 and so on and so forth
and in the last case when both the
inputs are 1 you get a value which is
greater than 1 which is the threshold so
only in this case the neuron gets
activated and the output is there is an
output in all the other cases there is
no output because the threshold value is
one so this is implementation of an and
gate using a single perceptron or a
single neuron similarly an or gate in
order to implement an or gate in case of
an or gate the output will be one if
either of these inputs is one so for
example zero one will result in one or
other in all the cases it is one except
for zero zero so how do we implement
this using a perceptron once again if
you have a perceptron with weights for
example 1.2 now if you see here if in
the first case when both are 0 the
output is 0 in the second case when it
is 0 and 1 1.2 into 0 is 0 and then 1.2
into 1 is 1. and in the second case
similarly the output is 1.2 in the last
case when both the inputs are 1 the
output is 2.4 so during the training
process these weights will keep changing
and then at one point where the weights
are equal to w1 is equal to 1.2 and w2
is equal to 1.2 the system learns that
it gives the correct output so that is
implementation of or gate using a single
neuron or a single layer perceptron now
xor gate this was one of the challenging
ones they tried to implement an xor gate
with a single level perceptron but it
was not possible and therefore in order
to implement an xor so this was like a a
roadblock in the progress of
neural network however subsequently they
realized that this can be implemented an
xor gate can be implemented using
a multi-level perceptron or mlp so in
this case there are two layers instead
of a single layer and this is how you
can implement an xor gate so you will
see that x1 and x2 are the inputs and
there is a hidden layer and that's why
it is denoted as h3 and h4 and then you
take the output of that and feed it to
the output at o5 and provide a threshold
here so we will see here that this is
the
numerical calculation so the weights are
in this case for x1 it is 20 and minus
20 and once again 20 and minus 20. so
these inputs are fed into h3 and h4 so
you'll see here for h3 the input is 0 1
1 1 and for h4 it is 1 0 1 1 and if you
now look at the output final output
where the threshold is taken as 1 if we
use a sigmoid with the threshold one you
will see that in these two cases it is
zero and in the last two cases it is one
so this is a implementation of xor in
case of x or only when one of the inputs
is one you will get an output so that is
what we are seeing here if we have
either both the inputs are one or both
the inputs are zero then the output
should be zero so that is what is an
exclusive or gate so it is exclusive
because only one of the inputs should be
one and then only you will get an output
of one which is satisfied by this
condition so this is a special
implementation xor gate is a special
implementation of perceptron now that we
got a good idea about perceptron let's
take a look at what is the neural
network so we have seen what is a
perceptron we have seen what is a neuron
so we will see what exactly is a neural
network so neural network is nothing but
a network of these neurons and they are
different types of neural networks there
are about five of them these are
artificial neural network convolutional
neural network then recursive neural
network or recurrent neural network deep
neural network and deep belief network
so and each of these types of neural
networks have a special you know they
can
solve special kind of problems for
example convolutional neural networks
are very good at performing image
processing and image recognition and so
on whereas rnn are very good for speech
recognition and also text analysis and
so on so each type has some special
characteristics and they can they're
good at performing certain special kind
of tasks what are some of the
applications of deep learning deep
learning is today used extensively in
gaming you must have heard about alphago
which is a game created by a startup
called deepmind which got acquired by
google and alphago is an ai which
defeated the human world champion lee
sedol in this game of go so gaming is an
area where deep learning is being
extensively used and a lot of
research happens in the area of gaming
as well in addition to that nowadays
there are neural networks or special
type called
generative adversarial networks which
can be used for synthesizing either
images or music or text and so on and
they can be used to compose music so the
neural network can be trained to compose
a certain kind of music and autonomous
cars you must be familiar with google
google's self-driving car and today a
lot of automotive companies are
investing in this space and deep
learning is a core component of this
autonomous cars the cars are trained to
recognize for example the road
the lane markings on the road
signals any objects that are in front
any obstruction and so on and so forth
so all this involves deep learning so
that's another major application and
robots we have seen several robots
including sofia you may be familiar with
sophia who was given a citizenship by
saudi arabia and there are several such
robots which are very human like and the
underlying technology in many of these
robots is deep learning medical
diagnostics and health care is another
major area where deep learning is being
used and within healthcare diagnostics
again there are multiple areas where
deep learning and image recognition
image processing can be used for example
for cancer detection as you may be aware
if cancer is detected early on it can be
cured and one of the challenges is in
the availability of specialists who can
diagnose cancer using these diagnostic
images and various scans and and so on
and so forth so the idea is to train
neural network to perform some of these
activities so that the lord on the
cancer specialist doctors or oncologists
comes down and there is a lot of
research happening here and there are
already quite a few applications that
are claimed to be performing better than
human beings in this space can be
lung cancer it could be breast cancer
and so on and so forth so health care is
a major area where deep learning is
being applied let's take a look at the
inner working of a neural network so how
does an artificial neural network let's
say identify can we train a neural
network to identify the shapes like
squares and circles and triangles when
these images are fed so this is how it
works any image is nothing but it is a
digital information of the pixels so in
this particular case let's say this is
an image of 28 by 28 pixel and this is
an image of a square there is a certain
way in which the pixels are lit up and
so these pixels have a certain value
maybe from 0 to 256 and 0 indicates that
it is
black or it is dark and 256 indicates it
is completely it is white or lit up so
that is like an indication or a measure
of the how the pixels are lit up and so
this is an image is let's say consisting
of information of
784 pixels so all the information what
is inside this image can be kind of
compressed into this 784 pixels the way
each of these pixels is lit up provides
information about what exactly is the
image so
we can train neural networks to use that
information and identify the images so
let's take a look how this works so each
neuron the value if it is close to one
that means it is white whereas if it is
close to zero that means it is black now
this is a an animation of how this whole
thing works so these pixels one of the
ways of doing it is we can flatten
this image and take this complete 784
pixels and feed that as input to our
neural network the neural network can
consist of probably several layers there
can be a few hidden layers and then
there is an input layer and an output
layer now the input layer take the 784
pixels as input the values of each of
these pixels and then you get an output
which can be
of three types or three classes one can
be a square a circle or a triangle now
during the training process there will
be initially obviously you feed this
image and it will probably say it's a
circle or it will say it's a triangle so
as a part of the training process
we then send that error back and the
weights and the biases of these neurons
are adjusted till it correctly
identifies that this is a square that is
the whole training mechanism that
happens out here
now let's take a look at a circle same
way
so you feed these 784 pixels there is a
certain pattern in which the pixels are
lit up
and the neural network is trained to
identify that pattern and during the
training process once again it would
probably initially identify it
incorrectly saying this is a square or a
triangle and then that error is fed back
and the weights and biases are adjusted
finally till it finally gets the image
correct
so that is the training process so now
we will take a look at
same way a triangle
so now if you feed
another image which is consisting of
triangles so this is the training
process now we have trained our neural
network to classify these images into
a triangle or a circle and a square so
now this neural network can
identify these three types of objects
now if you feed another image and it
will be able to identify whether it's a
square or a triangle or a circle now
what is important to be observed is that
when you feed a new image it is not
necessary that
the image or the
the triangle is exactly in this position
now the neural network actually
identifies the patterns so even if the
triangle is let's say positioned here
not exactly in the middle but maybe at
the corner or in the side it would still
identify that it is a triangle and that
is the whole idea behind pattern
recognition so how does this training
process work this is a quick
view of how the training process works
so we have seen that a neuron consists
of inputs it receives inputs and then
there is a weighted sum which is nothing
but this x i wi summation of that plus
the
bias and this is then fed to the
activation function and that in turn
gives us a output now during the
training process initially obviously
when you feed these images when you send
maybe a square it will identify it as a
triangle and when you maybe feed a
triangle it will identify as a square
and so on so that error information is
fed back and initially these weights can
be random maybe all of them have zero
values and then it will slowly keep
changing so the as a part of the
training process the values of these
weights w1 w2 up to wn keep changing in
such a way that towards the end of the
training process it should be able to
identify these images correctly so till
then the weights are adjusted and that
is known as the training process so and
these weights are numeric values it
could be 0.5 0.25 0.35 and so on it
could be positive or it could be
negative and the value that is coming
here is the pixel value as we have seen
it can be anything between 0 to 1 you
can scale it between 0 to 1 or 0 to 256
whichever way 0 being black and 256
being white and then all the other
colors in between so that is the input
so these are numerical values this
multiplication or the product w i x i is
the numerical value and the bias is also
a numerical value we need to keep in
mind that the bias is fixed for a neuron
it doesn't change with the inputs
whereas the weights are one per input so
that is one important point to be noted
so but the bias also keeps changing
initially it will again have a random
value but as a part of the training
process the weights the values of the
weights w1 w2 wn and
the value of b
will change
and ultimately once the training process
is complete these values are fixed for
this particular neuron w1 w2 up to wn
and plus the value of the b is also
fixed for this particular neuron and in
this way there will be multiple neurons
and each there may be multiple levels of
neurons here and that's the way the
training process works so this is
another example of multi-layer so there
are two hidden layers in between and
then you have the input layer values
coming from the input layer then it goes
through multiple layers hidden layers
and then there is an output layer and as
you can see there are weights and biases
for each of these neurons in each layer
and all of them gets keeps changing
during the training process and at the
end of the training process all these
weights have a certain value and that is
a trained model and those values will be
fixed once the training is completed all
right then there is something known as
activation function neural networks
consists of one of the components in
neural networks is activation function
and every neuron has an activation
function and there are different types
of activation functions that are used it
could be a relu it could be sigmoid and
so on and so forth and the activation
function is what decides whether a
neuron should be fired or not so whether
the output should be 0 or 1 is decided
by the activation function and the
activation function in turn takes the
input which is the weighted sum remember
we talked about w i x i plus b that
weighted sum is fed as a input to the
activation function and then the output
can be either a zero or a one and there
are different types of activation
functions which are covered in an
earlier video you might want to watch
all right so as a part of the training
process we feed the inputs the label
data or the training data and then it
gives an output which is the predicted
output by the network which we indicate
as y hat and then there is a labeled
data because we for supervised learning
we already know what should be the
output so that is the actual output and
in the initial process before the
training is complete obviously there
will be error so that is measured by
what is known as a cost function so the
difference between the predicted output
and the actual output is the error and
the cost function can be defined in
different ways there are different types
of cost functions so in this case it is
like the average of the squares of the
error so
and then
all the errors are added which can
sometimes be called as sum of squares
sum of square errors or sse and that is
then fed as a feedback in what is known
as backward propagation or back
propagation and that helps in
the network adjusting the weights and
biases and so the weights and biases get
updated till this value the error value
or the cost function
is minimum now there is a optimization
technique which is used here called
gradient descent optimization and this
algorithm
works in a way that the error which is
the cost function
needs to be minimized so there's a lot
of mathematics that goes behind this for
example they find the local minima the
global minima using the differentiation
and so on and so forth but the idea is
this so as a training process
as a part of training the whole idea is
to
bring down the error which is like let's
say this is the function the cost
function at certain
levels it is very high the cost value of
the cost function the output of the cost
function is very high so
the weights have to be adjusted in such
a way and also the bias of course that
the cost function is minimized so there
is this optimization technique called
gradient descent that is used and this
is known as the learning rate now
gradient descent you need to specify
what should be the learning rate and the
learning rate should be optimal because
if you have a very high learning rate
then the optimization will not converge
because at some point it will cross over
to the side on the other hand if you
have very low learning rate then it
might take forever to convert so you
need to come up with the optimum value
of the learning rate and once that is
done using the gradient descent
optimization
the error function is reduced
and that's like the end of the training
process all right so this is another
view of gradient descent so this is how
it looks this is your cost function the
output of the cost function and that has
to be minimized using gradient descent
algorithm and these are like the
parameters and weight could be one of
them so initially we start with certain
random values so cost will be high and
then the weights keep changing and in
such a way that the cost function needs
to come down and at some point it may
reach the minimum value and then it may
increase so that is where the gradient
descent algorithm decides that okay it
has reached a minimum value and it will
kind of try to stay here this is known
as the global
minima now sometimes these curves may
not be just for explanation purpose this
has been drawn in a nice way but
sometimes these curves can be pretty
erratic there can be some local minima
here and then there is a peak and then
and so on so the whole idea of gradient
descent optimization is to identify the
global minima and to find the weights
and the bias at that particular point so
that's what is gradient descent and then
this is another example so you can have
these multiple local minima so as you
can see at this point when it is coming
down it may appear like this is a
minimum value but then it is not this is
actually the global minimum value and
the gradient is an algorithm will make
an effort to reach this level and not
get stuck at this point so the algorithm
is already there and it knows how to
identify this global minimum and that's
what it does during the training process
now in order to implement deep learning
there are multiple platforms and
languages that are available but the
most common platform nowadays is
tensorflow and so that's the reason we
have uh this tutorial we created this
tutorial for tensorflow so we will take
you through a quick demo of how to write
a tensorflow code using python and
tensorflow is
an open source platform created by
google so let's just take a look at the
details of tensorflow and so this is a
library a python library so you can use
python or any other languages it's also
supported in other languages like java
and r and so on but python is the most
common language that is used so
it is a library for
developing deep learning applications
especially using neural networks and it
consists of primarily two parts if you
will so one is the tensors and then the
other is the graphs or the flow that's
the way the name that's the reason for
this kind of a name called tensorflow so
what are tensor sensors are like
multi-dimensional
arrays if you will that's one way of
looking at it so usually you have a
one-dimensional array so first of all
you can have what is known as a scalar
which means a number and then you have a
one-dimensional array something like
this which means this like a set of
numbers so that is a one-dimensional
array then you can have a
two-dimensional array which is like a
matrix
and beyond that sometimes it gets
difficult so this is a three-dimensional
array but tensorflow can handle many
more dimensions so it can have
multi-dimensional
arrays that is the strength of
tensorflow and which makes computation
deep learning computation much faster
and that's the reason why tensorflow is
used for developing deep learning
applications so tensorflow is a deep
learning tool and this is the way it
works so the data basically flows in the
form of tensors and the way the
programming works as well is that you
first create a graph of how to execute
it and then you actually
execute that particular graph in the
form of what is known as a session you
will see this in the tensorflow code as
we move forward so all the data is
managed or manipulated in tensors and
then the processing happens using these
graphs there are certain terms called
like for example ranks of a tensor the
rank of a tensor is like a dimensional
dimensionality in a way so for example
if it is scalar so there is just a
number just one number the rank is
supposed to be zero and then it can be a
one dimensional vector in which case the
rank is supposed to be one and then you
can have a two dimensional vector
typically like a matrix then in that
case we say the rank is two and then if
it is a three-dimensional array then
rank is three and so on so it can have
more than three as well so it is
possible
that you can store
multi-dimensional arrays in the form of
tensors so what are some of the
properties of tensorflow i think today
it is one of the most popular
platform tensorflow is the most popular
deep learning
platform or library
it is open source it's developed by
google developed and maintained by
google but it is open source one of the
most important things about tensorflow
is that it can run on cpus as well as
gpus gpu is a graphical processing unit
just like cpu's central processing unit
now in earlier days gpu was used for
primarily for
graphics and that's how the name has
come and one of the reasons is that it
cannot perform generic activities very
efficiently like cpu
but it can perform iterative actions or
computations
extremely fast and much faster than a
cpu so they are really good for
computational activities and in deep
learning there is a lot of iterative
computation that happens so in the form
of matrix multiplication and so on so
gpus are very well suited for this kind
of computation and tensorflow supports
both gpu as well as cpu and there's a
certain way of writing code in
tensorflow we will see as we go into the
code and of course tensorflow can be
used for traditional machine learning as
well but then that would be an overkill
but just for understanding it may be a
good idea to start writing code for a
normal machine learning use case so that
you get a hang of how tensorflow code
works and then you can move into
neural networks so that is uh just a
suggestion but if you are already
familiar with how tensorflow works then
probably yeah you can go straight into
the neural networks part so in this
tutorial we will take the use case of
recognizing
handwritten digits this is like a hello
world of deep learning and this is a
nice little mnist database is a nice
little database that has images of
handwritten digits nicely formatted
because very often in deep learning and
neural networks we end up spending a lot
of time in preparing the data for
training and with mnist database we can
avoid that
you already have the data in the right
format which can be directly used for
training and mnist also offers a bunch
of
built-in utility functions that we can
straight away use and call those
functions without worrying about writing
our own functions and that's one of the
reasons why mnist database is very
popular for training purposes initially
when people want to learn about deep
learning and tensorflow this is the
database that is used and it has a
collection of 70 000 handwritten digits
and
a large part of them
are for training then you have test just
like in any machine learning process and
then you have validation and all of them
are labeled so you have the images and
their label and these images they look
somewhat like this so they are hand
written images collected from a lot of
individuals people have these are
samples written by human beings they
have hand written these numbers these
numbers going from zero to nine so
people have written these numbers and
then the images of those have been taken
and formatted in such a way that it is
very easy to handle so that is mnis
database and the way we are going to
implement this in our
tensorflow is we will feed this data
especially the training data along with
the label information and
the data is basically these images are
stored in the form of the pixel
information as we have seen in one of
the previous slides all the images are
nothing but these are pixels
so an image is nothing but an
arrangement of pixels and the value of
the pixel either it is lit up or it is
not or in somewhere in between that's
how the images are stored and that is
how they are fed into the neural network
and for training once the network is
trained when you provide a new image it
will be able to identify within a
certain error of course and for this we
will use one of the simpler neural
network configurations called softmax
and for simplicity what we will do is we
will flatten these pixels so instead of
taking them in a two-dimensional
arrangement we just flatten them out so
for example it starts from here it is a
28 by 28 so there are
784 pixels so pixel number one starts
here it goes all the way up to 28 then
29 starts here and goes up to 56 and so
on and the pixel number 784 is here so
we take all these pixels flatten them
out and feed them like one single line
into our
neural network and this is a what is
known as a soft max layer what it does
is once it is trained it will be able to
identify what digit this is so there are
in this output layer there are 10
neurons each signifying a digit and at
any given point of time when you feed an
image only
one of these 10 neurons gets activated
so for example if this is trained
properly and if you feed a number 9 like
this
then this particular neuron gets
activated so you get an output from this
neuron let me just use
a pen or a laser to show you here okay
so you're feeding the number nine let's
say this has been trained and now if
you're feeding a number nine this will
get activated now let's say you fade
one to the trained
network then this neuron will get
activated if you feed two this neuron
will get activated and so on i hope you
get the idea so this is one type of a
neural network or an activation function
known as softmax layer so that's what we
will be using here this is one of the
simpler ones for
quick and easy understanding so this is
how the code would look we will go into
our lab environment in the cloud and
we will show you there directly but very
quickly this is how the code looks and
let me run you through
briefly here and then we will go into
the jupiter notebook where the actual
code is and we will run that as well so
as a first step first of all we are
using python here and that's why the
syntax of the language is python and the
first step is to import the tensorflow
library so
and we do this by using this line of
code saying import tensorflow as tf df
is just for convenience so you can name
give any name and once you do this tf is
tensorflow is available as an object in
the name of tf and then you can run its
methods and accesses its attributes and
so on and so forth and mnist database is
actually an integral part of tensorflow
and that's again another reason why we
as a first step we always use this
example mnist database example so you
just simply import mnist database as
well using this line of code and you
slightly modify this so that the labels
are in this format what is known as one
hot true which means that the label
information is stored like an array and
let me just
use pen to show what exactly it is so
when you do this one hot true what
happens is each label is stored in the
form of an array of 10 digits and let's
say the number is
8 okay so in this case all the remaining
values there will be a bunch of zeros so
this is like array at position zero this
is at position one position two and so
on and so forth let's say this is
position seven then this is position
eight that will be one because our input
is eight and again position nine will be
zero okay so one hot encoding this one
hot encoding true will kind of load the
data in such a way that the labels are
in such a way that only one of the
digits has a value of 1 and that
indicates so based on which
digit is 1 we know what is the label so
in this case the eighth position is one
therefore we know this sample data the
value is eight similarly if you have a
two here let's say then the labeled
information will be somewhat like this
so you have your labels so you have this
as 0 the 0th position the first position
is also 0 the second position is 1
because this indicates number 2 and then
you have third as 0 and so on okay so
that is the significance of this one hot
true all right and then we can
check how the data is uh looking by
displaying the data and as i mentioned
earlier this is pretty much in the form
of digital form like numbers so all
these are like pixel values so you will
not really see an image in this format
but there is a way to
visualize that image i will show you in
a bit and this tells you how many images
are there in each set so the training
there are 55 000 images in training and
in the test set there are 10 000 and
then validation there are 5 000 so all
together there are 70 000
images all right so let's
move on and we can
view the actual
image by
using the matplotlib library and this is
how you can view this is the code for
viewing the images and you can view them
in color or you can view them in
grayscale so the c map is what tells in
what way we want to view it and what are
the maximum values and the minimum
values of the pixel values so these are
the max and minimum values so of the
pixel values so maximum is 1 because
this is a scaled value
so 1 means it is white and 0 means it is
black and in between is it can be
anywhere in between black and white
and the way to train the model there is
a certain way in which you write your
tensorflow code and
the first step is to create some
placeholders and then you create a model
in this case we will use the softmax
model one of the simplest ones and
placeholders are primarily to get the
data from outside into the neural
network so this is a very common
mechanism that is used and then of
course you will have variables which are
your you remember these are your weights
and biases so for in our case there are
10 neurons and each neuron actually has
784 because each neuron takes all the
inputs if we go back to our slide here
actually every neuron takes all the 784
inputs right this is the first neuron it
has it receives all the 784 this is the
second neuron this also receives all the
700. so each of these inputs needs to be
multiplied with the weight and that's
what we are talking about here so these
are
this is a
matrix
of
values for each of the neurons and so it
is like a 10 by 784
matrix because there are 10 neurons and
similarly there are
biases now remember i mentioned bias is
only one per neuron so it is not one per
input unlike the weights so therefore
there are only 10 biases because there
are only 10 neurons in this case so that
is what we are creating a variable for
biases so this is something little new
in tensorflow you will see unlike our
regular programming languages where
everything is a variable here the
variables can be of three different
types you have placeholders which are
primarily used for feeding data you have
variables which can change during the
course of computation and then a third
type which is not shown here are
constants so these are like fixed
numbers all right so in a regular
programming language you may have
everything as variables or at the most
variables and constants but in
tensorflow you have three different
types placeholders variables and
constants and then you create what is
known as a graph so tensorflow
programming consists of graphs and
tensors as i mentioned earlier so this
can be considered ultimately as a tensor
and then the graph tells how to execute
the whole implementation so that the
execution is stored in the form of a
graph and in this case what we are doing
is we are doing a multiplication tf you
remember this tf was created as a
tensorflow object here one more level
one more so tf is available here now
tensorflow has what is known as a matrix
multiplication or matmal
function so that is what is being used
here in this case so we are using the
matrix multiplication of tensorflow so
that you multiply your input values x
with w right this is what we were doing
x w plus b you're just adding b and this
is in very similar to one of the earlier
slides where we saw sigma x i wi so
that's what we are doing here matrix
multiplication is multiplying all the
input values with the corresponding
weights and then adding the bias so that
is the graph we created and then we need
to define what is our loss function and
what is our optimizer so in this case we
again use the tensorflow's apis so tf
dot nn
max cross entropy with logits is the
api that we will use and reduce mean is
what is like the mechanism whereby which
says that you reduce
the
error and optimizer for doing deduction
of the error what optimizer are we using
so we are using gradient descent
optimizer we discussed about this in a
couple of slides
earlier and for that you need to specify
the learning rate you remember we saw
that there was a
slide somewhat like this and then you
define
what should be the learning rate how
fast you need to come down that is the
learning rate and this again needs to be
tested and tried and to find out the
optimum level of this learning rate it
shouldn't be very high in which case it
will not converge or shouldn't be very
low because it will in that case it will
take very long so you define the
optimizer and then you call the method
minimize for that optimizer and that
will kick start the training process and
so far we've been creating the graph and
in order to actually execute that graph
we create what is known as a session and
then we run that session and once the
training is completed we specify how
many times how many iterations we want
it to run so for example in this case we
are saying thousand steps so that is a
exit strategy in a way so you specify
the exit condition so training will run
for thousand iterations and once that is
done we can then evaluate the model
using some of the techniques
shown here so
let us
get into the code quickly and see how it
works so this is our cloud environment
now you can install tensorflow on your
local machine as well i'm showing this
demo on our existing cloud but you can
also install tensorflow on your local
machine and there is a separate video on
how to set up your tensorflow
environment you can watch that if you
want to install your local environment
or you can go for other any cloud
service like for example google cloud
amazon or cloud labs any of these you
can
use and
run then try the code okay so it has got
started
we will login
all right so this is our deep learning
tutorial
code
and this is our tensorflow environment
and so let's get started
the first we have seen a little bit of a
code walkthrough
in the slides as well now you will see
the actual code in action so the first
thing we need to do is import tensorflow
and then we will import the data and we
need to adjust the data in such a way
that
the
one hot is encoding is set to true one
hot encoding right as i explained
earlier so in this case the label values
will be shown appropriately
and if we just check what is the type of
the data so you can see that this is a
data sets python
data sets and if we
check the number of
images the way it looks so this is how
it looks it is an array of type float32
similarly
the
number if you want to see what is the
number of
training images there are 55 000 then
there are test images 10 000 and then
validation images 5 000. now
let's take a quick look at the data
itself visualization so we will use um
matplotlib for this
and
if we take a look at the shape now shape
gives us like the dimension of the
tensors or
or the arrays if you will so in this
case the training data set if we see the
size of the training data set using the
method shape it says there are 55 000
and
55 000 by 784 so remember the 784 is
nothing but the 28 by 28 28 into 28 so
that is equal to 784 so that's what it
is uh showing now we can take just uh
one
image and just see
what is the
the first image and see what is the
shape so again size obviously it is only
784 similarly you can
look at the image itself the data of the
first image itself so this is how it
shows so large part of it will probably
be zeros because as you can imagine
in the image only certain areas are
written rest is
black so that's why you will mostly see
zeros either it is black or white but
then there are these values are so the
values are actually they are scaled so
the values are between zero and one okay
so this is what you're seeing so certain
locations there are some values and then
other locations there are zeros
so
that is how the data is stored and
loaded
if we want to actually see what is the
value of the handwritten image
if you want to view it this is how you
view it so you
create like do this reshape and
matplotlib has this
feature to show you these images so we
will actually use the function called
i am show and then if you pass this
parameters appropriately
you will be able to see the different
images now i can change the values in
this position so which image we are
looking at right so we can say
if i want to see what is there in maybe
right so
5000 has 3
similarly you can just say 5 what is in
5 as 8
what is in 50.
again 8 so basically by the way if
you're wondering uh how i'm executing
this code shift enter in case you're not
familiar with jupiter notebooks shift
enter is how you
execute each cell individual cell and if
you want to execute the entire program
you can go here and say run all
so that is how
this code gets executed
and
here again we can check what is the
maximum value and what is the minimum
value of this pixel values as i
mentioned this is it is scaled so
therefore it is between the values lie
between 1 and 0. now this is
where we create our model
the first thing is to create the
required placeholders and variables and
that's what we are doing here as we have
seen in the slides so we create
one placeholder and we create two
variables which is for the weights and
biases these two variables are actually
matrices so
each variable has
784 by 10
actual values okay so
one for this 10 is for each neuron there
are 10 neurons and 784 is for the pixel
values inputs that are given which is 28
into 28
and the biases as i mentioned
one for each neuron so there will be 10
biases they are stored in a variable by
the name b
and this is the graph which is basically
the multiplication of these matrix
multiplication of x into w and then the
bias is added for each of the neurons
and the whole idea is to minimize
the error so let me just execute i think
this code is executed then we define
what is our the y value is basically the
label value so this is another
placeholder we had x as one placeholder
and white underscore true as a second
placeholder and this will have values in
the form of uh 10-digit
10-digit arrays and
since we said one hot encoded the
position which has a one value indicates
what is the
label for that particular number all
right then we have cross entropy which
is nothing but
the
loss
loss function
and we have the optimizer we have chosen
gradient descent as our optimizer then
the training process itself so the
training process is nothing but to
minimize
the cross entropy which is again nothing
but the
loss function
so we define all of this in the form of
a graph so up to here remember what we
have done is we have not exactly
executed any tensorflow code till now we
are just preparing the graph the
execution plan that's how the tensorflow
code works so the whole structure and
format of this code will be completely
different from how we normally do
programming so even with people with
programming experience may find this a
little difficult to understand it and it
needs quite a bit of practice so you may
want to view this
video also maybe a couple of times to
understand this flow
because the way tensorflow programming
is done is
slightly different from the normal
programming some of you who
let's say have done
maybe spark programming to some extent
will be able to easily understand this
but even in spark the the programming
the code itself is pretty
straightforward behind the scenes the
execution happens slightly differently
but in tensorflow even the code has to
be written in a completely different way
so the code doesn't get executed
in the same way as you have written so
that that's something you need to
understand and a little bit of practice
is needed for this
so so far what we have done up to here
is creating the variables and feeding
the variables and
rather not feeding but setting up the
variables and
the graph that's all defining
maybe the
uh what kind of a network you want to
use for example we want to use softmax
and so on so you have
created the variables how to load the
data loaded the data viewed the data
and prepared everything but you have not
yet executed anything in tensorflow now
the next step is the execution intensive
law so the first step for doing any
execution in tensorflow is to initialize
the variables so anytime you have any
variables defined in your code you have
to run this piece of code always so you
need to basically create what is known
as a a node for initializing so this is
a node you still are not yet executing
anything here you just created a node
for the initialization
so let us go ahead and create that
and
here onwards is where you will actually
execute your code
in tensorflow and in order to execute
the code what you will need is a session
tensorflow session so tf.session will
give you a session and there are a
couple of different ways in which you
can do this but one of the most common
methods of doing this is with what is
known as a with loop so you have
with
dot session as says and with the
colon here and this is like a block
starting of the block and these
indentations tell how far this block
goes and
this session is valid till
this block gets executed so that is the
purpose of creating this width block
this is known as a width block so with
tf dot session as says you say
says
dot run init now says dot run will
execute
a node that is
specified here so for example here we
are saying says dot run says is
basically an instance of the session
right so here we are saying tf dot
session so an instance of the session
gets created and we are calling that
says and then we run
a node within that
one of the nodes in the graph so one of
the nodes here is init so we say run
that particular node and that is when
the initialization of the variables
happens now what this does is if you
have any
variables in your code in our case we
have w is a variable and b is a variable
so any variables that we created you
have to run this code you have to run
the initialization of these variables
otherwise you will get an error okay so
that is the that's what this is doing
then
we within this width block we specify a
for loop
and we are saying
we want the system to iterate for 1000
steps and perform the training
that's what this for loop does
run training for thousand iterations
and what it is doing basically is it is
fetching
the data or these images remember there
are about 50 000 images but it cannot
get all the images in one shot because
it will take up a lot of memory and
performance issues will be there so this
is a very common way of performing deep
learning training you always do in
batches so we have maybe 50 000 images
but you always do it in batches of 100
or maybe 500 depending on the size of
your system and so on and so forth so in
this case we are saying okay get me 100
images at a time and get me only the
training images remember we use only the
training data for training purpose and
then we use test data for test purpose
you must be familiar with machine
learning so you must be aware of this
but in case you are not in machine
learning also not this is not specific
to deep learning but in machine learning
in general you have what is known as
training data set and test data set your
available data typically you will be
splitting into two parts and using the
training data set for training purpose
and then to see how well the model has
been trained you use the test data set
to check or test the validity or the
accuracy of the model so that's what we
are doing here and you observe here that
we are actually calling an mnist
function here so we are saying mnist
train dot next batch
right so this is the advantage of using
mnist database because they have
provided some very nice helper functions
which are readily available otherwise
this activity itself we would have had
to write a piece of code to fetch this
data in batches that itself is a lengthy
exercise so we can avoid all that if we
are using mnist database and that's why
we use this for the initial learning
phase okay so when we say fetch what it
will do is it will fetch the images into
x and the labels into y and then you
use this
batch of 100 images and you run the
training so says dot run basically what
we are doing here is we are running the
training mechanism which is nothing but
it passes this through the neural
network passes the images through the
neural network finds out what is the
output and if the output obviously the
initially it will be wrong so all that
feedback is given back to the neural
network and thereby all the w's and b's
get updated
till it reaches thousand iterations in
this case
the exit criteria is thousand but you
can also specify probably accuracy rate
or something like that for the as an
exit criteria so here it is it just says
that okay this particular image was
wrongly predicted so you need to update
your weights and biases that's the
feedback given to each neuron and that
is run for 1000 iterations and typically
by the end of this thousand iterations
the model would have learned to
recognize these handwritten images
obviously it will not be 100 accurate
okay so once that is done
after so this happens for 1000
iterations once that is done
you then test the accuracy of these
models by using the test data set right
so this is what we are trying to do here
the code may appear a little complicated
because if you're seeing this for the
first time you need to understand uh the
various methods of tensorflow and so on
but it is basically comparing the output
with
what has been what is actually there
that's all it is doing so you have your
test data and you're trying to find out
what is the actual value and what is the
predicted value and seeing whether they
are equal or not tf dot equal right and
how many of them are correct and so on
and so forth and based on that the
accuracy is
calculated as well so this is the
accuracy and that is what we are trying
to see how accurate the model is in
predicting these numbers or these digits
okay so let us run this this entire
thing is in one cell so we will have to
just run it in one shot it may take a
little while let us see
and
not bad so it has finished the thousand
iterations and what we see here as an
output is the accuracy so we see that
the accuracy of this model
is around 91 percent okay now which is
pretty good for such a short exercise
within such a short time we got 90
percent accuracy however in real life
this is probably not sufficient so there
are other ways in to increase the
accuracy we will see probably in some of
the later tutorials how to improve this
accuracy how to change maybe the hyper
parameters like number of neurons or
number of layers and so on and so forth
and
so that this accuracy can be increased
beyond 90 percent let's look at the
different types of artificial neural
networks and this is like the biggest
area growing is how these all come
together let's see the different types
of neural network and
again we're comparing this to human
learning so here's a human brain i feel
sorry for that poor guy so we have a
feed for forward neural network simplest
form of a they call it a a n a neural
network data travels only in one
direction input to output this is what
we just looked at so as the data comes
in all the weights are added it goes to
the hidden layer all the weights are
added it goes to the next hidden layer
all the weights are added and it goes to
the output the only time you use the
reverse propagation is to train it so
when you actually use it it's very fast
when you're training it it takes a while
because it has to iterate through all
your training data and you start getting
into big data because you can train
these with a huge amount of data the
more data you put in the better train
they get the applications vision and
speech recognition actually they're
pretty much everything we talked about a
lot almost all of them use this form of
neural network at some level radial
basis function neural network this model
classifies the data point based on its
distance from a center point what that
means is that you might not have
training data so you want to group
things together and you create central
points and it looks for all the things
you know some of these things are just
like the other if you've ever watched
the sesame street as a kid that dates me
so it brings things together and this is
a great way if you don't have the right
training model you can start finding
things that are connected you might not
have noticed before applications power
restoration systems they try to figure
out what's connected and then based on
that they can fix the problem if you
have a huge power system cajon and
self-organizing neural network vectors
of random dimensions are input to
discrete map comprised of neurons so
they basically find a way to draw they
call them they say dimensions or vectors
or planes because they actually chop the
data in one dimension two dimension
three dimension four five six they keep
adding dimensions and finding ways to
separate the data and connect different
data pieces together applications used
to recognize patterns and data like in
medical analysis the hidden layer saves
its output to be used for future
prediction recurrent neural networks so
the hidden layers remember its output
from last time and that becomes part of
its new input you might use that
especially in robotics or flying a drone
you want to know what your last change
was and how fast it was going to help
predict what your next change you need
to make is to get to where the drone
wants to go applications text-to-speech
conversation model so i talked about
drones but you know just identifying on
lexus or google assistant or any of
these they're starting to add in i'd
like to play a song on my pandora and
i'd like it to be at volume 90
so you now can add different things in
there and it connects them together the
input features are taken in batches like
a filter this allows a network to
remember an image in parts convolution
neural network today's world in photo
identification and taking apart photos
and trying to you know you ever seen
that on google where you have five
people together this is the kind of
thing separates all those people so then
it can do a face recognition on each
person applications used in signal and
image processing in this case i use
facial images or google picture images
as one of the options modular neural
network it has a collection of different
neural networks working together to get
the output so wow we just went through
all these different types of neural
networks and the final one is to put
multiple neural networks together i
mentioned that a little bit when we
separated people in a larger photo in
individuals in the photo and then do the
facial recognition on each person so one
network is used to separate them and the
next network is then used to figure out
who they are and do the facial
recognition applications still
undergoing research this is a cutting
edge you hear the term pipeline and
there's actual in python code and in
almost all the different neural network
setups out there they now have a
pipeline feature usually and it just
means you take the data from one neural
network and maybe another neural network
or you put it into the next neural
network and then you take three or four
other neural networks and feed them into
another one so how we connect the neural
networks is really just cutting edge and
it's so experimental i mean it's almost
creative in its nature there's not
really a science to it because each
specific domain has different things
it's looking at so if you're in the
banking domain it's going to be
different than the medical domain then
the automatic car domain and suddenly
figuring out how those all fit together
is just a lot of fun and really cool so
we have our types of artificial neural
network we have our feed forward neural
network we have a radial basis function
neural network we have our cohenon
self-organizing neural network recurrent
neural network convolution neural
network and modular neural network where
it brings them all together and no the
colors on the brain do not match what
your brain actually does but they do
bring it out that most of these were
developed by understanding how humans
learn and as we understand more and more
of how humans learn we can build
something in the computer industry to
mimic that to reflect that and that's
how these were developed so exciting
part use case problem statement so this
is where we jump in this is my favorite
part let's use the system to identify
between a cat and a dog if you remember
correctly i said we're going to do some
python code and you can see over here my
hair is kind of sticking up over the
computer cup of coffee on one side and a
little bit of old school a pencil and a
pen on the other side yeah most people
now take notes
i love the stickies on the computer
that's great that's that is my computer
i have sticky notes on my computer in
different colors so not too far from
today's programmer so the problem is is
we want to classify photos of cats and
dogs using a neural network and you can
see over here we have quite a variety of
dogs in the pictures and cats and you
know just sorting out it is a cat it's
pretty amazing and why would anybody
want to even know the difference between
a cat and a dog okay you know why well i
have a cat door it'd be kind of fun that
instead of it identifying instead of
having like a little collar with a
magnet on it which is what my cat has
the door would be able to see oh that's
the cat that's our cat coming in oh
that's the dog we have a dog too that's
a dog i want to let in maybe i don't
want to let this other animal in because
it's a raccoon so you can see where you
could take this one step further and
actually apply this you could actually
start a little startup company idea
self-identifying door so this use case
will be implemented on python i am
actually in python 3.6 it's always nice
to tell people the version of python
because it does affect sometimes which
modules you load and everything and
we're going to start by importing the
required packages i told you we're going
to do this in keras so we're going to
import from karas models sequential from
the cross layers conversion 2d or conv
2d max pooling 2d flatten and dense and
we'll talk about what each one of these
do in just a second but before we do
that let's talk a little bit about the
environment we're going to work in and
you know in fact let me go ahead and
open a
the website crosses website so we can
learn a little bit more about karas so
here we are on the cross website and
it's a
k-e-r-a-s dot io that's the official
website for karass and the first thing
you'll notice is that cross runs on top
of either tensorflow
cntk and i think it's pronounced thanos
or theano what's important on here is
that tensorflow and the same is true for
all these but tensorflow is probably one
of the most widely used currently
packages out there with the cross and of
course you know tomorrow this is all
going to change it's all going to
disappear and they'll have something new
out there so make sure when you're
learning this code that you understand
what's going on and also know the code i
mean look when you look at the code it's
not as complicated once you understand
what's going on the code itself is
pretty straightforward and the reason we
like cross and the reason that people
are jumping on it right now is such a
big deal is if we come down here let me
just scroll down a little bit they talk
about user friendliness modularity easy
extensibility work with python python is
a big one because a lot of people in
data science now use python although you
can actually access cross other ways if
we continue down here is layers and this
is where it gets really cool when we're
working with cross you just add layers
on remember those hidden layers we were
talking about and we talked about the
relu
activation you can see right here let me
just up that a little bit in size
there we go that's big i can add in an
relu layer and then i can add in a soft
max layer the next instance we didn't
talk about soft max so you could do each
layer separate now if i'm working in
some of the other kits i use i take that
and i have one set up and then i feed
the output into the next one this one i
can just add hidden layer after hidden
layer with a different information in it
which makes it very powerful and very
fast to spin up and try different setups
and see how they work with the data
you're working on and we'll dig a little
bit deeper in here and a lot of this is
very much the same so when we get to
that part i'll point that out to you
also now just a quick side note i'm
using anaconda with python in it and i
went ahead and created my own package
and i called it the cross python 36
because i'm in python 36. anaconda's
cool that way you can create different
environments real easily if you're doing
a lot of different experimenting with
these different packages probably want
to create your own environment in there
and the first thing as you can see right
here there's a lot of dependencies a lot
of these you should recognize by now if
you've done any of these videos if not
kudos for you for jumping in today pip
install numpy scipy the scikit learn
pillow and h5py are both needed for the
tensorflow and then putting the cross on
there and then you'll see here and pip
is just a standard installer that you
use with python you'll see here that we
did pip install tensorflow sensor we're
going to do cross on top of tensorflow
and then pip install and i went ahead
and used the github so git plus git and
you'll see here github.com this is one
of their releases one of the most
current release on there that goes on
top of tensorflow you can look up these
instructions pretty much anywhere this
is for doing it on anaconda certainly
you'd want to install these if you're
doing it in ubuntu server setup you'd
want to get i don't think you need the
h5py and ubuntu but you do need the rest
in there because they are dependencies
in there and it's pretty straightforward
and that's actually in some of the
instructions they have on their website
so you don't have to initially go
through this just remember their website
on there and then when i'm under my
anaconda navigator which i like you'll
see where i have environments and on the
bottom i created a new environment and i
called it cross python 36 just to
separate everything you can see i have
python 30.5 and python 36 i used to have
a bunch of other ones but it kind of
cleaned house recently and of course
once i go in here i can launch my
jupiter notebook making sure i'm using
the right environment that i just set up
this of course opens up my
in this case i'm using google chrome and
in here i could go and just create a new
document in here and this is all in your
browser window when you use the anaconda
do you have to use anaconda and jupyter
notebook no you can use any kind of
python editor whatever setup you're
comfortable with and whatever you're
doing in there so let's go ahead and go
in here and paste the code in and we're
importing a number of different settings
in here we have import sequential that's
under the models because that's the
model we're going to use as far as our
neural network and then we have layers
and we have conversion 2d max pooling 2d
flatten dense and you can actually just
kind of guess at what these do we're
talking we're working in a 2d photograph
and if you remember correctly i talked
about how the actual input layer is a
single array it's not in two dimensions
it's one dimension all these do is these
are tools to help flatten the image so
it takes a two-dimensional image and
then it creates its own proper setup you
don't have to worry about any of that
you don't have to do anything special
with the photograph you let the cross do
it we're going to run this and you'll
see right here they have some stuff that
is going to be depreciated and changed
because that's what it does everything's
being changed as we go you don't have to
worry about that too much if you have
warnings if you run it a second time the
warning will disappear and this is just
imported these packages for us to use
jupiter is nice about this that you can
do each thing step by step and i'll go
ahead and also zoom in there a little
control plus that's one of the nice
things about being in a browser
environment so here we are back another
sip of coffee
if you're familiar with my other videos
you'll notice i'm always sipping coffee
i always have a my case latte next to me
an espresso so the next step is to go
ahead and initialize we're going to call
it the cnn or classifier neural network
and the reason we call it a classifier
is because it's going to classify it
between two things it's going to be cat
or dog so when you're doing
classification you're just picking
specific objects your specific it's a
true or false yes no it is something or
it's not so first thing we're going to
create our classifier and it's going to
equal sequential so their sequential
setup is the classifier that's the
actual model we're using that's the
neural network so we call it a
classifier and the next step is to add
in our convolution and let me just do a
let me shrink that down in size you can
see the whole line and let's talk a
little bit about what's going on here i
have my classifier and i add something
what am i adding well i'm adding my
first layer this first layer we're
adding in is probably the one that takes
the most work to make sure you have it
set correct and the reason i say that
this is your actual input and we're
going to jump here to the part that says
input shape equals 64 by 64 by 3. what
does that mean well that means that our
pictures coming in and there's these
pictures remember we had like the
picture of the car was 128 by 128 pixels
well this one is 64 by 64 pixels and
each pixel has three values that's where
these numbers come from and it is so
important that this matches i mentioned
a little bit that if you have like a
larger picture you have to reformat it
to fit this shape if it comes in as
something larger there's no input notes
there's no input neural network there
that will handle that extra space so you
have to reshape your data to fit in here
now the first layer is the most
important because after that keras knows
what your shape is coming in here and it
knows what's coming out and so that
really sets the stage most important
thing is that input shape matches your
data coming in and you'll get a lot of
errors if it doesn't you'll go through
there and picture number 55 doesn't
match it correctly and guess what it
does it usually gives you an error and
then the activation if you remember we
talked about the different activations
on here we're using the relu model like
i said that is the most commonly used
now because one it's fast doesn't have
the added calculations in it it just
says here's the value coming out based
on the weights and the value going in
and um from there you know it's uh it's
if it's over one then it's good or over
zero it's good if it's under zero then
it's considered not active and then we
have this conversion 2d what the heck is
conversion 2d i'm not going to go into
too much detail in this because this has
a couple of things it's doing in here a
little bit more in-depth than we're
ready to cover in this tutorial but this
is used to convert from the photo
because we have 64 by 64x3 and we're
just converting it to two-dimensional
kind of setup so it's very aware that
this is a photograph and that different
pieces are next to each other and then
we're going to add in a second
convolutional layer that's what the conv
stands for 2d so these are hidden layers
so we have our input layer and our two
hidden layers and they are
two-dimensional because we're doing with
a two-dimensional photograph and you'll
see down here that on the last one we
add a max pooling 2d and we put a pool
size equals 2 2. and so what this is is
that as you get to the end of these
layers one of the things you always want
to think of is what they call mapping
and then reducing wonderful terminology
from the big data we're mapping this
data through all these layers and now we
want to reduce it to only two sets in
this case it's already in two sets
because the 2d photograph but we had you
know two dimensions by we actually have
64 by 64 by three so now we're just
getting it down to a two by two just the
two dimension two dimensional instead of
having the third dimension of colors and
we'll go ahead and run these we're not
really seeing anything on our run script
because we're just setting up this is
all set up and this is where you start
playing because maybe you'll add a
different layer in here to do something
else to see how it works and see what
your output is that's what makes cross
so nice is i can with just a couple
flips of code put in a whole new layer
that does a whole new processing and see
whether that improves my run or makes it
worse and finally we're going to do the
final setup which is to flatten
classifier add a flattened setup and
then we're going to also add a layer a
dense layer and then we're going to add
in another dense layer and then we're
going to build it we're going to compile
this whole thing together so let's flip
over and see what that looks like and
we've even numbered them for you so
we're going to do the flattening and
flatten is exactly what it sounds like
we've been working in a two-dimensional
array of picture which actually is in
three dimensions because of the pixels
the pixels have a whole nother dimension
to it of three different values and
we've kind of resized those down to two
by two but now we're just going to
flatten it i don't want to have multiple
dimensions being worked on by tensor and
by keras i want just a single array so
it's flattened out and then step four
full connection so we add in our final
two layers and you could actually do all
kinds of things with this you could
actually leave out this some of these
layers and play with them you do need to
flatten it that's very important then we
want to use the dents again we're taking
this and we're taking whatever came into
it so once we take all those different
the two dimensions or three dimensions
as they are and we flatten it to one
dimension we want to take that and we're
going to pull it into units of 128 they
got that you say where did they get 128
from you could actually play with that
number and get all kinds of weird
results but in this case we took the 64
plus 64 as 128. you could probably even
do this with 64 or 32. usually you want
to keep it in the same multiple whatever
the data shape you're already using is
in and we're using the activation the
relu just like we did before and then we
finally filter all that into a single
output and it has how many units one why
because we want to know whether true or
false it's either a dog or a cat you
could say one is dog zero is cat or
maybe you're a cat lover and it's one is
cat and zero is dog if you love both
dogs and cats
you're gonna have to choose and then we
use the sigmoid activation if you
remember from before we had the relu and
there's also the sigmoid the sigmoid
just makes it clear it's yes or no we
don't want a any kind of in between
number coming out and we'll go ahead and
run this and you'll see it's still all
in setup and then finally we want to go
ahead and compile and let's put the
compiling our classifier neural network
and we're going to use the optimizer
atom and i hinted at this just a little
bit before where does adam come in where
does an optimizer come in well the
optimizer is the reverse propagation
when we're training it it goes all the
way through and says error and then how
does it readjust those weights there are
a number of them atom is the most
commonly used and it works best on large
data most people stick with the atom
because when they're testing on smaller
data see if their model is going to go
through and get all their errors out
before they run it on larger data sets
they're going to run it on atom anyway
so they just leave it on atom most
commonly used but there are some other
ones out there you should be aware of
that that you might try them if you're
stuck in a bind or you might blur that
in the future but usually atom is just
fine on there and then you have two more
settings you have loss and metrics we're
not going to dig too much into loss or
metrics these are things you really have
to explore cross because there are so
many choices this is how it computes the
error there's so many different ways to
on your back propagation and your
training so we're using the atom model
but you can compute the error by
standard deviation standard deviation
squared they use binary cross entropy
i'd have to look that up to even know
what that is there's so many of these a
lot of times you just start with the
ones that look correct that are most
commonly used and then you have to go
read the cross site and actually see
what these different losses and metrics
and what different options they have so
we're not going to get too much into
them other than to reference you over to
the karass website to explore them
deeper but we are going to go ahead and
run them and now we've set up our
classifier so we have an object
classifier and if you go back up here
you'll see that we've added in step one
we added in our layer for the input we
added a layer that comes in there and
uses the relu for activation and then it
pulls the data so this is even though
these are two layers the actual neural
network layer is up here and then it
uses this to pull the data into a two by
two so into a two dimensional array from
a three-dimensional array with the
colors then we flatten it so there's our
outer flattened and then we add another
dense what they call dense layer this
dense layer goes in there and it
downsizes it to 128 it reduces it so you
can look at this as we're mapping all
this data down the two-dimensional setup
and then we flatten it so we map it to a
flattened map and then we take it and
reduce it down to 128
and we use the relu again and then
finally we reduce that down to just a
single output and we use the sigmoid to
do that to figure out whether it's yes
no true false in this case cat or dog
and then finally once we put all these
layers together we compile them that's
what we've done here and we've compiled
them as far as how it trains to use
these settings for the training back
propagation so if you remember we talked
about training our setup and when we go
into this you'll see that we have two
data sets we have one called the
training set and the testing set and
that's very standard in any data
processing is you need to have that's
pretty common in any data processing is
you need to have a certain amount of
data to train it and then you got to
know whether it works or not is it any
good and that's why you have a separate
set of data for testing it or you
already know the answer but you don't
want to use that as part of the training
set so in here we jump into part two
fitting the classifier neural network to
the images and then from cross let me
just zoom in there i always love that
about working with jupiter notebooks you
can really see we're going to come in
here we do the cross pre-processing and
image and we import image data generator
so nice of course it's such a high-end
product right now going out and since
images are so common they already have
all this stuff to help us process the
data which is great and so we come in
here we do train data gin and we're
going to create our object for helping
us train it for reshaping the data so
that it's going to work with our setup
and we use an image data generator and
we're going to rescale it and you'll see
here we have one point which tells us
it's a float value on the rescale over
255. where does 255 come from well
that's the scale in the colors of the
pictures we're using their value from 0
to 255. so we want to divide it by 255
and it will generate a number between 0
and 1. they have shear range and zoom
range horizontal flip equals true and
this of course has to do with if the
photos are different shapes and sizes
like i said it's a wonderful package you
really need to dig in deep to see all
the different options you have for
setting up your images for right now
though we're going to stick with some
basic stuff here and let me go ahead and
run this code and again it doesn't
really do anything because we're still
setting up the pre-processing let's take
a look at this next set of code and this
one is just huge we're creating the
training set so the training set is
going to go in here and it's going to
use our train data gen we just created
dot flow from directory it's going to
access in this case the path data set
training set that's a folder so it's
going to pull all the images out of that
folder now i'm actually running this in
the folder that the data sets in so if
you're doing the same setup and you load
your data in there and you're doing this
make sure wherever your jupyter notebook
is saving things to that you create this
path or you can do the complete path if
you need to you know see colon slash etc
and the target size the batch size and
class mode is binary so the classes
we're switching everything to a binary
value back size what the heck is batch
size well that's how many pictures we're
going to batch through the training each
time and the target size 64 by 64. a
little confusing but you can see right
here that this is just a general
training and you can go in there and
look at all the different settings for
your training set and of course with
different data we're doing pictures
there's all kinds of different settings
depending on what you're working with
let's go ahead and run that and see what
happens and you'll see that it found 800
images belonging to one classes so we
have 800 images in the training set and
if we're going to do this with the
training set we also have to format the
pictures in the test set now we're not
actually doing any predictions we're not
actually programming the model yet all
we're doing is preparing the data so
we're going to prepare a training set
and the test set so any changes we make
to the training set at this point also
have to be made to the test set so we've
done this thing we've done a train data
generator we've done our training set
and then we also have remember our test
set of data so i'm going to do the same
thing with that i'm going to create a
test data gen and we're going to do this
image data generator we're going to
rescale 1 over 255 we don't need the
other settings just the single setting
for the test data gen and we're going to
create our test set we're going to do
the same thing we did with the test set
except that we're pulling it from the
test set folder and we'll run that and
you'll see in our test set we found 2
000 images that's about right we're
using 20 percent of the images as test
and 80 to train it and then finally
we've set up all our data we've set up
all our layers which is where all the
work is is cleaning up that data and
making sure it's going in there
correctly and we're actually going to
fit it we're going to train our data set
and let's see what that looks like and
here we go let's put the information in
here and let's just take a quick look at
what we're looking at with our fit
generator we have our classifier dot fit
generator that's our back propagation so
the information goes through forward
with a picture and it says up you're
either right or you're wrong and then
the air goes backward and reprograms all
those weights so we're training our
neural network and of course we're using
the training set remember we created the
training set up here and then we're
going steps per epic so it's 8 000 steps
epic means that that's how many times we
go through all the pictures so we're
going to rerun each of the pictures and
we're going to go through the whole data
set 25 times but we're going to look at
each picture during each epic 8 000
times so we're really programming the
heck out of this and going back over it
and then they have validation data
equals test set so we have our training
set and then we're going to have our
test set to validate it so we're going
to do this all in one shot and we're
going to look at that and they're going
to do 200 steps for each validation and
we'll see what that looks like in just a
minute let's go ahead and run our
training here and we're going to fit our
data and as it goes it says epic one of
25 you start realizing that this is
going to take a while on my older
computer it takes about 45 minutes i
have a dual processor and we're
processing uh 10 000 photos that's not a
small amount of photographs to process
so if you're on your laptop you know
which i am it's going to take a while so
let's go ahead and go get our cup of
coffee and a sip and come back and see
what this looks like so i'm back you
didn't know i was gone that was actually
a lengthy pause there i made a couple
changes and let's discuss those changes
real quick and why i made them so the
first thing i'm going to do is i'm going
to go up here and insert a cell above
and let's paste the original code back
in there and you'll see that the
original thing was steps per epic 8
twenty-five epics and validation steps
two thousand and i changed these to four
thousand epics or four thousand steps
per epic
ten epics and uh just ten validation
steps and this will cause problems if
you're doing this as a commercial
release but for demo purposes this
should work and if you remember our
steps per epic that's how many photos
we're going to process in fact let me go
ahead and get my drawing pin out and
let's just highlight that right here we
have 8 000 pictures we're going through
so for each epic i'm going to change
this to 4000 i'm going to cut that in
half so it's going to randomly pick 4
000 pictures each time it goes through
an epic and the epic is how many
processes so this is 25 and i'm just
going to cut that to 10. so instead of
doing 25 runs through 8 000 photos each
which you can do the math of 25 times 8
000. i'm only going to do 10 through 4
000 so i'm going to run this 40 000
times through the processes and the next
thing i notice you'll you'll want to
notice is that i also changed the
validation step and this would cause
some major problems in releasing because
i dropped it all the way down to 10.
what the validation step does is it says
we have 2 000 photos in our trainings or
in our testing set and we're going to
use that for validation well i'm only
going to use a random 10 of those to
validate so not really the best settings
but let me show you why we did that
let's scroll down here just a little bit
and let's look at the output here and
see what that what's going on there so
i've got my drawing tool back on and
you'll see here it lists a run so each
time it goes through an epic it's going
to do 4 000 steps and this is where the
4000 comes in so that's what we have we
have epic one of 10 4 000 steps it's
randomly picking half the pictures in
the file and going through them and then
we're going to look at this number right
here that is for the whole epic and
that's 2411
seconds and if you remember correctly
you divide that by 60 you get minutes if
you divide that by 60 you get hours or
you can just divide the whole thing by
60 times 60 which is 3600. if 3600 is an
hour this is roughly 45 minutes right
here and that's 45 minutes to process
half the pictures so if i was doing all
the pictures we're talking an hour and a
half per epic times 36 or no 25 they had
25 up above 25. so that's roughly a
couple days a couple days of processing
well for this demo we don't want to do
that i don't want to come back the next
day plus my computer did a reboot in the
middle of the night so we look at this
and we say okay let's we're just testing
this out my computer that i'm running
this on is a dual core processor runs .9
gigahertz per second for a laptop it was
good about four years ago but for
running something like this is probably
a little slow so we cut the times down
and the last one was validation we're
only validating it on a random 10 photos
and this comes into effect because
you're going to see down here where we
have accuracy value loss
value accuracy and loss those are very
important numbers to look at so the 10
means i'm only validating across 10
pictures that is where here we have
value this is acc is for accuracy value
loss we're not going to worry about that
too much and accuracy now accuracy is
while it's running it's putting these
two numbers together that's what
accuracy is and value accuracy is at the
end of the epic what's our accuracy into
the epic what is it looking at in this
tutorial we're not going to go so deep
but these numbers are really important
when you start talking about these two
numbers reflect bias that is really
important let's just put that up there
and bias is a little bit beyond this
tutorial but the short of it is is if
this accuracy which is being our
validation per step is going down and
the value accuracy continues to go up
that means there's a bias that means i'm
memorizing the photos i'm looking at i'm
not actually looking for what makes a
dog a dog what makes a cat a cat i'm
just memorizing them and so the more
this discrepancy grows the bigger the
bias is and that is really the beauty of
the cross
neural network is a lot of built-in
features like this that make that really
easy to track so let's go ahead and take
a look at the next set of code so here
we are into part three we're going to
make a new prediction and so we're going
to bring in a couple tools for that and
then we have to process the image coming
in and find out whether it's an actual
dog or cat we can actually use this to
identify it and of course the final step
of part three is to print prediction
we'll go ahead and combine these and of
course you can see me there adding more
sticky notes to my computer screen
hidden behind the screen and you know
last one was don't forget to feed the
cat and the dog
so let's go and take a look at that and
see what that looks like in code and put
that in our jupiter notebook all right
and let's paste that in here and we'll
start by importing numpy as np numpy is
a very common package i pretty much
imported on any python project i'm
working on another one i use regularly
is pandas they're just ways of
organizing the data and then np is
usually the standard in most machine
learning tools as a return for the data
array although you know you use a
standard data array from python and we
have cross pre-processing import image
fish that all look familiar because
we're going to take a test image and
we're going to set that equal to in this
case cat or dog one as you can see over
here and you know let me get my drawing
tool back on so let's take a look at
this we have our test image we're
loading and in here we have test image
one and this one hasn't data hasn't seen
this one at all so this is all new let
me shrink the screen down let me start
that over so here we have my test image
and we went ahead and the cross
processing has this nice image set up so
we're going to load the image and we're
going to alter it to a 64 by 64 print so
right off the bat we're going to cross
as nice that way it automatically sets
it up for us so we don't have to redo
all our images and find a way to reset
those and then we use also to set the
image to an array so again we're all in
pre-processing the data just like we
pre-processed before with our test
information and our training data and
then we use the numpy here's our numpy
that's uh from our right up here
important numpy as in p expand the
dimensions test image axes equals zero
so it puts it into a single array and
then finally
all that work all that pre-processing
and all we do is we run the result we
click on here we go result equals
classifier predict test image and then
we find out well what is the test image
and let's just take a quick look and
just see what that is and you can see
when i ran it it comes up dog and if we
look at those images there it is cat or
dog image number one that looks like a
nice floppy eared lab
friendly with his tongue hanging out
it's either that or a very floppy eared
cat i'm not sure which but coordinator
software says it's a dog and uh we have
a second picture over here let's just
see what happens when we run the second
picture we can go up here and change
this from dog image one to two we'll run
that and it comes down here and says cat
you can see me highlighting it down
there as cat so our process works you're
able to label a dog a dog and a cat a
cat just from the pictures there we go
cleared my drawing tool and the last
thing i want you to notice when we come
back up here to when i ran it you'll see
that has an accuracy of 1 and the value
accuracy of 1. well the value accuracy
is the important one because the value
accuracy is what it actually runs on the
test data remember i'm only testing it
on i'm only validating it on a random 10
photos and those 10 folders just happen
to come up one now when they ran this on
the server it actually came up about 86
this is why cutting these numbers down
so far for a commercial release is bad
so you want to make sure you're a little
careful of that when you're testing your
stuff that you change these numbers back
when you run it on a more enterprise
computer other than your old laptop that
you're just practicing on or messing
with and we come down here and again you
know we had the validation of cat and so
we have successfully built a neural
network that could distinguish between
photos of a cat and a dog imagine all
the other things you could distinguish
imagine all the different industries you
could dive into with that just being
able to understand those two difference
of pictures what about mosquitoes could
you find the mosquitoes that bite versus
mosquitoes that are friendly it turns
out the mosquitoes that bite us are only
four percent of the mosquito population
if even that maybe two percent there's
all kinds of industries that use this
and there's so many industries that are
just now realizing how powerful these
tools are just in the photos alone there
is a myriad of industries sprouting up
and i said it before i'll say it again
what an exciting time to live in with
these tools and that we get to play with
welcome to tensorflow 2.0 tutorial
what's in it for you we're going to
cover today deep learning frameworks
what is tensorflow features of
tensorflow tensorflow applications how
tensorflow works
tensorflow 1.0 versus 2.0 tensorflow 2.0
architecture and then we'll go over a
tensorflow demo where we roll up our
sleeves and dive right into the code
so let's start with deep learning
frameworks to start with this chart
doesn't even do the filled
justice because it's just exploded these
are just some of the major frameworks
out there there's a cross which happens
to sit on tensorflow so they're very
integrated there's tensorflow
pie torches out there cafe piano dl4j
and chainer these are just a few of the
deep learning frameworks we're talking
about neural networks if you're just
starting out never seen a neural network
you can go into python in the
scikit and do the neural network in
there which is probably the most
simplest version i know but the most
robust version out there the most top of
the ladder as far as the technology
right now is tensorflow and that of
course is changing from day to day and
some of these
are
better for different purposes so let's
dive into tensorflow let's see what is
tensorflow what is tensorflow tensorflow
is a popular open source library
released in 2015 by google brain team
for building machine learning and deep
learning models
it is based on python programming
language and performs numerical
computations using data flow graphs to
build models so let's take a look at
some of the features of tensorflow it
works efficiently with multi-dimensional
arrays
if you've ever played with any of the
simpler packages of neural networks
you're going to find that you have to
pretty much flatten them and make sure
your your stuff is set in a flat model
tensorflow works really good so we're
talking pictures here where you have
x and y coordinates where the picture is
and then each pixel has three or four
different channels that's a very
complicated array a very
multi-dimensional array it provides
scalability of computation across
machines and large data sets
this is so new right now
and you might think that's a minor thing
but when python is operating on one
computer and it has a float value
and it truncates it differently on each
computer you don't get the same results
and so your training model might work on
one machine and then another it doesn't
this is one of the things that
tensorflow
addresses and does a very good job on
it supports fast debugging and model
building
this is why i love tensorflow
i can go in there and i can build a
model with different layers each layer
might have different properties
they have like the convolutional neural
network which you can then sit on top of
a regular neural network with reverse
propagation there's a lot of tools in
here and a lot of options and each layer
that it goes through can utilize those
different options and stack differently
and it has a large community and
provides tensorboard to visualize the
model tensorboard is pretty uh recent
but it's a really nice tool to have to
when you're working with other people or
showing your
clients or the
shareholders in the company you can give
them a nice visual model so they know
what's going on what are they paying for
and let's take a glance at some of the
different uses or applications for
tensorflow when we talk about tensorflow
applications
clearly this is data analytics we're
getting into the data science i like to
use data science as probably a better
term this is the programming side
and it's really the sky is the limit
we can look at face detection language
translation
fraud detection video detection
there are so many different things out
there that tensorflow can be used for
when you think of neural networks
because tensorflow is a neural network
think of complicated chaotic data this
is very different than if you have a set
numbers like you're looking at the stock
market you can use this on the stock
market but if you're doing something
where the numbers are very clear
and not so chaotic as you have in a
picture then you're talking more about
linear regression models
and different regression models when
you're looking at that when you're
talking about these really complicated
data patterns
then you're talking neural networks and
tensorflow and if we're going to talk
about tensorflow we should talk about
what tensors are after all that is what
tensor that's what this is named after
so we talk about tensors in tensorflow
tensorflow is derived from its core
component known as a tensor a tensor is
a vector or a matrix of n dimensions
that represent all types of data and you
can see here we have the scalar which is
just a single
number you have your vector which is two
numbers
might be a number in a direction
you have a simple matrix and then we get
into the tensor i mentioned how a
picture is a very complicated tensor
because it has your x y coordinates and
then each one of those pixels has three
to four channels for your different
colors
and so each image coming in would be its
own tensor
and
in tensorflow tensors are defined by a
unit of dimensionality called as rank
and you can see here we have our
scalar which is a single number that has
a rank of zero because it has no real
dimensions to it other than it's just a
single point
and then you have your vector which
would be a single list of numbers
so that's a rank one
matrix would have rank two and then as
you can see right here as we get into
the full tensor it has a rank three
and so
the next step is to understand how a
tensorflow works and if you haven't
looked at um the basics of a neural
network in reverse propagation that is
the basics of tensorflow and then it
goes through a lot of different options
and properties that you can build into
your different tensors
so a tensorflow performs computations
with the help of data flow graphs it has
nodes that represent the operations in
your model and if you
look at this you should see a
neural network going on here we have our
inputs bc and d
and you might have x equals b plus c y
equals d minus four
a equals x times y and then you have an
output
and so
even though this isn't a neural network
here it's just a simple set of
computations going across
you can see how the more complicated it
gets the more because you can actually
one of the tensors is a neural network
with reverse propagation
but it's not limited to that there's so
much more you can do with it and this
here is just a basic uh flow of
computations of the data going across
and you can see we can plug in the
numbers uh b equals four c equals three
d equals six
and you get x equals four plus three
so x equals seven y equals six minus
four so y equals two and finally a
equals seven times two or a equals
fourteen like i said this is a very
simplified version of how tensorflow
works each one of these layers can get
very complicated
but tensorflow does such a nice job that
you can spin different setups up very
easily and test them out so you can test
out these different models to see how
they work now tensorflow has gone
through two major stages
we had the original tensorflow release
of 1.0 and then they came out with the
2.0 version and the 2.0 addressed so
many things out there that the 1.0
really needed so we start talking about
tensorflow 1.0 versus 2.0
i guess you would need to know this for
a legacy programming job if you're
pulling apart somebody else's code the
first thing is that tensorflow 2.0
supports eager execution by default it
allows you to build your models and run
them instantly and you can see here from
tensorflow 1 to tensorflow 2
we have
almost double the code to do the same
thing so if i want to do with tf.session
or tensorflow session as a session the
session run you have your variables your
session run you have your tables
initializer and then you do your model
fit
x train y train and then your validation
data your x value y value and your epics
and your batch size all that goes into
the fit
and you can see here where that was all
just compressed to make it run easier
you can just create a model and do a fit
on it and you only have like that last
set of code on there so it's automatic
that's what they mean by the eager so if
you see the first part you're like what
the heck is all the session thing going
on that's tensorflow 1.0 and then when
you get into 2.0 it's just nice and
clean
if you remember from the beginning i
said cross on our list up there
and cross is the high level api in
tensorflow 2.0
cross is the official high level api of
tensorflow 2.0 it has incorporated cross
as tf.caras cross provides a number of
model building apis such as sequential
functional and subclassing so you can
choose the right level of abstraction
for your project and
we'll hopefully touch base a little bit
more on this sequential being the most
common uh form that is your your
layers are going from one side to the
other so everything's going in a
sequential order
functional
is where you can split the layer so you
might have your input coming in one side
it splits into two completely mod
different models and then they come back
together
and one of them might be doing
classification the other one might be
doing just linear regression kind of
stuff or a neural basic
reverse propagation neural network and
then those all come together into
another layer which is your
neural network reverse propagation setup
subclassing
is the most complicated as you're
building your own models and you can
subclass your own models into cross so
very powerful tools here this is all the
stuff that's been coming out currently
in the tensorflow cross setup a third
big change we're going to look at is it
in tensorflow 1.0
in order to use tf layers as variables
you would have to write tf variable
block so you'd have to pre-define that
in tensorflow 2 you just add your layers
in under the sequential and it
automatically defines them as long as
they're flat layers
of course this changes a little bit as
the more complicated
tensor you have coming in but all of
it's very easy to do and that's what 2.0
does a really good job of and here we
have
a little bit more on the scope of this
and you can see how tensorflow 1 asks
you to do
these different layers and values if you
look at the scope and the default name
you start looking at all the different
code in there to create the variable
scope that's not even necessary in
tensorf 2.0 so you'd have to do one
before you do do what you see the code
in 2.0 in 2.0 you just create your model
it's a sequential model and then you can
add all your layers in you don't have to
pre-create the
variable scope so if you ever see the
variable scope you know that came from
an older version and then we have the
last two which is our api cleanup and
the autograph
in the api cleanup tensorflow 1 you
could build models using tf gans tf app
tf contrib tf flags etc in tensorflow 2
a lot of apis have been removed and this
is just they just cleaned them up
because people weren't using them and
they've simplified them and that's your
tf app your tf flags your tf logging are
all gone
so there's those are three legacy
features that are not in 2.0 and then we
have our tf function and autograph
feature in the old version tensorflow 1
0 the python functions were limited and
could not be compiled or exported
re-imported
so you were continually having to redo
your code you couldn't very easily just
put a pointer to it and say hey let's
reuse this
in tensorflow 2 you can write a python
function using the tf function to mark
it for the jit compilation for the
python jit so that tensorflow runs it as
a single graph autograph feature of tf
function helps to write graph code using
natural python syntax
now we just threw in a new word in you
graph a graph is not a picture of a
person
you'll hear graph x and some other
things
graph is what are all those lines that
are connecting different objects so if
you remember from before where we had
the different layers going through
sequentially each one of those white
lined arrows would be a graph x that's
where that computation is taken care of
and that's what they're talking about
and so if you had your own special code
or python way that you're sending that
information forward you can now put your
own function in there instead of using
whatever function they're using
in neural networks this would be your
activation function although it could be
almost anything out there depending on
what you're doing next let's go for
hierarchy and architecture and then
we'll cover three basic tools in
tensorflow before we roll up our sleeves
and dive into the example so let's just
take a quick look at tensorflow toolkits
in their hierarchy at the high level we
have our object oriented api so this is
what you're working with you have your
tf cross you have your estimators
this sits on top of your tf layers tf
losses tf metrics so you have your
reusable libraries for model building
this is really where tensorflow shines
is between the cross
running your estimators and then being
able to swap in different layers you can
your losses your metrics all of that is
so built into tensorflow makes it really
easy to use and then you can get down to
your low level tf api
you have extensive control over this you
can put your own formulas in there your
own procedures or models in there
you could have it split we talked about
that earlier so with the 2.0 you can now
have it split one direction we do a
linear regression model and then go to
the other where it does a
neural network and maybe each neural
network has a different activation set
on it and then it comes together into
another layer which is another neural
network so you can build these really
complicated models and at the low level
you can put in your own apis you can
move that stuff around and most recently
we have the tf code can run on multiple
platforms
and so you have your cpu
which is
basically like in the computer i'm
running on i have
eight cores and 16 dedicated threads i
hear they now have one out there that
has over 100 cores
so you have your cpu running and then
you have your gpu which is your graphics
card
and most recently they also include the
tpu setup which is specifically for
tensorflow models
neural network kind of set up
so now you can export the tf code and it
can run on all kinds of different
platforms for the most
diverse setup out there and moving on
from the hierarchy to the architecture
in the tensorflow 2.0 architecture
we have
you can see on the left this is usually
where you start out with and 80 of your
time in data science is spent
pre-processing data making sure it's
loaded correctly and everything looks
right
so the first level in tensorflow is
going to be your read and pre-processed
data your tf data feature columns
this is going to feed into your tf cross
or your pre-made estimators
and kind of you have your tensorflow hub
that sits on top of there so you can see
what's going on uh once you have all
that set up you have your distribution
strategy where are you gonna run it
you're gonna be running it on just your
regular cpu are you gonna be running it
with the gpu added in
like i have a pretty high-end graphics
card so it actually grabs it in gpu
processor and uses it or do you have a
specialized tpu setup in there that you
paid extra money for
it could be if you're in later on when
you're distributing the package you
might need to run this on some really
high processors because you're
processing at a server level for uh
let's say net you might be processing
this at a
distribute you're distributing it not
the distribution strategy but you're
distributing it into a server where that
server might be analyzing thousands and
thousands of purchases done
every minute
and so you need that higher speed to
give them a
to give them a recommendation or a
suggestion so they can buy more stuff
off your website or maybe you're looking
for
data fraud analysis working with the
banks you want to be able to run this at
a high speed so that when you have
hundreds of people
sending their transactions in it says
hey this doesn't look right someone's
scamming this person and probably has
their credit card so when we're talking
about all those fun things we're talking
about saved model this is we were
talking about that earlier where it used
to be when you did one of these models
it wouldn't truncate the float numbers
the same and so a model going from one
you build the model on your
machine in the office and then you need
to distribute it and so we have our
tensorflow serving cloud on premium
that's what i was talking about if
you're like a banking or something like
that
now they have tensorflow lite so you can
actually run a tensorflow on an android
or an ios or raspberry pi a little
breakout board there in fact they just
came out with a new one that has a
built-in there's just a little mini tpu
with the camera on it so it can
pre-process a video so you can load your
tensorflow model onto that
talking about an affordable way to beta
test a new product uh you have the
tensorflow js which is for browser and
node server so you can get that out on
the browser for some simple computations
that don't require a lot of heavy
lifting but you want to distribute to a
lot of endpoints and now they also have
other language bindings so you can now
create your tensorflow back in save it
and have it accessed from c java go
c sharp rust r or from whatever package
you're working on so we kind of have an
overview of the architecture and what's
going on behind the scenes and in this
case what's going on as far as
distributing it let's go ahead and take
a look at
three specific pieces of tensorflow
and those are going to be constants
variables and sessions
so very basic things you need to know
and understand when you're working with
the tensorflow setup so constants in
tensorflow in tensorflow constants are
created using the function constant in
other words they're gonna stay static
the whole time whatever you're working
with the syntax for constant
value d type 9 shape equals none name
constant verify shape equals false
that's kind of the syntax you're looking
at and we'll explore this with our hands
on a little more in depth
and you can see here we do z equals t f
dot constant 5.2 name equals x
d type is a float that means that we're
never going to change that 5.2 it's
going to be a constant value and then we
have our variables in tensorflow
variables in tensorflow are in memory
buffers that store tensors
and so we can declare a two by three
tensor populated by ones you could also
do constants this way by the way so you
can create a an array of ones for your
constants i'm not sure why you'd do that
but you know you might need that for
some reason
in here we have v equals tf.variables
and then in tensorflow you have tf.ones
and you have the shape which is two
three which is then going to create a
nice two by three
array that's filled with ones and then
of course you can go in there and
they're variables so you can change them
it's a tensor so you have full control
over that and then you of course have
sessions in tensorflow a session in
tensorflow is used to run a
computational graph to evaluate the
nodes
and remember when we're talking a graph
or graph x we're talking about all that
information then goes through all those
arrows and whatever computations they
have that take it to the next node and
you can see down here where we have
import tensorflow as tf if we do x
equals a tf.constant of 10
we do y equals a tf constant of 2.0 or
20.0 and then you can do z equals
tf.variable
and it's a tf dot add x comma y
and then once you have that set up in
there you go ahead and init your tf
global variables initializer
with tf session as session you can do a
session run init
and then you print the session run y
uh and so when you run this you're going
to end up with of course the 10 plus 20
is 30. and we'll be looking at this a
lot more closely as we actually roll up
our sleeves and put some code together
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that and for my coding today i'm going
to go ahead and go through anaconda and
then i'll use specifically the jupiter
notebook on there and of course this
code is going to work uh whatever
platform you choose whether you're in a
notebook
the jupiter lab which is just the
jupiter notebook but with tabs for
larger projects we're going to stick
with jupiter notebook
uh whatever it is you're going to use in
here you have your spider and your qt
console for different programming
environments the thing to note
is kind of hard to see but i have my
main
pi 36
right now when i was writing this
tensorflow works in python version three
six
if you have python version three seven
or three eight you're probably gonna get
some errors in there uh might be that
they've already updated and i don't know
it now you have an older version
but you want to make sure you're in
python version 3.6 in your environment
and of course in anaconda i can easily
set that environment up make sure you go
ahead and
pip in your tensorflow or if you're in
anaconda you can do a conda install
tensorflow to make sure it's in your
package
so let's just go ahead and dive in and
bring that up
this will open up a nice browser window
i just love the fact i can zoom in and
zoom out depending on what i'm working
on making it really easy to just
demo for the right size go under new and
let's go ahead and create a new python
and once we're in our new python window
this is going to leave it untitled
let's go ahead and import import
tensorflow as tf
uh at this point we'll go ahead and just
run it real quick
no errors yay no errors i
i do that whenever i do my imports
because i unbearably will have opened up
a new environment and forgotten to
install tensorflow into that environment
or something along those lines so it's
always good to double check
and if we're going to double check that
we also it's also good to know
what version we're working with
and we can do that simply by
using the version command in tensorflow
which you should know is is probably
intuitively the tf
dot underscore underscore version
underscore underscore
and
you know it always confuses me because
sometimes you do tf.version for one
thing you do tf dot underscore version
underscore for another thing
this is a double underscore in
tensorflow for pulling your version out
and it's good to know what you're
working with we're going to be working
in tensorflow version 2.1.0 and i did
tell you the the um we were going to dig
a little deeper into our constants and
you can do an array of constants and
we'll just create this nice array
a equals tf.constant
and we're just going to put the ray
right in there 4361.
we can run this and now that is what a
is equal to and if we want to just
double check that remember we're in
jupiter notebook where you can just put
the letter a
and it knows that that's going to be
print
otherwise you'd round you surround it in
print and you can see it's a tf tensor
it has the shape the type and the and
the array on here it's a two by two
array and just like we can create a
constant we can go and create a variable
and this is also going to be a two by
two array and if we go ahead and print
the v out we'll run that
and sure enough there's our tf variable
in here
then we can also let's just go back up
here and add this in here
i could create another tensor and we'll
make it a constant this time
and we're going to put that in over here
uh we'll have b tf constant
and if we go and print out v and b
we're going to run that
and this is an interesting thing that
always that happens in here you'll see
right here when i print them both out
what happens is it only prints the last
one unless you use print commands so
important to remember that in jupyter
notebooks we can easily fix that by go
ahead and print and surround v with
brackets and now we can see with the two
different variables we have
we have the three one five two which is
a variable
and this is just a flat
constant so it comes up as a tf tensor
shape two kind of two and that's
interesting to note
that this label is a tf.tensor and this
is a tf variable
so that's how it's looking in the back
end when you're talking about the
difference between a variable and a
constant
the other thing i want you to notice is
that in variable we capitalize the v and
with the constant we have a lowercase c
little things like that can lose you
when you're programming and you're
trying to find out hey why doesn't this
work
so those are a couple of things to note
in here and just like any other array in
math
we can do like a concatenate or
concatenate the different values here
and you can see we can take a b
concatenated you just do a tf.concat
values and there's our a b axis on one
hopefully you're familiar with axes and
how that works when you're dealing with
matrixes
and if we go ahead and print this out
you'll see right here we end up with a
tensor so it's put it in as a constant
not as a variable
and you have your array four three seven
eight and six one four five it's
concatenated the two together and again
i wanna highlight a couple things on
this our axis equals one this means
we're doing the columns um so if you had
a longer array like right now we have an
array that is like you know has a shape
one whatever it is two comma two
um axes
zero
is going to be your first one and axes
one is going to be your second one and
it translates as columns and rows
if we had a shape let me just put the
word shape here
um
so you know what i'm talking about it's
very clear and this is i'll tell you
what i spent a lot of time
looking at these shapes and trying to
figure out which direction i'm going in
and whether to flip it or whatever
so you can get lost in which way your
matrix is going which is column which is
rows are you dealing with the third axes
or the second axes
axes one you know zero one two that's
going to be our columns uh and if you
can do columns then we also can do rows
and that is simply just changing the
concatenate uh we'll just grab this one
here and copy it we'll do the whole
thing over
ctrl copy
ctrl v and changes from axes one
to axis zero and if we run that uh
you'll see that now we concatenate by
row as opposed to column
and you have four three six one seven
eight four seven so it just brings it
right down and turns it into rows versus
columns you can see the difference there
your output this really you want to look
at the output sometimes just to make
sure your eyes are looking at it
correctly
and it's in the format i find visually
looking at it is almost more important
than
understanding
what's going on because conceptually
your mind just just too many dimensions
sometimes
the second thing i want you to notice is
this says a numpy array uh so tensorflow
is utilizing numpy as part of their
format as far as python is concerned and
so you can treat you can treat this
output like a numpy array because it is
just that it's going to be a numpy array
another thing that comes up
more than you would think is filling
one of these with zeros or ones and so
you can see here we just create a tensor
tf.zeros
and we give it a shape we tell it what
kind of data type it is in this case
we're doing an integer
and then if we um print out our tensor
again we're in jupiter so i can just
type out tensor and i run this you can
see i have a nice
array of with shape three comma four of
zeros one of the things i want to
highlight here is integer 32. if i go to
the
tensorflow data types i want you to
notice how
we have float 16 float 32 float 64
complex if we scroll down you'll see the
integer down here 32 the reason for this
is that we want to control how many bits
are used in the precision
this is for exporting it to another
platform
so what would happen is i might run it
on this computer where python goes does
a float to indefinite however long it
wants to
and then we can take it but we want to
actually say hey we don't want that high
precision we want to be able to run this
on any computer and so we need to
control whether it's a tf float 16 in
this case we did an integer 32
we could also do this as a float
so if i run this as a float 32
that means this has a 32 bit precision
you'll see zero point whatever and then
to go with zeros
we have ones if we're going from the
opposite side and so we can easily just
create a tensorflow with ones
and you might ask yourself why would i
want zeros and ones and your first
thought might be to initiate a new
tensor
usually we initiate a lot of this stuff
with random numbers because it does a
better job solving it if you start with
a uniform
set of ones or zeros you're dealing with
a lot of bias so be very careful about
starting a neural network
for one of your rows or something like
that with ones and zeros
on the other hand
i use this for masking you can do a lot
of work with masking you can also have
it might be that
one tenser row is masked
you know zero is is false one is true or
whatever you want to do it
and so in that case you do want to use
the zeros and ones and there are cases
where you do want to initialize it with
all zeros or all ones and then swap in
different numbers as
the tensor learns so it's another form
of control
but in general
you see zeros and ones you usually are
talking about a mask over another array
and just like in numpy you can also
do reshapes so if we take our remember
this is shaped three comma four
maybe we wanna swap that to four comma
three
and if we print this out you will see
let me just go and do that ctrl v
let me run that
and you'll see that the the order of
these is now switched instead of four
across now we have three across and four
down
and just for fun let's go back up here
where we did the ones
and i'm going to change the ones to
tf.random
uniform uh and we'll go ahead and just
take off well we'll go and leave that
we'll go and run this
and you'll see now we have 0.0441
and this way you can actually see how
the reshape looks a lot different
0.041.15.71 and then instead of having
this one it rolls down here to the 0.14
and this is what i was talking about
sometimes you fill a lot of times you
fill these with random numbers and so
this is the random dot uniform is one of
the ways to do that now i just talked a
little bit about this float 32 and all
these data types
one of the things that comes up of
course is
recasting your data
so if we have a d type float 32 we might
want to convert these two integers
because of the project we're working on
i know one of the projects i've worked
on
ended up wanting to do a lot of round
off so that it would take a dollar
amount or a float value and then have to
rent it off to a dollar amount so we
only wanted two decimal points
in which case you have a lot of
different options you can multiply by
100 and then round it off or whatever
you want to do there's a lot or then
convert it to an integer was one way to
round it off
uh kind of
a cheap and dirty trick
uh so we can take this and we can take
this same tensor and we'll go ahead and
create a
as an integer and so we're going to take
this tensor we're going to tf.cast it
and if we print
tensor
and then we're going to go ahead and
print
our
tensor
let me just
do a quick copy and paste and when i'm
actually programming i usually type out
a lot of my stuff just to double check
it
in doing a demo copy and paste works
fine but sometimes be aware that copy
and paste can copy the wrong code over
personal choice depends on what i'm
working on
and you can see here we took
a float 32 4.6 4.2 and so on and it just
converts it right down to a integer
value
sorry integer 32 set up and
remember we talked about
a little bit about reshape
as far as flipping it and i just did uh
four comma three on the reshape up here
and we talked about axis zero axis one
uh one of the things that is important
to be able to do is to take one of these
variables we'll just take this last one
tensor as integer
and i want to go ahead and transpose it
and so i can do
we'll do a
equals tf.transpose
and we'll do our tensor integer in there
and then if i print the a out and we run
this
you'll see that's the same array but
we've flipped it so that our columns and
rows are flipped this is
the same as reshaping so when you
transpose you're just doing a reshape
what's nice about this is if you look at
the numbers the columns
when we went up here and we did the
reshape they kind of roll down to the
next row so you're not maintaining the
structure of your matrix so when we do a
reshape up here they're similar but
they're not quite the same and you can
actually go in here and there's settings
in the reshape that would allow you to
turn it into a transform
so when we come down here it's all done
for you and so there are so many times
you have to transpose
your digits that this is important to
know that you can just do that you can
flip your rows and columns rather
quickly here and just like numpy you can
also do multiple your different math
functions we'll look at multiplication
and so we're going to take matrix
multiplication of tensors
we'll go ahead and create a
as a constant 5 8 3 9 and we'll put in a
vector v 4 comma 2. and we could have
done this where they matched where this
was a two by two array
but instead
we're going to do just a
two by one array and the code for that
is your tf.mat
mole
so matrix multiplier and we have a times
v and if we go ahead and run this up
let's
make sure we print out our av on there
and if we go ahead and run this
you'll see that we end up with 36 by 30.
and if it's been a while since you've
seen the matrix math
this is
5 times 4 plus 8 times 2
3 times 4 plus 9 times 2
and that's where we get the 36 and 30.
now i know we're covering a lot really
quickly as far as the basic
functionality
so the matrix or your matrix multiplier
is a very commonly used back-end tool as
far as computing
different models or linear regression
stuff like that
one of the things
is to note is that just like in
numpy you have all of your different
math so we have our tf math
and if we go in here we have
functions we have our cosines absolute
angle all of that's in here so all of
these
are available for you to use in the
tensorflow model
and if we go back to our example and
let's go ahead and pull
um oh let's do some multiplication
that's always good we'll stick with our
av
our
constant a and our vector v
and we'll go ahead and do some bit wise
multiplication and we'll create an av
which is a times b let's go and print
that out
and you can see coming across here we
have the 4 2 and the 5 8 3 9 and it
produces 20 32 6 18
and that's pretty straight forward if
you look at you have 4 times
5 is 20 4 times 8 is
32 that's where those numbers come from
now we can also quickly create an
identity matrix
which is basically um your main values
on the diagonal being ones and zeros
across the other side
let's go ahead and take a look and see
what that
looks like and we can do let's do this
ah
so we're going to get the shape this is
a simple way very similar to your numpy
you can do a dot shape and it's going to
return a tuple in this case our rows and
columns and so we can do a quick
print
we'll do rows oops
and we'll do columns
and if we run this
you can see we have three rows
two columns
and then if we go ahead and create an
identity matrix
the scripts
the script for that
got a wrong button there the script for
that looks like this
where we have the number of rows equals
rows the number of columns equals
columns and d type is a 32 and then if
we go ahead and just print out our
identity
you can see we have a nice identity
column with our ones going across here
now clearly we're not going to go
through every math module
available but we do want to start
looking at this as a prediction model
and seeing how it functions
so we're going to move on to a more of a
direct setup we can actually see the
full tensorflow in use for that let's go
back and create a
new setup
and we'll go in here new python 3 module
there we go
bring this out so it takes up the whole
window because i like to do that
hopefully you made it through that first
part and you have a basic understanding
of tensorflow as far as being a series
of numpy arrays you've got your math
equations and different things that go
into them
we're going to start building a full
setup as far as the numpy so you can see
how uh cara sits on top of it in the
different aspects of how it works
the first thing we want to do is we're
going to go ahead and do a lot of
imports
date times warning scipy scipy is your
math so the back end scientific math
warnings because
whenever we do a lot of this you have
older versions newer versions
and so sometimes when you get warnings
you want to go ahead and just suppress
them
we'll talk about that if it comes up on
this particular setup and of course date
time
pandas again is your data frame think
rows and columns we import it as pd
numpy is your numbers array which of
course tensorflow is integrated heavily
with
seaborn for our graphics and the
seaborne as sns is going to be set on
top of our map plot library which we
import as mpl and then of course we're
going to import our matplot library pi
plot as plt and right off the bat we're
going to set some graphic colors um
patch force edge color equals true
the style we're going to use the 538
style you can look this all up there's
when you get into matplot library and to
seaborn there are so many options in
here it's just kind of nice to make it
look pretty when we start the um
when we start up that way we don't have
to think about it later on
uh and then we're going to take we have
our
mplrc we're going to put a patch ed
color dim gray line width again this is
all part of our graphics here in our
setup we'll go ahead and do an
interactive shell
node interactivity equals last
expression
here we are pd for pandas options
display max columns so we don't want to
display more than 50.
and then our matplot library is going to
be inline this is a jupiter notebook
thing the matplot library inline and
then warnings we're going to filter our
warnings and we're just going to ignore
warnings that way when they come up we
don't have to worry about them
not really what you want to do when
you're working on a major project you
want to make sure you know those
warnings and then
filter them out and ignore them later on
and if we run this it's just going to be
loading all that into the background
so that's a little back end kind of
stuff then what we want to go ahead and
do is we want to go ahead and import
our specific packages
that we're going to be working with
which is under cross now remember cross
kind of sits on tensorflow so when we're
importing cross and the sequential model
we are in effect importing
um tensorflow underneath of it
we just brought in the math probably
should have put that up above
and then we have our cross models we're
going to import sequential now if you
remember from our
slide there was three different options
let me just flip back over there so we
can have a quick uh recall on that and
so in keras uh we have sequential
functional and subclassing so remember
those three different setups in here we
talked about earlier and if you remember
from here we have a sequential where
it's going
one tensorflow layer at a time you go
kind of look at think of it as going
from left to right or top to bottom or
whatever direction it's going in but it
goes in one direction all the time where
functional can have a very complicated
graph of directions you can have the
data split into two separate
tensors and then it comes back together
into another tensor
all those kinds of things and then
subclassing is really the really
complicated one where now you're adding
your own subclasses into the tensor to
do external computations right in the
middle of like a huge flow of data
but we're going to stick with sequential
it's not a big jump to go from
sequential to functional
but we're running a sequential
tensorflow and that's what this first
import is here we want to bring in our
sequential and then we have our layers
and let's talk a little bit about these
layers this is where cross and
tensorflow
really are happening this is what makes
them so nice to work with is all these
layers are pre-built
so from cross we have layers import
dense
from cross layers import lstm
when we talk about these layers
cross has so many built-in layers you
can do your own layers the dense layer
is your standard neural network
by default it uses relu for its
activation
and then the lstm is a long short term
memory layer since we're going to be
looking probably at sequential data
we want to go ahead and do the lstm and
if we go into
cross and we look at their layers this
is across website you can see as we
scroll down for the cross layers that
are built in
we can get down here and we can look at
let's see here we have our layer
activation our base layers
activation layer weight layer waste
there's a lot of stuff in here we have
the relu which is the basic activation
that was listed up here for layer
activations you can change those and
here we have our core layers
and our dense layers you have an input
layer a dense layer
and then we've added a more customized
one with the long-term short-term memory
layer and of course you can even do your
own custom layers in cross there's a
whole functionality in there if you're
doing your own thing
what's really nice about this is it's
all built in even the convolutional
layers this is for processing graphics
there's a lot of cool things in here you
can do
this is why cross is so popular it's
open source and you have all these tools
right at your fingertips so from cross
we're just going to import a couple
layers the dense layer
and the long short term memory layer
and then of course from
sk learn our scikit
we want to go ahead and do our min max
scalar standard scalar for pre editing
our
data and then metrics just so we can
take a look at the errors and compute
those let me go ahead and run this and
that just loads it up we're not
expecting anything from the output and
our file coming in is going to be air
quality.csv
and let's go ahead and take a quick look
at that this is in openoffice it's just
a standard you know like we can do excel
whatever you're using for your
spreadsheet and you can see here we have
a number of columns
number of rows it actually goes down to
like eight thousand
the first thing we want to notice is
that the first row
is kind of just a random number put in
going down
probably not something we're going to
work with
the second row
is bendung
i'm guessing that's a reference for the
profile
if we scroll to the bottom which i'm not
going to do because it takes forever to
get back up they're all the same
the same thing with the status the
status is the same
we have a date so we have a sequential
order here
here is the jam which i'm going to guess
is the time stamp on there so we have a
date and time
we have our o3 co no2 reading so2 no co2
voc
and then some other numbers here pm1 pm
2.5 pm 4 pm 10
without actually
looking through the data i mean some of
this i can guess is like temperature
humidity i'm not sure what the pms are
but we have a whole slew of data here so
we're looking at air quality as far as
an area in a region and what's going on
with our date time stamps on there and
so code wise we're going to read this
into a pandas data frame so our data
frame df is a nice abbreviation commonly
used for data frames
equals pd.read csv and then our the path
to it just happens to be on my d drive
separated by spaces and so if we go
ahead and run this
we'll print out the head of our data and
again this looks very similar to what we
were just looking at
being in jupiter i can take this and go
the other way
make it real small so you can see all
the columns going across and we get a
full view of it
um
or we can bring it back up in size
that's pretty small on there overshot um
but you can see it's the same data we
were just looking at we're looking at
the number we're looking at the profile
which is the bandung
the
date we have a time stamp
our 03 count co and so forth on here
and this is just your basic
printing out the top five rows we could
easily have done
three rows
five rows ten whatever you want to put
in there by default that's five for
pandas now i talk about this all the
time so i know i've already said it at
least once or twice during this video
most of our work is in pre-formatting
data what are we looking at how do we
bring it together
so we want to go ahead and start with
our
date time it's come in in two columns
we have our date here and we have our
time and we want to go ahead and combine
that and then we have this is just a
simple script in there that says
combined date time that's our formula
we're building
our we're going to submit our
pandas data frame
and the tab name when we go ahead and do
this
that's all of our information that we
want to go ahead and create
and then goes for i in range df
shape 0.
so we're going to go through
the whole setup and we're going to list
tab append df location i
and here is our date going in there and
then return the numpy array list tab d
types date time 64. that's all we're
doing we're just switching this to a
date time stamp and if we go ahead and
do df datetime equals combined datetime
and then i always like to uh print we'll
do df head
just so we can see what that looks like
and so when we come out of this
we now have our setup on here and of
course it's edited on to the far right
here's our date time
you can see the format's changed
so there's our we've added in the date
time column and we've brought the date
over and we've taken this format here
and it's an actual variable with a 0 0 0
on here well that doesn't look good so
we need to also include the time part of
this and we want to convert it into
hourly data
so let's go ahead and do that to do that
to finish combining our date time let's
go ahead and create a a little
script here to combine the time in there
same thing we just did we're just
creating a numpy array returning a numpy
array and cr forcing this into a date
time format and we can actually spend
hours just going through uh these
conversions how do you
pull it from the pandas data frame
how do you set it up
so i'm kind of skipping through it a
little fast because i want to stay
focused on tensorflow and cross
keep in mind this is like 80 of your
coding when you're doing a lot of this
stuff is going to be reformatting these
things resetting them back up uh so that
it looks right on here and you know it
just takes time to get through all that
but that is usually what the companies
are paying you for that's what the big
bucks are for
and we want to go ahead and a couple
things going on here is we're going to
go ahead and do our date time we're
going to reorganize some of our setup in
here convert into hourly data we just
put a pause in there
now remember we can select from df are
different columns we're going to be
working with and you're going to see
that we actually dropped
a couple of the columns those ones i
showed you earlier they're just
repetitive data so there's nothing in
there that exciting
and then we want to go ahead and we'll
create a
second
data frame here let me just get rid of
the df head
and df2 is we're going to group by date
time and we're looking at the mean value
and then we'll print that out so you can
see we're talking about
we have now reorganized this so we put
in date time 03 co
so now this is in the same order
as it was before and you'll see the date
time
now has our 0 0
same date 1 2 3 and so on so let's group
the data together
so there's a lot more manageable and in
the format we want and in the right
sequential order
and if we go back to
there we go our air quality
you can see right here we're looking at
these columns going across we really
don't need since we're going to create
our own
date time column we can get rid of those
these are the different columns of
information we want and that should
reflect right here in the columns we
picked coming across so this is all the
same columns on there that's all we've
done is reformatted our data
grouped it together by date and then you
can see the different data coming out
set up on there and then as a data
scientist
first thing i want to do is get a
description what am i looking at and so
we can go ahead and do the df2 describe
and this gives us our you know describe
gives us our basic data analytics
information we might be looking for like
what is the mean standard deviation
uh minimum amount maximum amount we have
our first quarter second quarter and
third quarter
numbers also in there
so you can get a quick look at a glance
describing the data or descriptive
analysis
and even though we have our quantile
information in here we're going to dig a
little deeper into that
we're going to calculate the quantile
for each variable
we're going to look at a number of
things for each variable and we'll see
right here q1
we can simply do the quantile 0.25
percent
which should match um our 25 percent up
here and we'll be looking at the min the
max
and we're just going to do this is
basically we're breaking this down
for each
different
variable in there
one of the things that's kind of fun to
do
we're going to look at that in just a
second let me get put the next piece of
code in here
clean out some of our um we're gonna
drop a couple thing our
last rows and first row because those
have
usually have a lot of null values and
the first row is just our titles uh so
that's important it's important to drop
those rows in here and so this right
here as we look at our different
quantiles
again it's it's the same you know we're
still looking at the 25
quantile here
we're going to do a little bit more with
this
so now that we've cleared off our first
and last rows
we're going to go ahead and go through
all of our columns and this way we can
look at each
column individually and so we'll
just create a q1 q3 min max min iqr max
iqr
and calculate the quantile of i of df2
we're basically doing
the math that they did up here but we're
splitting it apart that's all this is
and
this happens a lot because you might
want to look at individual if this was
my own project i would probably spend
days and days going through
what these different values mean
one of the biggest
data science
things we can look at that's important
is uh use your use your common sense
you know if you're looking at this data
and it doesn't make sense and you go
back in there and you're like wait a
minute what the heck did i just do
at that point you probably should go
back and double check what you have
going on
now
we're looking at this and you can see
right here here's our attribute for our
o3 so we've broken it down
we have our q1 5.88 q3 10.37 if we go
back up here here's our 5 8 we've
rounded it off
10.37 is in there
so we've basically done the same math
just split it up we have our minimum and
our max iqr and that's computed let's
see where is it here we go
q1 minus 1.5 times iqr and the iqr is
your q3 minus q1 so that's the
difference between our two different
quarters and this is all
data science
as far as the hard math
we're really not we're actually trying
to focus on cross and tensorflow you
still got to go through all this stuff i
told you 80
of your programming is going through and
understanding what the heck
uh happened here
what's going on what does this data mean
and so when we're looking in that we're
going to go ahead and say hey
we've computed these numbers and the
reason we've computed these numbers is
if you take the minimum value and it's
less than your minimum iqr
that means something's going wrong there
and they usually in this case is going
to show us an outlier
so we want to go ahead and find the
minimum value if it's less than the min
minimum iqr it's an outlier and if the
max value is greater than the
max iqr uh we have an outlier and that's
all this is doing low outliers found
minimum value high outlier is found
really important actually outliers are
almost everything in data sometimes
sometimes you do this project just to
find the outliers because you want to
know
crime detection what are we looking for
we're looking for the outliers what
doesn't fit a normal business deal and
then we'll go ahead and throw in
just threw in a lot of code oh my
goodness uh so we have if your max is
greater than iqr print outlier is found
what we want to do is we want to start
cleaning up these outliers and so we
want to convert
we'll do create a convert nand
x max iqr equals max
underscore iqr min iqr equals mini qr so
this is just saying this is the data
we're going to send that's all that is
in python and if x is greater than the
max iqr and x is less than the min iqr x
equals
null we're going to set it to null why
because we want to clear
these outliers out of the data now again
if you're doing fraud detection you
would do the opposite you would be
cleaning everything else that's not in
that series so that you can look at just
the outlier uh and then we're going to
convert the nand hum again we have x
max iqr is hundred percent min iqr is
men iqr
if x is greater than max iqr and x is
less than min iqr again we're going to
return a null value otherwise it's going
to remain the same value x x equals x
and you can see as we go through the
code if i equals
our hum
then we go ahead and do this
that's a column specific to humidity
that's your hum column uh then we're
going to go ahead and convert do the
run a map on there and convert the non
h2m
you can see here it's this is just
cleanup
we run we found out that humidity
probably has some weird values in it
we have our outliers
that's all this is
and so when we go ahead and finish this
and we take a look at our outliers
and we run this code here
we have a low outlier 2.04 we have a
high outlier
99.06
outliers have been interpolated
that means we've given them a new value
chances are these days when you're
looking at something like
these sensors coming in
they probably have a failed sensor in
there something went wrong
that's the kind of thing that you really
don't want to do your data analysis on
so that's what we're doing is we're
pulling that out and then
converting it over and setting it up
method linear
so we interpolate left linears it's
going to fill that data in
based on a linear regression model of
similar data
same thing with this up here with the
df2y interpolate that's what we're doing
again this is all data prep we're not
actually talking about tensorflow we're
just trying to get all our data
set up correctly so that when we run it
it's not going to cause problems or have
a huge bias
so we've dealt with outliers
specifically in humidity
and again this is one of these things
where when we start running
we run through this you can see down
here that we have our
outliers found
high low outliers
migrated them in we also know there's
other issues going on with this data
how do we know that
some of it's just looking at the data
playing with it until you start
understanding what's going on let's take
the temp value and we're going to go
ahead and use a logarithmic function on
the temp value
and uh
it's interesting because it's like how
do you how do you heck do you even know
to use logarithmic on the temp value
that's domain specific
we're talking about being an expert in
air care i'm not an expert in air care
um you know it's not
what i go look at i don't look at air
care data in fact this is probably the
first air care data set up i've looked
at but the experts come in there and
they come to you and say hey in data
science this is a exponentially variable
variable on here so we need to go ahead
and do
transform it
and use a logarithmic scale on that
so at that point that would be coming
from your uh
data here we go data science programmer
overview does a lot of stuff connecting
the database and connecting in with the
experts
data analytics a lot of times you're
talking about somebody who is a data
analysis might be all the way usually a
phd level
data science programming level
interfaces database manager that's going
to be the person who's your admin
working on it
so when we're looking at this we're
looking at something they've sent to me
and they said hey domain air care
this needs to be this is a skew because
the data just goes up exponentially and
affects everything else and we'll go
ahead and take that data let me just go
ahead and run this
just for another quick look at it
we have our
uh we'll do a distribution df
we'll create another data frame from the
temp values and then from a data set
from the log temp so we can put them
side by side and we'll just go ahead and
do a quick histogram and this is kind of
nice plot of figure figure size here's
our plt from matplot library
and then we'll just do a distribution
underscore df there's our data frames
this is nice because it just integrates
the histogram right into pandas love
pandas
and this is a chart you would send back
to your data analysis and say hey is
this what you wanted this is how the
data is converting on here as a data
science scientist the first thing i note
is we've gone from a 10
20 30 scale to 2.5 3.0 3.5 scale
and the data itself has kind of been
adjusted a little bit based on some kind
of a skew on there so let's jump into uh
we're getting a little closer to
actually doing our
cross on here
we'll go ahead and split our data up
and this of course is any good data
scientists you want to have a training
set and a test set
and we'll go ahead and do the train size
we're going to use 0.75 percent of the
data make sure it's an integer don't
want to take a slice as a float value
give you a nice error and we'll have our
train size of 75 percent and the test
size is going to be
of course the train size minus the
length of the data set and then we can
simply do train comma test
here's our data set
which is going to be the train size the
test size
and then if we go and print this let me
just go ahead and run this we can see
how these values
split it's a nice split of 1298 and then
433 points of value
they're going to be for our setup on
here and if you remember we're
specifically looking at the data set
where did we create that data set from
that was from up here that's what we
called the
logarithmic
value of the temp
that's where the data set came from so
we're looking at just that column with
this train size and the test with the
train and test data set here and let's
go ahead and do uh convert an array of
values into a data set matrix we're
going to create a little um
setup in here we'll create our data set
our data set's going to come in we're
going to do a look back of one so we're
going to look back one piece of data
going backward
and we have our data x and our data y
for i and range length of data set look
back minus one
this is creating let me just go ahead
and run this actually the best way to do
this
is to go ahead and create this data
and take a look at the shape of it let
me go ahead and just put that code in
here
so we're going to do a look back one
here's our train x our train y
and it's going to be adding the data on
there and then when we come up here
and we take a look at the shape
there we go
when we run this piece of code here
we look at the shape on this and we have
a new slightly different change on here
but we have a shape of x
1296 comma 1
shape of y train y test x text y
and so what we're looking at is that
um
the x comes in
and we're only having a single value at
out
uh we want to predict what the next one
is that's what this little piece of code
is here for what are we looking for well
we want to look back one that's the um
what we're going to train the data with
is yesterday's data yesterday says hey
the humidity was at
97 percent what should today's humidity
be at if it's 97 yesterday is it going
to go up or is it going to go down today
if 97 does it go up to 100 what's going
on there
and so our we're looking forward to the
next piece of data which says hey
tomorrow's is going to you know today's
community is this this is what
tomorrow's humidity is going to be
that's all that is all that is is
stacking our data so that
our y is basically
x plus 1 or x could be y minus 1.
and then a couple things to note is our
x data
we're only dealing with the one column
but you need to have it in a shape that
has it by the columns so you have the
two different numbers and since we're
doing just a single point of data
we have and you'll see with the train y
we don't need to have the extra shape on
here
now this is going to run into a problem
and the reason is is that we have what
they call a time step
and the time step is that long-term
short-term memory layer
uh so we're going to add another reshape
on here let me just go down here and put
it into the next cell
and so we want to reshape the input
array in the form of sample time step
features we're only looking at one
feature
and i mean this is one of those things
when you're playing with this you're
like why am i getting an error in the
numpy array why is this giving me
something weird going on
so we're going to do is we're going to
add one more
level on here instead of being 1299.1
we want to go one more
and when we put the code together in the
back you can see we kept the same shape
the 1299
we added the one dimension and then we
have our train x shape one
and this could have depends again on how
far back in the long short term memory
you want to go
that is what that piece of code is for
and that reshape is and you can see the
new shape is now one uh
1299 one one
uh versus the 1299 one and then the
other part of the shape 432 one one
again this is our tr our x in and of
course our test x and then our y is just
a single column because we're just doing
one output that we're looking for
so now we've done our 80 percent um you
know that's all the the
writing all the code reformatting our
data
bringing it in now we want to go ahead
and do the fun part which is we're going
to go ahead and create and fit
the lstm neural network
and if we're going to do that the first
thing we need is we're going to need to
go ahead and create a model and we'll do
this sequential model and if you
remember sequential means it just goes
in order that means we have if you have
two layers the layers go from layer one
to layer two or layer zero to layer one
this is different than functional
functional allows you to split the data
and run two completely separate models
and then bring them back together
we're doing just sequential on here and
then we decided to do the long short
term memory uh and we have our input
shape which it comes in again this is
what all this switching was we could
have easily made this one two three or
four going back as far as the end number
on there we just stuck to going back one
and it's always a good idea when you get
to this point where the heck
is this model coming from
what kind of models do we have available
and there's let me go and put the next
model in there
because we're going to do two models and
the next model is going to go ahead and
we're going to do dent so we have model
equal sequential
and then we're going to add the lstm
model and then we're going to add a
dense model and if you remember from the
very top of our code
where we did the imports oops there we
go our cross
this is it right here here's our
importing a dense model and here's our
importing an lstm now just about every
tensorflow model uses dents
your dense model is your basic
forward propagation reverse propagation
error
or it does reverse propagation to
program the model uh so any of your
neural networks you've already looked at
that
luxon says here's the error and sends
the error backwards that's what this is
the long short term memory is a little
different
the real question that we want to look
at right now is where do you find these
models what kind of models do you have
available and so for that let's go to
the cross website
which is the cross dot io
if you go under api
layers and i always have to do a search
just search for cross api layers it'll
open up and you can see we have
your base layers right here class
trainable weights all kinds of stuff
like there your activation
so a lot of your layers you can switch
how it activates
relu which is like your smaller arrays
or if you're doing convolutional neural
networks the convolution usually uses a
relu
your sigmoid all the way up to soft mac
soft plus all these different choices as
far as how those
are set up and what we want to do is we
want to go ahead and if you scroll down
here you'll see your core layers and
here is your dense layer
so you have an input object your dense
layer your activation layer embedding
layer this is your your kind of your one
set up on there that's most common
uh convolutional neural networks or
convolutional layers these are like for
doing uh image categorizing uh so trying
to find objects in a picture that kind
of thing
we have pooling layers so as you have
the layers come together
usually you bring them down into
a single layer although you can still do
like global max pulling 3d and there is
just i mean this list just goes on and
on uh there's all kinds of different
things hidden in here as far as what you
can do and it changes you know you go in
here and you just have to do a search
for what you're looking for
and figure out what's going to work best
for you
as far as which project you're working
on uh long short term memory is a big
one because this is when we start
talking about text
uh what if someone says the what comes
after the
uh the cat in the hat a little kid's
book there
it starts programming it and so you
really want to know not only
what's going on but it's going to be
something that has a history the history
behind it tells you what the next one
coming up is
now once we've built all our different
you know we built our model we've added
our different layers we went in there
um play with it remember if you're in
functional you can actually link these
layers together and they branch out and
come back together if you do a uh
the sub
setup then you can create your own
different model you can embed a model in
there that might be coming linear
regression you can embed a linear
regression model
as part of your functional split and
then have that come back together with
other things so we're going to go ahead
and compile
your model this brings everything
together we're going to put in what the
loss is which we'll use the mean squared
error
and we'll go ahead and use the atom
optimizer clearly there's a lot of
choices on here depending on what you're
doing and just like any of these
different prediction models if you've
been doing any uh
scikit from python
you'll recognize that we have to then
fit the model
uh so what are we doing in here we're
going to send in our train x our train y
we're going to decide how many epochs
we're going to run it through
500 is probably a lot for this i'm
guessing it'd probably be about 200 or
300 probably do just fine
our batch size
so how many different when you process
it this is the math behind it
if you're in data analytics
you might try to know what this number
is as a data scientist where i haven't
had the phd level math that says this is
why you want to use this particular
batch size you kind of play with this
number a little bit
you can dig deeper into the math
see how it affects the results depending
what you're doing
and there's a number of other settings
on here we did verbose 2. i'd have to
actually look that up to tell you what
verbose means i think that's actually
the default on there if i remember
correctly
there's a lot of different settings when
you go to fit it
the big ones are your epic and your
batch size those are what we're looking
for
and so we're going to go ahead and run
this
and this is going to take a few minutes
to run because it's going through
500 times
through all the data so if you have a
huge data set this is the point where
you're kind of wondering oh my gosh is
this going to finish tomorrow
if i'm running this on a single machine
and i have a tera terabyte of data
going into it
if this is my personal computer and i'm
running a terabyte of data into this
you know this is running rather quickly
through all 500 iterations
but yeah a terabyte of data we're
talking something closer to days week
you know even with a
3.5 gigahertz machine and in eight cores
it's still going to take a long time to
go through a full terabyte of data
and then we want to start looking at
putting it into some other framework
like spark or something that will print
the process on there more across
multiple
processors and multiple computers
and if we scroll all the way down to the
bottom you're going to see here's our
square mean error of 0.0088
if we scroll way up you'll see it kind
of oscillates between 0.088 and 0.08089
it's right around 2 to 250 where you
start seeing that oscillation where it's
really not going anywhere so we really
didn't need to go through a full 500
epics
you know if you're retraining the stuff
over and over again it's kind of good to
know where that
error zone is so you don't have to do
all the extra processing of course if
you're going to build a model
we want to go ahead and run a prediction
on it
so let's go ahead and make our
prediction remember we have our training
test set
and our test set or the
we have the
train x and the train y for training it
or train predict and then we have our
test x and our test y going in there
so we can test to see how good it did
and when we come in here we have
you'll see right here we go ahead and do
our train predict equals
model predict train x and test predict
model predict test x
why would we want to run the prediction
on train x well it's not a hundred
percent on its prediction we know it has
a certain amount of error and we want to
compare the error we have on what we
programmed it with with the error we get
when we run it on new data that's never
seen the model has never seen before and
one of the things we can do we go ahead
and invert the predictions
this helps us
level it off a little bit more
get rid of some of our bias we have
train predict equals and np
exponential m1 the train predict
and then train y equals the exponential
m1 for train y and then we do the again
that with train test predict and test y
um
again reformatting the data so that we
can it all matches and then we want to
go ahead and calculate the root mean
square error
so we have our train score which is your
math square root times the mean square
root error train
y and train predict and again we're just
um this is just feeding the data through
so we can compare it and the same thing
with the test
and let's take a look at that because
really
the code makes sense if you're going
through it line by line you can see what
we're doing but the answer really helps
to zoom in
so we have a train score which is 2.40
of our root mean square error and we
have a test score of 3.16 of the root
mean square error
if these were reversed if our test score
is better than our training score then
we've over trained something's really
wrong at that point you got to go back
and figure out what you did wrong
because you should never have a better
result on your test data than you do
when you're training data and that's why
we put them both through that's why we
look at the error for both the training
and the testing
when you're going out and quoting you're
publishing this and you're saying hey
how good is my model it's the test score
that you're showing people this is what
it did on my test data that the model
had never seen before this is how good
my model is
and a lot of times you actually want to
put together like a little formal code
where we actually want to print that out
and if we print that out you can see
down here
test prediction standard deviation of
data set 3.16 is less than 4.40
i'd have to go back
and we're
up here if you remember we did the
square means error this is standard
deviation that's why these numbers are
different
it's saying the same thing that we just
talked about
uh
3.16 is less than 4.40 model is good
enough we're saying hey this is this
model is valid we have a valid model
here so we can go ahead and go with that
uh and along with
putting a formal print out of there
we want to go ahead and plot what's
going on
uh and this we just want to pretty graft
here so that people can see what's going
on when i walk into a meeting and i'm
dealing with a number of people
they really don't want these numbers
they don't want to say hey what's i mean
standard deviation unless you know what
statistics are
you might be dealing with a number of
different departments head of cells
might not work with standard deviation
or have any idea what that really means
number wise and so at this point we
really want to put it in a graph so we
have something to display and with
displaying you remember that we're
looking at uh the data
today going into it and what's gonna
happen tomorrow
so let's take a quick look at this uh
we're gonna go ahead and shift the train
predictions for plotting we have our
train predict plot
np empty leg data set train predict plot
set it up with null values
you know it's just kind of
it's kind of a weird thing where we're
creating the
the
data groups as we like them
and then putting the data in there is
what's going on here so we have our
train predict plot
which is going to be our look back our
length
plus look back
we're just is going to equal train uh
train predict
so we're creating this basically we're
taking this and we're dumping the train
predict into it so now we have our nice
train predict plot
and then we have the shift test
predictions for the plotting uh we're
going to continue more of that oops
looks like i put it in here double no
it's just uh yeah they put it in here
double
didn't mean to do that
we really only need to do it once oh
here we go
this is where the problem was is because
this is the test predict
so we have our training prediction we're
doing the shift on here and then the
test predict we're going to look at that
same thing we're just creating those two
data sets
uh test
predict plot length prediction set up on
there
and then we're going to go through the
plotting the original data set and the
predictions so we have a time axis
always nice to have your time set on
there
set that to the time array
time axes lap
all this is setting up the time variable
for the bottom and then we have a lot of
stuff going on here as far as setting up
our figure
let's go ahead and run that and then
we'll break it down
we have on here
our main plot we have two different
plots going on here
the ispu going up and the data and the
ispu here with all these different
settings on it
and so we look at this we have our ax1
that's the main plot i mean our ax
that's the main plot and we have our ax1
which is the secondary plot over here so
we're doing a figure plt
or plt.figure
and we're going to dump those two graphs
on there
and so we take
and if you
go through the code piece by piece
which we're not going to do we're going
to do the um the
data set here
exponential reverse exponential so it
looks correctly we're going to label it
the original data set
we're going to plot the train predict
plot that's what we just created
we're going to make that orange and
we'll label it train prediction
test predicts plot we're going to make
that red and label it test prediction
and so forth um set our ticks up this
actually just put ticks time axes gets
its ticks
the little little marks they're going
along the axes that kind of thing and
let's take a look and see what these
graphs look like
and these are just kind of fun you know
when you show up into a meeting and this
is the final output you say hey this is
what we're looking at
here's our original data in blue
here's our training prediction
you can see that it trains pretty close
to what the data is up there
i would also probably put a um like a
little little time stamp and do just
right before and right after where we go
from train to test prediction
and you can see with the test prediction
the data comes in in red
and then you can also see what the
original data set look like behind it
and how it differs
and then we can just isolate that here
on the right that's all this is
is just the
test prediction on the right
and it's you know there's you'll see
with the original data set there's a lot
of peaks were missing and a lot of lows
were missing but as far as the actual
test prediction it's pretty does pretty
good it's pretty right on you can get a
good idea what to expect for your ispu
and so from this we would probably
publish it and say hey this is
what you expect and this is our area of
this is a range of error that's the kind
of thing i put out
on a daily basis maybe we predict the
cells are going to be this or maybe a
weekly
so you kind of get a nice you kind of
flatten the
data coming out and you say hey this is
what we're looking at the big takeaway
from this is that we're working with
let me go back up here oops oh too far
there we go
is this model here this is what this is
all about we worked through all of those
pieces
all the tensorflows
and that is to build this sequential
model and we're only putting in the two
layers
this can get pretty complicated if you
get too complicated it never
it never verges into a usable model
so if you have like 30 different layers
in here there's a good chance you might
crash it kind of thing
so don't go too hate wire on that and
that you kind of learn as you go again
it's domain knowledge
um and also starting to understand all
these different layers and what they
mean
the data
analytics behind those layers
is something that your data analysis
professional would come in and say this
is what we want to try
but i tell you as a data scientist
a lot of these basic setups are common
and i don't know how many times uh
working with somebody and they're like
oh my gosh if i only did a tangent h
instead of a relu activation
i worked for two weeks to figure that
out well as a data science i can run it
through the model in you know five
minutes instead of spending two weeks
doing the the math behind it
so that's one of the advantages of data
scientist is we do it from programming
side and a data analytics is going to
look for it how does it work in math
and this is really the core right here
of tensorflow and cross is being able to
build your data model quickly and
efficiently and of course
with any data science
putting out a pretty graph so that your
shareholders again we want to take and
reduce the information down to something
people can look at and say oh that's
what's going on they can see stuff
what's going on as far as the dates and
the change in the ispu
in this video i will walk you through
the tensorflow code to perform object
detection in a video so let's get
started this part is basically we are
importing all the libraries we need a
lot of these libraries for example numpy
we need image i o date time and pill and
so on and so forth and of course
matplotlib so we import all these
libraries and then there are a bunch of
variables which have some paths for the
files and folders so this is regular
stuff let's keep moving then we import
the matplotlib and make it inline and
a few more imports all right and then
these are some warnings we can just
ignore them so if i run this code once
again we could go away all right and
then here onwards we do the model
preparation now what we're going to do
is we're going to use an existing neural
network model so we are not going to
chain a new one because that really will
take a long time and it needs a lot of
computation resources and so on and it
is really not required there are already
models that have been trained and in
this case it is the ssd with mobilenet
that's the model that we are going to
use and this model is trained to detect
objects and it is readily available as
open source so we can actually use this
and if you want to use other models
there are a few more models available so
you can click on this
link here and
let me just take you there there are a
few more models but we have chosen this
particular one because this is faster it
may not be very accurate but that is one
of the faster models but on this link
you will see a lot of other models that
are readily available these are trained
models some of them would take a little
longer but they may be more accurate and
so on so you can probably play around
with these other models okay so we will
be using that model so this piece of
code this line is basically importing
that model and this is also known as
frozen model the term we use is frozen
model so we import download and import
that and then we will actually use that
model in our code all right so these two
cells
we have downloaded and import the model
and then once it is available locally we
will then load this into our program all
right so
we are loading this into memory and
you need to perform a couple of
additional steps which is basically we
need to map the numbers to
text as you may be aware when we
actually build the model and when we run
predictions the model will not give a
text the output of the model is usually
a number so we need to map that to a
text so for example if the network
predicts that the output is 5 we know
that 5 means it is an airplane things
like that so this mapping is done in
this next cell all right so let's keep
moving and then we have a helper code
which will basically load the data or
load the images and transform into numpy
arrays this is also used in doing object
detection in images so we are actually
going to reuse because video is nothing
but it consists of frames which in turn
are images so we are going to pretty
much use reuse the same code which we
use for doing object detection in images
so this is where the actual detection
starts so here this is the path for
where the images are stored so this is
here once again we are reusing the code
which we wrote for detecting objects in
an image so this is the path where the
images were stored and this is the
extension and this was done for about
two or three images so we will continue
to use this and
we go down i'll skip this section so
this is the cell where we are actually
loading the video and converting it into
frames and then using frame by frame we
are detecting the objects in the image
so in this code what we are doing
basically is there are a few lines of
code what they do is basically once they
find an object a box will be drawn
around those
each of those objects and the input file
the name of the input video file is
traffic it is the extension is mp4 and
we have this video reader it's a
excellent object which is basically part
of this class called image io so we can
read and write videos using that and the
video that we are going to use is
traffic.mp4 you can use any mp4 file but
in our case i picked up video which has
uh like car so let me just show you so
this is in this object detection folder
i have this mp4 file i'll just quickly
play this video it's a little slow yeah
okay so here we go this is the video
it's a short one relatively small video
so that for this particular demo and
what it will do is once we run our code
it will detect each of these cars and it
will annotate them as cars so in this
particular video we only have cars we
can later on see with another video i
think i have cat here so we can also try
with that but let's first check with
this traffic video so let me go back so
we will be reading this frame by frame
and
you know actually we will be
reading the video file but then we will
be analyzing it frame by frame and we
will be reading them at 10 frames per
second that is the rate we are
mentioning here and analyzing it and
then annotating and then writing it back
so you will see that we will have a
video file name something like this
traffic underscore annotated and
we will see the annotated video so let's
go back and run through this piece of
code and then we will come back and see
the annotated video this might take a
little while so i will pause the video
after
running this particular cell and then
come back to show you the results all
right so let's go ahead and run it so it
is running now and it is also important
that at the end you close the video
writer so that it is similar to a file
pointer when you open a file you should
also make sure you close it so that it
doesn't hog the resources so it's very
similar at the end of it the last piece
or last line of code should be video
underscore writer dot close all right so
i'll pause and then i'll come back okay
so i will see you in a little bit all
right so now as you can see here the
processing is done the hourglass has
disappeared that means the video has
been processed so let's go back and
check the annotated video we'll go back
to my file manager so this was the
original
traffic.mp4 and now you have here
traffic underscore annotated mp4 so
let's go and run this and see how it
looks
you see here just got each of these cars
are getting detected let me pause and
show you so we pause here it says car 70
let us allow it to go a little further
it detects something on top what is that
truck okay so i think because of the
board on top it somehow thinks there is
a truck let's play it some more and see
if it detects anything else so this is
again a car looks like so let us yeah so
this is a car and
it has confidence level of 69 percent
okay this is again a car all right so
basically till the end it goes and
detects each and every car that is
passing by now we can quickly repeat
this process for another video let me
just show you the other video which is a
cat again there is uh this cat is not
really moving or anything but it is just
standing there staring and moving a
little slowly and
our application will our network will
detect that this is a cat and even when
the cat moves a little bit in the other
direction it will continue to detect and
show that it is a cat okay so yeah so
this is how the original video is let's
go ahead and change our code to analyze
this one and see if it detects our
network detects this cat close this here
we go and i'll go back to my code all we
need to do is change this traffic to
cat the extension it will automatically
pick up because it is given here and
then it will run through so very quickly
once again what it is doing is this
video reader video underscore reader has
a neat little feature or interface
whereby you can say for frame in video
underscore reader so it will basically
provide frame by frame so you're in a
loop frame by frame and then you take
that each frame that is given to you you
take it and analyze it as if it is an
image individual image so that's the way
it works so it is very easy to handle
this all right so now let's once again
run just this cell the rest of the stuff
remains the same so i will run this cell
again it will take a little while so the
r class has come back i will pause and
then come back in a little while all
right so the processing is done let's go
and check the annotated video go here so
we have get annotated dot mp4 let's play
this all right so you can see here just
detecting the cat and in the beginning
you also saw it detected something else
here there looks like it detected one
more object so let's just go back and
see what it has detected here
let's see yes so what is it trying to
show here it's too small not able to see
but uh it is trying to detect something
i think it is saying it is a car i don't
know
all right okay so in this video there's
only pretty much only one object which
is the cat and
let's wait for some time and see if it
continues to detect it when the cat
turns around and moves as well just
in a little bit that's going to happen
and we will see there we go and in spite
of turning the other way i think our
network is able to detect that it is a
cat so let me freeze and then show here
it is actually still continues to detect
it as a cat all right so that's pretty
much it i think that's the only object
that it detects in this particular video
okay so close this so that's pretty much
it in this video we will learn about an
important popular deep learning neural
network called generative adversarial
networks
yan lacoon one of the pioneers in the
field of machine learning and deep
learning described it as the most
interesting idea in the last 10 years in
machine learning in this video you will
learn about what are generative
adversarial networks and look in brief
at generator and discriminator
then we'll understand how gans work and
the different types of gans
finally we'll look at some of the
applications of gans so let's begin so
what are generative adversarial networks
generative adversarial networks or gans
introduced in 2014 by ian j goodfellow
and co-authors became very popular in
the field of machine learning
gann is an unsupervised learning task in
machine learning it consists of two
models that automatically discover and
learn the patterns in input data
the two models called generator and
discriminator compete with each other to
analyze capture and copy the variations
within a data set
gans can be used to generate new
examples that possibly could have been
drawn from the original data set
in the image below you can see that
there is a database that has real 100
rupee nodes the generator which is
basically a neural network generates
fake hundred rupees notes the
discriminator network will identify if
the nodes are real or fake let us now
understand in brief
about what is a generator a generator in
gans is a neural network that creates
fake data to be trained on the
discriminator
it learns to generate plausible data the
generated instances become negative
training examples for the discriminator
it takes a fixed length random vector
carrying noise as input and generates a
sample now the main aim of the generator
is to make the discriminator classify
its output as real
the portion of the gan that trains a
generator includes
a noisy input vector
the generator network which transforms
the random input into a data instance
a discriminator network which classifies
the generated data and a generator loss
which penalizes the generator for
failing to dalt the discriminator
the back propagation method is used to
adjust each weight in the right
direction by calculating the weight's
impact on the output
the back propagation method is used to
obtain gradients and these gradients can
help change the generator weights now
let us understand in brief what a
discriminator is a discriminator is a
neural network model that identifies
real data from the fake data generated
by the generator the discriminator's
training data
comes from two sources
the real data instances such as real
pictures of birds humans currency notes
etc are used by the discriminator as
positive samples during the training
the fake data instances created by the
generator are used as negative examples
during the training process
while training the discriminator it
connects with two loss functions during
discriminator training the discriminator
ignores the generator loss and just uses
the discriminator laws
in the process of training the
discriminator the discriminator
classifies both real data and fake data
from the generator the discriminator
loss penalizes the discriminator for
misclassifying a real data instance as
fake or a fake data instance as real now
moving ahead
let's understand how gans work now gans
consists of two networks a generator
which is represented as g of x and a
discriminator which is represented as d
of x they both play an adversarial game
where the generator tries to fool the
discriminator by generating data similar
to those in the training set
the discriminator tries not to be fooled
by identifying fake data from the real
data
they both work simultaneously to learn
and train complex data like audio video
or image files now you are aware that
gans consists of two networks at
generator g of x and discriminator dfx
now the generator network takes a sample
and generates a fake sample of data the
generator is trained to increase the
probability of the discriminator network
to make mistakes
on the other hand
the discriminator network decides
whether the data is generated or taken
from the real sample using a binary
classification problem with the help of
a sigmoid function that gives the output
in the range 0 and 1.
here is an example of a generative
adversarial network trying to identify
if the 100 rupee nodes are real or fake
so first a noise vector or the input
vector is fed to the generator network
the generator creates fake hundred rupee
nodes
the real images of hundred rupee notes
stored in a database are passed to the
discriminator along with the fake nodes
the discriminator then identifies the
nodes and classifies them as real or
fake we train the model calculate the
loss function at the end of the
discriminator network and back propagate
the loss into both discriminator and
generator now the mathematical equation
of training again can be represented as
you can see here now this is the
equation
and these are the parameters here g
represents generator
d represents the discriminator
now p data of x is the probability
distribution of real data
p of z is the distribution of generator
x is the sample of probability data of x
z is the sample size from p of z d of x
is the discriminator network and g of
said
is the generator network now the
discriminator focuses to maximize the
objective function such that d of x is
close to 1 and z of z is close to 0.
it simply means that the discriminator
should identify all the images from the
training set as real that is 1
and all the generated images as fake
that is zero the generator wants to
minimize the objective function such
that
d of z of z is one this means that the
generator tries to generate images that
are classified as real that is one by
the discriminator network next
let's see the steps for training a
neural network so we have to first
define the problem
and collect the data
then we'll choose the architecture of
gan now depending on your problem choose
how your gans should look like
then we need to train the discriminator
in real data now that will help us
predict them as real for n number of
times next you need to generate fake
inputs for the generator after that we
need to train the discriminator on fake
data to predict the generator data as
fake finally train the generator on the
output of discriminator
with the discriminator predictions
available train the generator to fool
the discriminator let us now look at the
different types of gans
so first we have vanilla gans
now vanilla gans have min max
optimization formula that we saw earlier
where the discriminator is a binary
classifier and is using sigmoid cross
entropy loss during optimization
in vanilla gans the generator and the
discriminator are simple multi-layer
perceptrons the algorithm tries to
optimize the mathematical equation using
stochastic gradient descent
up next we have deep convolutional gans
or dc gans
now dc gans support convolutional neural
networks instead of vanilla neural
networks at both discriminator and
generator they are more stable and
generate higher quality images the
generator is a set of convolutional
layers with fractional strided
convolutions or transpose convolutions
so it unsamples the input image at every
convolutional layer the discriminator is
a set of convolutional layers with
strided convolution so it down samples
the input image at every convolutional
layer moving ahead
the third type you have is conditional
gans or sea gans vanilla gans can be
extended into conditional models by
using an extra label information to
generate better results in c gan an
additional parameter called y is added
to the generator for generating the
corresponding data
labels are fed as input to the
discriminator to help distinguish the
real data from fake data generated
finally we have super resolution gans
now sr gans use deep neural networks
along with adversarial neural network to
produce higher resolution images super
resolution gans generate a
photorealistic high resolution image
when given a low resolution image let's
look at some of the important
applications of gans
so with the help of dc gans you can
train images of cartoon characters for
generating faces of anime characters and
pokemon characters as well next
gans can be used on the images of humans
to generate realistic faces the faces
that you see on your screens have been
generated using gans and do not exist in
reality third application we have is
gans can be used to build realistic
images from textual descriptions of
objects like birds humans and other
animals
we input a sentence and generate
multiple images
fitting the description here is an
example of a text-to-image translation
using gans for a bird with a black head
yellow body and a sort beak the final
application we have is creating 3d
objects
so gans can generate 3d models using 2d
pictures of objects from multiple
perspectives
gans are very popular in the gaming
industry
gans can help automate the task of
creating 3d characters and backgrounds
to give them a realistic feel
so we're going to dive right into what
is cross we'll also go all the way
through this into a couple of tutorials
because that's where you really learn a
lot is when you roll up your sleeves so
we talk about what is cross cross is a
high level deep learning api written in
python for easy implement implementation
of neural networks uses deep learning
frameworks such as tensorflow pytorch
etc is back in to make computation
faster
and this is really nice because as a
programmer there is so much stuff out
there and it's evolving so fast
it can get confusing and having some
kind of high level order in there we can
actually view it and easily program
these different
neural networks uh is really powerful
it's really powerful to
have something out really quick
and also be able to start testing your
models and seeing where you're going
so crossworks by using complex deep
learning frameworks such as tensorflow
pytorch
ml played etc as a back end for fast
computation
while providing a user friendly and easy
to learn front end
and you can see here we have the cross
api uh specifications and under that
you'd have like tf cross for tensorflow
thano cross and so on and then you have
your tensorflow workflow that this is
all sitting on top of
and this is like i said it organizes
everything the heavy lifting is still
done by tensorflow or whatever you know
underlying package you put in there and
this is really nice because you don't
have to
dig as deeply into the heavy end stuff
while still having a very robust package
you can get up and running rather
quickly
and it doesn't distract from the
processing time because all the heavy
lifting is done by packages like
tensorflow this is the organization on
top of it
so the working principle of cross
the working principle of keras is cross
uses computational graphs to express and
evaluate mathematical expressions
you can see here we put them in blue
they have the expression
expressing complex problems as a
combination of simple mathematical
operators
where we have like the percentage or in
this case in python that's usually your
left your remainder or multiplication
you might have the operator of x to the
power of 0.3 and it uses useful for
calculating derivatives by using uh back
propagation so if we're doing with
neural networks we send the error back
up to figure out how to change it
this makes it really easy to do that
without
really having not banging your head and
having to hand write everything it's
easier to implement distributed
computation
and for solving complex problems
specify input and outputs and make sure
all nodes are connected
and so this is really nice as you come
in through is that as your layers are
going in there you can get some very
complicated
different setups nowadays which we'll
look at in just a second
and this just makes it really easy to
start spinning this stuff up and trying
out the different models
so we look across models across model we
have a sequential model
sequential model is a linear stack of
layers where the previous layer leads
into the next layer
and this if you've done anything else
even like the sk learn with their neural
networks and propagation and any of
these setups this should look familiar
you should have your input layer it goes
into your layer 1 layer 2 and then to
the output layer
and it's useful for simple classifier
decoder models
and you can see down here we have the
model equals across sequential this is
the actual code you can see how easy it
is
uh we have a layer that's dense your
layer one
has an activation now they're using the
relu in this particular example and then
you have your name layer one layer dense
relu name layer two and so forth
and they just feed right into each other
so it's really easy just to stack them
as you can see here and it automatically
takes care of everything else for you
and then there's a functional model
and this is really where things are at
this is new make sure you update your
cross or you'll find yourself running
this
doing the functional model you'll run
into an error code because this is a
fairly new release
and he uses multi input and multi output
model the complex model which forks into
two or more branches
and you can see here we have our image
inputs equals your cross input shape
equals 32 by 32 by 3.
you have your dense layers dense 64
activation relu
this should look similar to what you
already saw before
but if you look at the graph on the
right it's going to be a lot easier to
see what's going on
you have two different inputs
and one way you could think of this is
maybe one of those is a small image and
one of those is a full-sized image
and
that feedback goes into you might feed
both of them into one node because it's
looking for one thing
and then only into one node for the
other one and so you can start to get
kind of an idea that there's a lot of
use
for this kind of split and this kind of
setup
we have multiple information coming in
but the information's very different
even though it overlaps and you don't
want to send it through the same neural
network
and they're finding that this trains
faster and is also has a better result
depending on how you split the data and
how you fork the models coming down
and so in here we do have the two
complex models coming in
we have our image inputs which is a 32
by 32 by three or three channels or four
if you're having an alpha channel
you have your dense your layers dense as
64 activation using the relu very common
x equals dense inputs x layers dense x64
activation equals relu x outputs equals
layers dense 10
x
model equals cross model inputs equals
inputs outputs equals outputs name
equals minced model
uh so we add a little name on there and
again this is this kind of split here
this is setting us up to
have the input go into different areas
so if you're already looking at crust
you probably already have this answer
what are neural networks uh but it's
always good to get on the same page and
for those people who don't fully
understand neural networks to dive into
them a little bit or do a quick overview
neural networks are deep learning
algorithms modeled after the human brain
they use multiple neurons which are
mathematical operations to break down
and solve complex mathical problems
and so just like the neuron one neuron
fires in and it fires out to all these
other neurons or nodes as we call them
and eventually they all come down to
your output layer
and you can see here we have the really
standard graph input layer a hidden
layer and an output layer
one of the biggest parts of any data
processing is your data pre-processing
so we always have to touch base on that
with a neural network like many of these
models they're kind of uh when you first
start using them they're like a black
box you put your data in
you train it and you test it and see how
good it was
and you have to pre-process that data
because bad data in is
bad outputs so in data pre-processing we
will create our own data examples set
with keras the data consists of a
clinical trial conducted on 2100
patients ranging from ages 13 to 100
with a the patients under 65 and the
other half over 65 years of age
we want to find the possibility of a
patient experiencing side effects due to
their age
and you can think of this in today's
world with covid
uh what's going to happen on there and
we're going to go ahead and do an
example of that in our
live hands on like i said most of this
you really need to have hands on to
understand so let's go ahead and bring
up our anaconda and open that up and
open up a jupiter notebook for doing the
python code in now if you're not
familiar with those you can use pretty
much any of your
setups i just like those for doing demos
and showing people especially
shareholders it really helps because
it's a nice visual so let me go and flip
over to our anaconda and the anaconda
has a lot of cool two tools they just
added data lore and ibm watson studio
cloud into the anaconda framework but
we'll be in the jupiter lab or jupiter
notebook i'm going to do a jupiter
notebook for this because i use the lab
for like large projects with multiple
pieces because multiple tabs or the
notebook will work fine for what we're
doing
and this opens up in our browser window
because that's how jupiter dope so
jupiter
notebook is set to run
and we'll go under new
create a new python 3 and it creates an
untitled python we'll go ahead and give
this a title and we'll just call this a
cross
tutorial
and let's change that to capital there
we go i'm going to just rename that
and the first thing we want to go ahead
and do
is uh
get some pre-processing tools involved
and so we need to go ahead and import
some stuff for that like our numpy do
some random number generation
i mentioned sklearn or your site kit if
you're installing sklearn the sk learn
stuff it's a
scikit you want to look up
that should be a tool of anybody who is
doing data science if you're not if
you're not familiar with the sklearn
toolkit
it's huge but there's so many things in
there that we always go back to
and we want to go ahead and create some
train labels and train samples for
training our data
and then
just a note of what we're we're actually
doing in here let me go ahead and change
this this is kind of a fun thing you can
do we can change the code to markdown
and then markdown code is nice for doing
examples once you've already built this
uh our example data we're gonna do
experimental
there we go
experimental drug was tested on 2100
individuals between 13 to 100 years of
age
half the participants are under 65 and
95 percent of participants are under 65
experience no side effects well 95
percent of participants over 65 percent
experience side effects so that's kind
of where we're starting at
and this is just a real quick example
because we're going to do another one
with a little bit more complicated
information
and so we want to go ahead and
generate our setup
so we want to do for i and range and we
want to go ahead and create if you look
here we have random integers
trading the labels append so we're just
creating some random data
let me go ahead and just run that
and so once we've created our random
data and if you if i mean you can
certainly ask for a copy of the code
from simplylearn they'll send you a copy
of this or you can
zoom in on the video and see how we went
ahead and did our train samples of pin
and we're just using this i do this kind
of stuff all the time i was running a
thing on they had to do with errors
following a bell-shaped curve on
a standard distribution error
and so what do i do i generate the data
on a standard distribution error to see
what it looks like and how my code
processes it since that was the baseline
i was looking for in this we're just
doing uh generating random data for our
setup on here
and we could actually go in
print some of the data up let's just do
this print
we'll do train
samples and we'll just do the first
five pieces of data in there to see what
that looks like
and you can see the first five pieces of
data in our train samples is 49 85 41 68
19.
just random numbers generated in there
that's all that is and we generated
significantly more than that
let's see 50 up here 1000. yeah so
there's 1 000 here 1 000 numbers we
generated and we could also if we wanted
to find that out we could do a quick
print the length of it
and
so or you could do a shape kind of thing
and if you're using numpy
although the link for this is just fine
and there we go it's actually 2100 like
we said in the demo setup in there
and then we want to go ahead and take
our labels oh that was our train labels
we also did samples didn't we
so we could also print
do the same thing
labels
and let's change this to
and labels
and run that just to double check and
sure enough we have 2100 and they're
labeled one zero one zero one zero
i guess that's if they have symptoms or
not one symptoms zero none and so we
want to go ahead and take our train
labels and we'll convert it into a numpy
array and the same thing with our
samples
and let's go ahead and run that
and we also shuffle uh this is just a
neat feature you can do in numpy right
here
put my drawing thing on which i didn't
have on earlier
i can take the data and i can shuffle it
so we have our so it's it just
randomizes it that's all that's doing
we've already randomized it so it's kind
of an overkill it's not really necessary
but if you're doing a larger package
where the data is coming in and a lot of
times it's organized somehow
and you want to randomize it just to
make sure that
you know the input doesn't follow a
certain pattern
that might create a bias in your model
and we go ahead and create a scalar
the scalar range minimum max scalar
feature range zero to one
uh and then we go ahead and scale the uh
scaled train samples so we're gonna go
ahead and fit and transform the data
so it's nice and scaled
and that is the age
so you can see up here we have 49 85 41.
we're just moving that so it's going to
be between 0 and 1. and so this is true
with any of your neural networks
you really want to convert the data
to zero and one otherwise you create a
bias
so if you have like a hundred creates a
bias versus
the math behind it gets really
complicated
if you actually start multiplying stuff
there's a lot of multiplication addition
going on in there
that higher end value will eventually
multiply down and it will have a huge
bias as to how the model
fits it and then it will not fit as well
and then one of the fun things we can do
in jupiter notebook is that if you have
a variable you're not doing anything
with it it's the last one on the line
it will automatically print
and we're just going to look at the
first five samples on here it's just
going to print the first five samples
and you can see here we go 0.9195.791
so everything's between 0 and 1.
and that just shows us that we scaled it
properly and it looks good
it really helps a lot to do these kind
of print ups halfway through
you never know what's going to go on
there
i don't know how many times i've gotten
down and found out that the data is sent
to me that i thought was scaled was not
and then i have to go back and track it
down and figure it out on there
uh so let's go ahead and create our
artificial neural network
and for doing that this is where we
start diving into tensorflow and cross
tensorflow
if you don't know the history of
it helps to jump into we'll just use
wikipedia
be careful don't quote wikipedia on
these things because you get in trouble
but it's a good place to start back in
2011 google brain built disbelief as a
proprietary machine learning setup
tensorflow became the open source for it
so tensorflow was a google product
and then it became
uh open sourced and now it's just become
probably one of the defactos when it
comes for neural networks as far as
where we're at
so when you see the tensorflow setup
it's got like a huge following there are
some other setups like
the scikit under the sk learn has their
own little neural network
but the tensorflow is the most robust
one out there right now
and cross sitting on top of it makes it
a very powerful tool so we can leverage
both the cross
easiness in which we can build a
sequential setup
on top of tensorflow
and so in here we're going to go ahead
and do our input of tensorflow
uh and then we have the rest of this is
all cross here from number two down uh
we're going to import from tensorflow
the cross connection and then you have
your tensorflow cross models import
sequential it's a specific kind of model
we'll look at that in just a second if
you remember
from the files that means it goes from
one layer to the next layer to the next
layer there's no funky splits or
anything like that
and then we have from tensorflow across
layers we're going to import our
activation and our dense layer
and we have our optimizer atom
this is a big thing to be aware of how
you optimize uh your data when you first
do it adam's as good as any atom is
usually there's a number of optimizer
out there there's about uh there's a
couple of main ones but atom is usually
assigned to bigger data
it works fine usually the lower data
does it just fine but atom is probably
the mostly used but there are some more
out there and depending on what you're
doing with your layers your different
layers might have different activations
on them and then finally down here
you'll see
our setup where we want to go ahead and
use the metrics
and we're going to use the tensorflow
cross metrics
for categorical cross entropy so we can
see how everything performs when we're
done that's all that is a lot of times
you'll see us
go back and forth between tensorflow and
then scikit has a lot of really good
metrics also for measuring these things
again it's the end of the day at the end
of the story how good does your model do
and we'll go ahead and load all that and
then comes the fun part um i actually
like to spend hours messing with these
things
and uh four lines of code you're like oh
you're gonna spend hours on four lines
of code
um no we don't spend hours on four lines
of code that's not what we're talking
about when i say spend hours on four
lines of code uh what we have here i'm
gonna explain that in just a second we
have a model and it's a sequential model
if you remember correctly we mentioned
the sequential up here where it goes
from one layer to the next
and our first layer is going to be our
input
it's going to be what they call dents
which is uh
usually it's just dense and then you
have your input and your activation
how many units are coming in we have 16
what's the shape
what's the activation and this is where
it gets interesting
because we have in here
uh relu
on two of these and softmax activation
on one of these
there are so many different options for
what these mean
and how they function how does the relu
how does the soft max function
and they do a lot of different things
we're not going to go into the
activations in here that is what really
you spend hours doing is looking at
these different activations
and just
some of it is just
almost like you're playing with it
like an artist you start getting a fill
for like a
inverse tangent activation or the 10h
activation
takes up a huge processing amount
so you don't see it a lot
yet
it comes up with a better solution
especially when you're doing uh when
you're analyzing word documents and
you're tokenizing the words
and so you'll see this shift from one to
the other because you're both trying to
build a better model
and if you're working on a huge data set
um it'll crash the system it'll just
take too long to process
and then you see things like soft max
softmax
generates an interesting
setup where a lot of these when you talk
about rayleigh it lets me do this uh
rayleigh there we go relu has
a setup where if it's less than zero
it's zero and then it goes up
and then you might have what they call
lazy
setup where it has a slight negative to
it so that the errors can translate
better same thing with softmax it has a
slight laziness to it so that errors
translate better all these little
details
make a huge difference on your model
so one of the really cool things about
data science that i like
is you build
your
what they call you build to fail and
it's an interesting
design setup oops i forgot the end of my
code here
the concept to build a file is you want
the model as a whole to work so you can
test your model out
so that you can do uh
you can get to the end and you can do
your let's see where was it
over shot down here
you can test your test out the quality
of your setup on there
and
see where did i do my tensorflow oh here
we go it was right above me there we go
we start doing your cross entropy and
stuff like that is you need a full
functional set of code so that when you
run it
you can then test your model out and say
hey it's either this model works better
than this model and this is why
and then you can start swapping in these
models and so when i say i spend a huge
amount of time on pre-processing data
it's probably 80 of your programming
time
well between those two it's like 80 20.
you'll spend a lot of time on the models
once you get the model down once you get
the whole code and the flow down
set
depending on your data your models get
more and more robust as you start
experimenting with different inputs
different data streams and all kinds of
things and we can do a simple model
summary here
here's our sequential here's a layer
output a parameter
this is one of the nice things about
cross is you just you can see right here
here's our sequential one model boom
boom boom boom everything's set and
clear and easy to read
so once we have our model built uh the
next thing we're going to want to do is
we're going to go ahead and train that
model
and so the next step is of course model
training
and when we come in here
this a lot of times it's just paired
with the model because it's so
straightforward it's nice to
print out the model setup so you can
have a tracking
but here's our model
the keyword in cross is compile
optimizer atom learning rate another
term right there that we're just
skipping right over
that really becomes the meat of
[Music]
the setup is your learning rate uh so
whoops i forgot that i had an arrow but
i'll just underline it
a lot of times the learning rate set to
0.00
set to 0.01
depending on what you're doing
this learning rate
can overfit and underfit
so you'd want to look up
i know we have a number of tutorials out
on overfitting and under fitting that
are really worth reading once you get to
that point and understanding and we have
our loss
sparse categorical cross entropy
so this is going to tell kuros how far
to go until it stops
and then we're looking for metrics of
accuracy so we'll go ahead and run that
and now that we've compiled our model
we want to go ahead and
run it fit it so here's our model fit
um we have our scaled train samples
our train labels our validation split
in this case we're going to use 10
percent of the data for validation
uh batch size another number you kind of
play with not a huge difference as far
as how it works
but it does affect how long it takes to
run and it can also affect the bias a
little bit most of the time though a
batch size is between 10 to 100
depending on just how much data you're
processing in there we want to go ahead
and shuffle it we're going to go through
30 epochs
and
put the verb rows of two let me just go
ahead and run this
and you can see right here here's our
epic here's our training
here's our loss now if you remember
correctly up here we set the loss let's
see where was it
compiled our data
there we go loss uh so it's looking at
the sparse categorical cross entropy
this tells us that as it goes how how
how much um how how much does the
error go down
is the best way to look at that and you
can see here
the lower the number the better it just
keeps going down
and vice versa accuracy we want let's
see where's my accuracy
value accuracy at the end
and you can see 0.619 0.69 0.74 it's
going up we want the accuracy would be
ideal if it made it all the way to 1
but we also the loss is more important
because
it's a balance you can have 100 accuracy
and your model doesn't work because it's
over fitted
again you won't look up
overfitting and under fitting models
and we went ahead and went through 30
epics it's always fun to kind of watch
your code going
to be honest i
usually
[Music]
the first time i run it i'm like oh
that's cool i get to see what it does
and after the second time of running it
i'm like i like to just not see that and
you can repress those of course in your
code
repress the warnings in the printing
and so the next step is going to be
building a test set and predicting it
now
so here we go we want to go ahead and
build our test set
and we have just like we did our
training set
a lot of times you just split your your
initial set up
but we'll go ahead and do a separate set
on here
and this is just what we did above
there's no difference as far as
the randomness that we're using to build
this set on here
the only difference is that
we already
did our scalar up here well it doesn't
matter because the data is going to be
across the same thing but this should
just be just transform down here instead
of fit transform
because you don't want to refit your
data
on your
testing data
there we go now we're just transforming
it because you never want to transform
the test data
easy to mistake to make especially on an
example like this where we're not doing
you know we're randomizing the data
anyway so it doesn't matter too much
because we're not expecting something
weird
and then we went ahead and do our
predictions the whole reason we built
the model is we take our model we
predict
and we're going to do here's our x scale
data batch size 10 verbose
and now we have our predictions in here
and we could go ahead and do a
we'll print
predictions
and then i guess i could just put down
predictions in five so we can look at
the first five of the predictions
and what we have here is we have our
age
and uh the prediction on this age versus
on what is what we think it's going to
be but what we think is going to they
are going to have uh symptoms or not
and the first thing we notice is that's
hard to read because we really want to
yes no answer
so we'll go ahead and just
round off the predictions
using the arg max
the numpy arg max for prediction so it
just goes to zero one
and
if you remember this is a jupiter
notebook so i don't have to put the
print i can just put in
rounded predictions and we'll just do
the first five
and you can see here zero one zero zero
zero so that's what the predictions are
that we have coming out of this
is no symptoms symptoms no symptoms
symptoms no symptoms
and just as we were talking about at the
beginning we want to go ahead and
take a look at this there we go
confusion matrix is for accuracy check
most important part
when you get down to the end of the
story how accurate is your model before
you go and play with the model and see
if you can get a better accuracy out of
it and for this we'll go ahead and use
the scikit the sk learn metrics site kit
being where that comes from
import confusion matrix
some iteration tools and of course a
nice map plot library
that makes a big difference so it's
always nice
to have a nice graph to look at a
picture is worth a thousand words
and then we'll go ahead and call it cm
for confusion matrix why true equals
test labels why predict rounded
predictions
and we'll go ahead and load in our cm
and i'm not going to spend too much time
on the plotting
going over the different plotting code
you can spend
like whole we have whole tutorials on
how to do your different plotting on
there uh but we do have here is we're
gonna do a plot confusion matrix there's
our cm our classes normalize false title
confusion matrix
c map is going to be in blues
and you can see here we have uh to the
nearest c map titles all the different
pieces whether you put tick marks or not
the marks the classes the color bar
so a lot of different information on
here as far as how we're doing the
printing of the of the confusion matrix
you can also just dump the confusion
matrix into a seaborn and real quick get
an output
it's worth knowing how to do all this uh
when you're doing a presentation to the
shareholders
you don't want to do this on the fly you
want to take the time to make it look
really nice like our guys in the back
did and let's go ahead and do this
forgot to put together our cm plot
labels
we'll go ahead and run that
and then we'll go ahead and call the
little the
definition
for our mapping
and you can see here plot confusion
matrix that's our the little script we
just wrote and we're going to dump our
data into it
so our confusion matrix
our classes
title confusion matrix and let's just go
ahead and run that
and you can see here we have our basic
setup
no side effects 195
had side effects 200
no side effects that had side effects so
we predicted the 10 of them
who actually had side effects and that's
pretty good i mean i don't know about
you but you know that's five percent
error on this and this is because
there's 200 here that's where i get five
percent is uh divide these both by by
two and you get five out of a hundred uh
you can do the same kind of math up here
not as quick on the fly because it's 15
and 195 not an easily rounded number but
you can see here where they have 15
people
who predicted to have no
with the no side effects but had side
effects
kind of set up on there and these
confusion matrix are so important at the
end of the day
this is really where where you show uh
whatever you're working on comes up and
you can actually show them hey this is
how good we are or not how messed up it
is
so this was a uh i spent a lot of time
on some of the parts uh but you can see
here is really simple uh we did the
random generation of data but when we
actually built the model coming up here
uh here's our model summary
and we just have the layers on here that
we built with our model on this and then
we went ahead and trained it and ran the
prediction
now we get a lot more complicated let me
flip back on over here because we're
going to do another uh demo
so that was our basic introduction to it
we talked about the uh oops there we go
okay so implementing a neural network
with keras after creating our samples
and labels we need to create our cross
neural network model we will be working
with a sequential model which has three
layers and this is what we did we had
our input layer our hidden layers and
our output layers and you can see the
input layer coming in
was the age factor we had our hidden
layer and then we had the output are you
going to have symptoms or not
so we're going to go ahead and go with
something a little bit more complicated
training our model is a two-step process
we first compile our model and then we
train it in our training data set
so we have compiling compiling converts
the code into a form of understandable
by machine
we use the atom in the last example a
gradient descent algorithm to optimize a
model and then we trained our model
which means it let it uh learn on
training data
and i actually had a little backwards
there but this is what we just did is we
if you remember from our code we just
had let me go back here
here's our model that we created
summarized
we come down here and we compile it
so it tells it hey we're ready to build
this model and use it and then we train
it this is the part where we go ahead
and fit our model and put that
information in here and it goes through
the training on there
and of course we scaled the data which
was really important to do and then you
saw we did the creating a confusion
matrix with keras
as we are performing classifications on
our data we need a confusion matrix to
check the results a confusion matrix
breaks down the various
misclassifications as well as correct
classifications to get the accuracy
and so you can see here this is what we
did with the true positive false
positive true negative false negative
and that is what we went over let me
just scroll down here
on the end we printed it out and you can
see we have a nice printout of our
confusion matrix
uh with the true positive false positive
false negative true negative
and so the blue ones uh we want those to
be the biggest numbers because those are
the better side and then
we have our false predictions on here
as far as this one so had no side
effects but we predicted
let's see no side effects predicting
side effects and vice versa if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skill up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
now
saving and loading models with karass
we're going to dive into a more
complicated demo
and you can say oh that was a lot of
complication before well if you broke it
down we randomized some data we created
the
kara setup we compiled it we trained it
we predicted and we ran our matrix
uh so we're going to dive into something
a lot a little bit more fun is we're
going to do a face mask detection with
cross so we're going to build a cross
model to check if a person is wearing a
mask or not in real time and this might
be important if you're at the front of a
store this is something today which is
um
might be very useful as far as some of
our you know making sure people are safe
and so we're going to look at mask and
no mask and let's start with a little
bit on the data
and so in my data i have with a mask you
can see they just have a number of
images showing the people in masks and
again
if you want some of this information
contact simply learn and they can send
you some of the information as far as
people with and without masks so you can
try it on your own and this is just such
a wonderful example of this setup on
here
so before i dive into the mass detection
talk about being in the current with a
covid and seeing if people are wearing
masks
this particular example i had to go
ahead and update to a python 3.8 version
it might run in a 3.7 i'm not sure i
haven't i kind of skipped three seven
and installed three eight
so i'll be running in a three python
three-eighth
and then you also want to make sure your
tensorflow is up to date
because the um they call functional
uh layers with that's where they split
if you remember correctly from back
oh let's take a look at this
remember from here the functional model
and a functional layer allows us to feed
in the different layers into different
you know different nodes into different
layers and split them a very powerful
tool
very popular right now in the edge of
where things are with neural networks
and creating a better model so i've
upgraded to python 3.8 and let's go
ahead and open that up and
go through
our next example which includes
multiple layers
programming it to recognize whether
someone wears a mask or not and then
saving that model so we can use it in
real time so we're actually almost a
full
um end-to-end development of a product
here of course this is a very simplified
version and it'd be a lot more to it
you'd also have to do like recognizing
whether it's someone's face or not all
kinds of other things go into this
so let's go ahead and jump into that
code and we'll open up a new python
three oops python three
it's working on it there we go
and then we want to go ahead and train
our mask we'll just call this train mask
and we want to go ahead and train mask
and save it
so it's
safe mask train mask detection
not to be confused with masking data a
little bit different we're actually
talking about a physical mask on your
face
and then from the cross standpoint we've
got a lot of imports to do here
and i'm not going to dig too deep on the
imports
we're just going to go ahead and notice
a few of them
so we have in here
alt d there we go
have something to draw with a little bit
here
we have our
image processing
and the image processing right here let
me underline that
deals with how do we bring images in
because most images are like a
square grid and then each value in there
has three values for the three different
colors
cross and tensorflow do a really good
job of
working with that so you don't have to
do all the heavy listening and figuring
out what's going to go on
uh and we have the mobile net average
pooling 2d
this again is
how do we deal with the images and
pulling them
dropout's a cool thing worth looking up
if you haven't when you as you get more
and more into cross and tensorflow
it'll auto drop out certain nodes that
way you'll get a better um
the notes just kind of die
they find that they actually create more
of a bias and help
and they also add processing time so
they remove them
and then we have our flatten that's
where you take that huge array with the
three different colors and you find a
way to flatten it so it's just a one
dimensional array instead of a two by
two by three
dense input we did that in the other one
so that should look a little familiar
oops there we go our input
our model again these are things we had
on the last one
here's our optimizer with our atom
we have some pre-processing on the input
that goes along with bringing in the
data in
more pre-processing with image to array
loading the image
this stuff is so nice it looks like a
lot of works you have to import all
these different modules in here but the
truth is is it does everything for you
you're not doing a lot of pre-processing
you're letting the software do the
pre-processing
and we're going to be working with the
setting something to categorical
again that's just a conversion from a
number to a category 0 1 doesn't really
mean anything it's like true false
label binarizer the same thing uh we're
changing our labels around and then
there's our train test split
classification report um our
im utilities let me just go ahead and
scroll down here a notch for these
this is something a little different
going on down here this is not part of
the
tensorflow or the sklearn this is the
site kit set up in tensorflow above
the path this is part of
opencv
and we'll actually have another tutorial
going out with the opencv so if you want
to know more about opencv you'll get a
glance on it in
this software especially the
second piece when we reload up the data
and hook it up to a video camera we're
going to do that on this round
but this is part of the opencv thing
you'll see cv2 is usually how that's
referenced
but the im utilities has to do with how
do you rotate pictures around and stuff
like that
and resize them and then the matte plot
library for plotting because it's nice
to have a graph tells us how good we're
doing and then of course our numpy
numbers array and just a straight os
access wow so that was a lot of imports
like i said i'm not going to spend i
spent a little time going through them
but we didn't want to go too much into
them
and then i'm going to create
some variables that we need to go ahead
and initialize
we have the learning rate number of
epics to train for and the batch size
and if you remember correctly we talked
about the learning rate
to the negative 4.0001
a lot of times it's 0.001 or 0.001
usually it's in that
variation depending on what you're doing
and how many epochs and they kind of
play with the epics
the epics is how many times we're going
to go through all the data
and now i have it as two
the actual setup is for 20 and 20 works
great the reason i have it for two is it
takes a long time to process
one of the downsides of jupiter
is that jupiter isolates it to a single
kernel so even though i'm on an eight
core processor
with 16 dedicated threads only one
thread is running on this no matter what
so it doesn't matter
so it takes a lot longer to run even
though
tensorflow really scales up nicely and
the batch size is how many pictures do
we load at once in process
again those are numbers you have to
learn to play with depending on your
data and what's coming in and the last
thing we want to go ahead and do is
there's a directory with a data set
we're going to run
and this just has images of mass and not
masks
and if we go in here you'll see data set
um and then you have pictures with mass
they're just images of people with mass
on their face uh and then we have the
opposite let me go back up here
without masks so it's pretty
straightforward they look kind of askew
because they tried to format them into
very similar uh setup on there so
they're they're
mostly squares you'll see some that are
slightly different on here
and that's kind of important thing to do
on a lot of these data sets
get them as close as you can to each
other and we'll we actually will run in
the in this processing of images up here
and the cross layers and importing and
dealing with images it does such a
wonderful job of converting these that a
lot of it we don't have to do a whole
lot with
so you have a couple things going on
there
and so we're now going to be this is now
loading the
images
and let me see
we'll go ahead and create data and
labels here's our
here's the features going in which is
going to be our pictures and our labels
going out
and then for categories in our list
directory directory and if you remember
i just flashed that at you it had a
face mask or or no face mask those are
the two options
and we're just going to load into that
we're going to append the image itself
and the labels so we'll just create a
huge array
and you can see right now this could be
an issue if you had more data at some
point
thankfully i have a 32 gig hard drive or
ram
even that
doesn't you could do with a lot less of
that probably under 16 or even eight
gigs would easily load all this stuff
and there's a conversion going on in
here i told you about how we are going
to convert
the size of the image so it resizes all
the images that way our data is all
identical the way it comes in
and you can see here with our labels we
have without mask without mask without
mask
the other one would be with mask those
are the two that we have going in there
and then we need to change it to the one
not hot encoding
and this is going to take our
up here we had was it labels and data
we want the labels to be categorical so
we're going to take labels and change it
to categorical and our labels then equal
a categorical list
we'll run that and again if we do
labels and we just do the last or the
first 10. let's do the last 10 just
because
minus 10 to the end there we go
just so we can see where the other side
looks like we now have one that means
they have a mask one zero one zero so on
uh one being they have a mask and zero
no mask
and if we did this in reverse
i just realized that this might not make
sense if you've never done this before
let me run this
zero one
so zero
is
do they have a mask on zero do they not
have a mask on one so this is the same
as what we saw up here without mask one
equals
the second value is without mass so with
mass without mask
and that's just a with any of your data
processing
we can't really zero if you have a zero
one output
uh
it causes issues as far as training and
setting it up so we always want to use a
one hot encoder if the values are not
actual
uh linear value or regression values
they're not actual numbers
if they represent a thing
and so now we need to go ahead and do
our train x test x train y test y
train split test data
and we'll go ahead and make sure it's
going to be random and we'll take 20
percent of it for testing
and the rest for
setting it up as far as training their
model
this is something that's become so cool
when they're training these set
they realize we can augment the data
what does augment mean well if i rotate
the data around and i zoom in i zoom out
i rotate it
share it a little bit flip it
horizontally
fill mode as they do all these different
things to the data it
is able to it's kind of like increasing
the number of samples i have
so if i have all these perfect samples
what happens when we only have part of
the face or the face is tilted sideways
or all those little shifts cause a
problem if you're doing just a standard
set of data so we're going to create an
augment
in our image data generator
which is going to rotate zoom and do all
kinds of cool thing and this is worth
looking up this image data generator and
all the different features it has
a lot of times i'll the first time
through my models i'll leave that out
because i want to make sure there's a
thing we call build to fail which is
just cool to know
you build the whole process and then you
start adding these different things in
uh so that you can better train your
model and so we go and run this and then
we're gonna load
and then we need to go ahead and you
probably would have gotten an error if
you hadn't put this piece in right here
um i haven't run it myself because the
guys in the back did this uh we take our
base model and one of the things we want
to do is we want to do a mobile net v2
and this we this is a big thing right
here include the top equals false
a lot of data comes in with a label on
the top row
so we want to make sure that that is not
the case
and then the construction of the head of
the model that will be placed on the top
of the base model
we want to go ahead and set that up
and you'll see a warning here i'm kind
of ignoring the warning because it has
to do with the
size of the pictures and the weights for
input shape
so they'll switch things to defaults to
saying hey we're going to auto shape
some of this stuff for you you should be
aware that with this kind of imagery
we're already augmenting it by moving it
around and flipping it and doing all
kinds of things to it
so that's not a bad thing in this but
another data it might be if you're
working in a different domain
and so we're going to go back here and
we're going to have we have our base
model we're going to do our head model
equals our base model output
and what we got here is we have an
average pooling 2d pool size 77 head
model
head model flattened so we're flattening
the data
so this is all
processing and flattening the images and
the pooling has to do
with some of the ways it can process
some of the data we'll look at that a
little bit when we get down to the lower
levels processing it
and then we have our dents we've already
talked a little bit about a dents just
what you think about and then the head
model has a drop out
of 0.5
what we can do with a drop out
the dropout says that we're going to
drop out a certain amount of nodes while
training
so when you actually use the model
it will use all the nodes but this drops
certain ones out and it helps
stop biases from performing so it's
really a cool feature in here
they discovered this a while back
uh we have another dense mode and this
time we're using soft max activation
lots of different activation options
here softmax is a real popular one for a
lot of things
and so is relu
and you know there's we could do a whole
talk on activation formulas uh and why
what their different uses are and how
they work
when you first start out you'll you'll
use mostly the relu and the max for a
lot of them
just because they're some of the basic
setups it's a good place to start
and then we have our model equals model
inputs equals base model dot input
outputs equals head model so again we're
still building our model here we'll go
ahead and run that
and then we're going to loop over all
the layers in the base model and freeze
them so they will not be updated during
the first training process
so for layer and base model layers
layers dot trainable equals false
a lot of times when you go through your
data
you want to kind of jump in part way
through
i
i'm not sure why in the back they did
this for this particular example
but i do this a lot when i'm working
with series and
specifically in stock data
i wanted to iterate through the first
set of 30 data before it does anything
i would have to look deeper to see why
they froze it on this particular one
and then we're going to compile our
model
so compiling the model atom
init layer decay
initial learning rate over epics
and we go ahead and compile our loss is
going to be the binary cross entropy
which will have that print out
optimizer for opt metrics is accuracy
same thing we had before not a huge jump
as far as
the previous code
and then we go ahead and we've gone
through all this and now we need to go
ahead and fit our model
so train the head of the network print
info training head run
now i skipped a little time because
you'll see the run time here is at 80
seconds per epic takes a couple minutes
for it to get through on a single kernel
one of the things i want you to notice
on here while we're while it's finishing
the processing
is that we have up here our augment
going on so
anytime the train x and trading y go in
there's some randomness going on there
it is jiggling it around what's going
into our setup
uh of course we're batch sizing it so
it's going through whatever we set for
the batch values how many we process at
a time
and then we have the steps per epic
the train x the batch size validation
data here's our
test x and test y where we're sending
that in
and this again it's validation
one of the important things to know
about validation is are
when both our training data and our test
data have about the same accuracy that's
when you want to stop that means that
our model isn't biased
if you have a higher accuracy on your
testing
you know you've trained it and your
accuracy is higher on your actual test
data then something in there is probably
uh has a bias and it's overfitted
so that's what this is really about
right here with the validation data and
validation steps
so it looks like it's let me go ahead
and see if it's done processing it looks
like we've gone ahead and gone through
two epics again you could run this
through about 20
with this amount of data and it would
give you a nice refined uh model at the
end we're going to stop at 2 because i
really don't want to sit around all
afternoon and i'm running this on a
single thread
so now that we've done this we're going
to need to evaluate
our model and see how good it is and to
do that we need to go ahead and make our
predictions
um these are our predictions on our test
x
to see what it thinks are going to be uh
so now it's going to be evaluating the
network and then we go ahead and go down
here and we will need to
turn the index in because remember it's
it's either zero or one it's a
zero one zero one so you have two
outputs uh not wearing uh wearing a mask
not wearing a mask and so we need to go
ahead and take that argument at the end
and change those predictions to a
0 or 1 coming out
and then
to finish that off we want to go ahead
and let me just put this right in here
and do it all in one shot we want to
show a nicely formatted classification
report so we can see what that looks
like on here
and there we have it we have our
precision uh it's 97 with the mask
there's our f1 score support without a
mass 97
um so that's pretty
high uh set up on there you know you
three people are going to sneak into the
store who
are without a mask and
thinks they have a mask and there's
going to be three people with a mask
that's going to flag the person at the
front to go oh hey look at this person
you might not have a mask
that's if i guess it's just set up in
front of a store
um so there you have it and of course
one of the other cool things about this
is if someone's walking in to the store
and you take multiple pictures of them
you know this is just an it would be a
way of flagging and then you can take
that average of those pictures and make
sure they match or don't match if you're
on the back end and this is an important
step because we're gonna this is just
cool i love doing this stuff uh so we're
gonna go ahead and take our model and
we're gonna save it uh so model save
mass detector.model we're gonna give it
a name
uh we're gonna save the format
in this case we're going to use the h5
format
and so this model we just programmed has
just been saved
so now i can load it up into say another
program what's cool about this is let's
say i want to have somebody work on the
other part of the program well i just
save the model they upload the model now
they can use it for whatever and then if
i get more information
and we start working with that
at some point
i might want to update this model and
make a better model and this is true of
so many things where i take this model
and maybe i'm running a prediction on
making money for a company and as my
model gets better
i want to keep updating it and then it's
really easy just to push that out to the
actual end user
uh here we have a nice graph you can see
the training loss and accuracy as we go
through the epics
we only did the you know only shows just
the one epic coming in here but you can
see right here as the
value loss train accuracy and value
accuracy
starts switching and they start
converging and you'll hear converging
this is a convergence they're talking
about when they say you're you're
i know when i work in the
psy kit with sk learn neural networks
this is what they're talking about a
convergence
is our
loss and our accuracy come together and
also up here and this is why i'd run it
more than just two epics as you can see
they still haven't converged all the way
so that would be a cue for me to keep
going
but what we want to do is we want to go
ahead and create a new python 3
program
and we just did our train mask so now
we're going to go ahead and import that
and use it and show you in a live action
get a view of both myself in the
afternoon along with my background of an
office which is in the middle still of
reconstruction for another month
and we'll call this a mask
detector
and then we're going to grab a bunch of
a few items coming in
we have our mobile net v2 import
pre-processing input so we're still
going to need that
we still have our tensorflow image to
array we have our load model that's
where most of this stuff is going on
this is our cv2 or opencv again i'm not
going to dig too deep into that we're
going to flash a little opencv code at
you
and we actually have a tutorial on that
coming out
our numpy array our im utilities which
is part of the opencv or cv2 setup
and then we have of course time and just
our operating system so those are the
things we're going to go ahead and set
up on here and then we're going to
create
this takes just a moment
our module here which is going to do all
the heavy lifting
so we're going to detect and predict the
mask we have frame face net mass net
these are going to be generated by our
open cv we have our frame coming in and
then we want to go ahead and
create a mask around the face it's going
to try to detect the face and then set
that up so we know
what we're going to be processing
through our model
and then there's a frame shape here this
is just our height versus width that's
all hw stands for
they've called it blob which is a cv2
dnn blob form image frame
so this is reformatting this frame
that's going to be coming in literally
from my camera and we'll show you that
in a minute that little piece of code
that shoots that in here
and we're going to pass the blob through
the network and obtain the face
detections
so face net dot set import blob
detections face net forward
print detections shape
uh so this is this is what's going on
here this is that model we just created
we're gonna send that in there and i'll
show you in a second where that is but
it's gonna be under face net
uh and then we go ahead and initialize
our list of faces their corresponding
locations in the list of predictions
from our face mask network
we're going to loop over the detections
and this is a little bit more work than
you think
as far as looking for different faces
whatever the view of a crowd of faces
so we're looping through the detections
and the shapes going through here
and probability associated with the
detection here's our confidence of
detections
we're going to filter out weak detection
by ensuring the confidence is greater
than the minimum confidence
so we've said it remember zero to one so
0.5 would be our minimal confidence
probably is pretty good
[Music]
and then we're going to put in compute
bounding boxes for the object if i'm
zipping through this it's because we're
going to do an open cv and i really want
to stick to just the cross part
and so i'm just kind of jumping through
all this code you can get a copy of this
code from simplylearn and take it apart
or look for the opencv coming out
and we'll create a box the box sets it
around the image
ensure the bounding boxes fall within
the dimensions of the frame
as we create a box around what's going
to what we hope is going to be the face
extract the face roi convert it from bgr
to rgb channel
again this is an open cv issue not
really an issue but it has to do with
the order i don't know how many times
i've forgotten to check the order colors
when working with opencv
because there's all kinds of fun things
when red becomes blue
and blue becomes red
and we're going to resize it process it
frame it
face frame
setup again the face the cbt color we're
going to convert it
we're going to resize it
image to array pre-process the input
pin the face locate face start x dart y
and x
boy that was just a huge amount and i
skipped over a ton of it but the bottom
line is we're building a box around the
face
and that box because the open cv does a
decent job of finding the face and that
box is going to go in there and see hey
does this person have a mask on it
and so that's what that's what all this
is doing on here and then finally we get
down to this where it says predictions
equals mass net dot predict faces batch
size 32
so these different images of where we're
guessing where the faces are then going
to go through and
generate an array of faces if you will
and we're going to look through and say
does this face have a mask on it and
that's what's going right here is our
prediction that's the big thing that
we're working for
and then we return the locations and the
predictions the location just tells
where on the picture it is
and then the
prediction tells us what it is is it a
mask or is it not a mask
all right so we've loaded that all up
so we're going to load our serialized
face detector model from disk
and we have our the path that it was
saved in obviously you're going to put
it in a different
path depending on where you have it or
however you want to do it and how you
saved it on the last one where we
trained it
and then we have our weights path
and so finally our face net here it is
equals cb2.dnn.readnet
prototext path weights path and we're
going to load that up on here so let me
go ahead and run that
and then we also need to i'll just put
it right down here i always hate
separating these things in there
and then we're going to load the actual
mass detector model from disk this is
the the model that we saved so let's go
ahead and run that on there also
so this is pulling on all the different
pieces we need for our model
and then the next part
is we're going to create open up our
video
and this is just kind of fun because
it's all part of the opencv
a video setup
and we just put this all in as one
there we go
so we're going to go ahead and open up
our video we're going to start it and
we're going to run it until we're done
and this is where we get some real like
kind of live action stuff which is fun
this is what i like working about with
images and videos
is that when you start working with
images and videos it's all like right
there in front of you it's visual and
you can see what's going on
so we're going to start our video
streaming this is grabbing our video
stream source zero start
that means it's grabbing my main camera
i have hooked up
and then you know starting video you're
gonna print it out
here's our video source equals zero
start loop over the frames from the
video stream
oops a little redundancy there
let me close
i'll just leave it that's how they
headed in the code so
so while true we're going to grab the
frame from the threaded video stream and
resize it to have the maximum width of
400 pixels so here's our frame we're
going to read it
from our visual
stream
we're going to resize it
and then we have we're returning
remember we return from the our
procedure the location and the
prediction so detect and predict mask
we're sending it the frame
we're sending it the face net and the
mass net so we're sending all the
different pieces that say this is what's
going through on here
and then it returns our location and
predictions and then for our box
and predictions in the location and
predictions
and the boxes is again this is an open
cv set that says hey this is a box
coming in from the location
because you have the two different
points on there
and then we're going to unpack the box
in predictions and we're going to go
ahead and do mask without a mask equals
prediction
we're going to create our label
no mask and create color if the label
equals mask l0225
and you know it's going to make a lot
more sense when i hit the run button
here but we have the probability of the
label
we're going to display the label and
bounding box rectangle on the output
frame
and then we're going to go ahead and
show the output from the frame cv2 i am
show frame frame and then the key equals
cp2 weight key one we're just going to
wait till the next one comes through
from our feed
and we're going to do this until we hit
the stop button pretty much
so you're ready for this to see if it
works we've distributed our
our model we've loaded it up into our
distributed uh code here we've got it
hooked into our camera and we're going
to go ahead and run it
and there it goes it's going to be
running and we can see the data coming
down here and we're waiting for the
pop-up
and there i am in my office with my
funky headset on
uh
and you can see in the background my
unfinished wall and it says up here no
mask oh no i don't have a mask on
i wonder if i cover my mouth
what would happen
you can see my no mask
goes down a little bit i wish i brought
a mask into my office it's up at the
house but you can see here that this
says you know there's a 95 98
chance that i don't have a mask on and
it's true i don't have a mask on right
now and this could be distributed this
is actually an excellent little piece of
script that you can start you know you
install somewhere on a video feed on a
on a security camera or something and
then you'd have this really neat uh
setup saying hey do you have a mask on
when you enter a store or a public
transportation or whatever it is where
they're required to wear a mask
let me go ahead and stop that
now if you want a copy of this
code definitely give us a hauler we will
be going into opencv in another one so i
skipped a lot of the opencv
code in here as far as going into detail
really focusing on the cross
saving the model uploading the model and
then processing a streaming video
through it so you can see it that the
model works we actually have this
working model that hooks into
the video camera
which is just pretty cool a lot of fun
so i told you we're going to dive in and
really roll up our sleeve and do a lot
of coding today we did the basic
demo up above for just pulling in a
cross and then we went into a cross
model
where we pulled in data to see whether
someone was wearing a mask or not so
very useful in today's world as far as a
fully running application welcome to the
rnn tutorial that's the recurrent neural
network so we talk about a feed forward
neural network in a feed forward neural
network information flows only in the
forward direction from the input nodes
through the hidden layers if any into
the output nodes there are no cycles or
loops in the network and so you can see
here we have our input layer i was
talking about how it just goes straight
forward into the hidden layers so each
one of those connects and then connects
to the next hidden layer connects to the
output layer and of course we have a
nice simplified version where it has a
predicted output the refer to the input
is x a lot of times and the output as y
decisions are based on current input no
memory about the past no future scope
why recurrent neural network issues in
feed forward neural network so one of
the biggest issues is because it doesn't
have a scope of memory or time a feed
forward neural network doesn't know how
to handle sequential data it only
considers only the current input so if
you have a series of things and because
three points back affects what's
happening now and what your output
affects what's happening that's very
important so whatever i put as an output
is going to affect the next one um a
feedforward doesn't look at any of that
it just looks at this is what's coming
in and it cannot memorize previous
inputs so it doesn't have that list of
inputs coming in solution to feed
forward neural network you'll see here
where it says recurrent neural network
and we have our x on the bottom going to
h going to y that's your feed forward
but right in the middle it has a value c
so there's a whole another process was
memorizing what's going on in the hidden
layers and the hidden layers as they
produce data feed into the next one so
your hidden layer might have an output
that goes off to y
but that output goes back into the next
prediction coming in what this does is
this allows it to handle sequential data
it considers the current input and also
the previously received inputs and if
we're going to look at general drawings
and solutions we should also look at
applications of the rnn image captioning
rnn is used to caption an image by
analyzing the activities present in it a
dog catching a ball in midair that's
very tough i mean you know we have a lot
of stuff that analyzes images of a dog
and the image of a ball but it's able to
add one more feature in there that's
actually catching the ball in midair
time series prediction any time series
problem like predicting the prices of
stocks in a particular month can be
solved using rnn and we'll dive into
that in our use case and actually take a
look at some stock one of the things you
should know about analyzing stock today
is that it is very difficult and if
you're analyzing the whole stock the
stock market at the new york stock
exchange in the u.s produces somewhere
in the neighborhood if you count all the
individual trades in fluctuations by the
second
it's like three terabytes a day of data
so we're gonna look at one stock just
analyzing one stock is really tricky in
here we'll give you a little jump on
that so that's exciting but don't expect
to get rich off of it immediately
another application of the rnn is
natural language processing text mining
and sentiment analysis can be carried
out using rnn for natural language
processing and you can see right here
the term natural language processing
when you stream those three words
together is very different than i if i
said processing language naturally so
the time series is very important when
we're analyzing sentiments it can change
the whole value of a sentence just by
switching the words around or if you're
just counting the words you might get
one sentiment where if you actually look
at the order they're in you get a
completely different sentiment when it
rains look for rainbows when it's dark
look for stars both of these are
positive sentiments and they're based
upon the order of which the sentence is
going in machine translation given an
input in one language rnn can be used to
translate the input into a different
languages as output i myself very
linguistically challenged but if you
study languages and you're good with
languages you know right away that if
you're speaking english you would say
big cat and if you're speaking spanish
you would say cat big so that
translation is really important to get
the right order to get there's all kinds
of parts of speech that are important to
know by the order of the words here this
person is speaking in english and
getting translated and you can see here
a person is speaking in english in this
little diagram i guess that's denoted by
the flags i have a flag i own it no um
but they're speaking in english and it's
getting translated into
chinese italian french german and
spanish languages some of the tools
coming out are just so cool so somebody
like myself who's very linguistically
challenged i can now travel into worlds
i would never think of because i can
have something translate my english back
and forth readily and i'm not stuck with
a communication gap so let's dive into
what is a recurrent neural network
recurrent neural network works on the
principle of saving the output of a
layer and feeding this back to the input
in order to predict the output of the
layer sounds a little confusing when we
start breaking it down i'll make more
sense and usually we have a propagation
forward neural network with the input
layers the hidden layers the output
layer with the recurrent neural network
we turn that on its side so here it is
and now our x comes up from the bottom
into the hidden layers into y and they
usually draw very simplified x to h with
c as a loop a to y where a b and c are
the perimeters a lot of times you'll see
this kind of drawing in here digging
closer and closer into the h and how it
works going from left to right you'll
see that the c goes in and then the x
goes in so the x is going upward bound
and c is going to the right a is going
out and c is also going out that's where
it gets a little confusing so here we
have xn
cn and then we have y out and c out and
c is based on h t minus one so our value
is based on the y and the h value are
connected to each other they're not
necessarily the same value because h can
be its own thing and usually we draw
this or we represent it as a function h
of t equals a function of c where h of t
minus 1 that's the last h output and x
of t going in so it's the last output of
h combined with the new input of x where
h t is the new state fc is a function
with the parameters c that's a common
way of denoting it ht minus one is the
old state coming out and then x of t is
an input vector at time of step t
well we need to cover types of recurrent
neural networks and so the first one is
the most common one which is a
one-to-one single output
one-to-one neural network is usually
known as a vanilla neural network used
for regular machine learning problems
why because vanilla is usually
considered kind of a just a real basic
flavor but because it's very basic a lot
of times they'll call it the vanilla
neural network which is not the common
term but it is like kind of a slang term
people will know what you're talking
about usually if you say that then we
run one to many so you have a single
input and you might have a multiple
outputs in this case uh image captioning
as we looked at earlier where we have
not just looking at it as a dog but a
dog catching a ball in the air and then
you have many to one network takes in a
sequence of inputs examples sentiment
analysis where a given sentence can be
classified as expressing positive or
negative sentiments and we looked at
that as we were discussing if it rains
look for a rainbow so positive sentiment
where rain might be a negative sentiment
if you're just adding up the words in
there and then the course if you're
going to do a one-to-one mini to one one
to many there's many to many networks
takes in a sequence of inputs and
generates a sequence of outputs example
machine translation so we have a lengthy
sentence coming in in english and then
going out in all the different languages
you know just a wonderful tool very
complicated set of computations if
you're a translator you realize just how
difficult it is to translate into
different languages
one of the biggest things you need to
understand when we're working with this
neural network is what's called the
vanishing gradient problem while
training an rnn your slope can be either
too small or very large and this makes
training difficult when the slope is too
small the problem is known as vanishing
gradient and you'll see here they have a
nice
image loss of information through time
so if you're pushing not enough
information forward that information is
lost and then when you go to train it
you start losing the third word in the
sentence or something like that or
doesn't quite follow the full logic of
what you're working on exploding
gradient problem oh this is one that
runs into everybody when you're working
with this particular neural network when
the slope tends to grow exponentially
instead of decaying this problem is
called exploding gradient issues in
gradient problem long training time poor
performance bad accuracy and i'll add
one more in there your computer if
you're on a lower end computer testing
out a model will lock up and give you
the memory error explaining gradient
problem consider the following two
examples to understand what should be
the next word in the sequence the person
who took my bike and blank a thief the
students who got into engineering with
blank from asia and you can see in here
we have our x value going in we have the
previous value going forward and then
you back propagate the error like you do
with any neural network and as we're
looking for that missing word maybe
we'll have the person took my bike and
blank was a thief and the student who
got into engineering with a blank were
from asia consider the following example
the person who took the bike so we'll go
back to the person who took the bike was
blank a thief in order to understand
what would be the next word in the
sequence the rnn must memorize the
previous context whether the subject was
singular noun or a plural noun so was a
thief is singular the student who got
into engineering well in order to
understand what would be the next word
in the sequence the rnn must memorize
the previous context whether the subject
was singular noun or a plural noun and
so you can see here the students who got
into engineering with blank were from
asia it might be sometimes difficult for
the error to back propagate to the
beginning of the sequence to predict
what should be the output so when you
run into the gradient problem we need a
solution the solution to the gradient
problem first we're going to look at
exploding gradient where we have three
different solutions depending on what's
going on one is identity initialization
so the first thing we want to do is see
if we can find a way to minimize the
identities coming in instead of having
it identify everything just the
important information we're looking at
next is to truncate the back propagation
so instead of having
whatever information it's sending to the
next series we can truncate what it's
sending we can lower that particular set
of layers make those smaller and finally
is a gradient clipping so when we're
training it we can clip what that
gradient looks like and narrow the
training model that we're using when you
have a vanishing gradient the option
problem we can take a look at weight
initialization very similar to the
identity but we're going to add more
weights in there so it can identify
different aspects of what's coming in
better choosing the right activation
function that's huge so we might be
activating based on one thing and we
need to limit that we haven't talked too
much about activation functions so we'll
look at that just minimally there's a
lot of choices out there and then
finally there's long short term memory
networks the lstms and we can make
adjustments to that so just like we can
clip the gradient as it comes out we can
also
expand on that we can increase the
memory network the size of it so it
handles more information and one of the
most common problems in today's uh setup
is what they call long term dependencies
suppose we try to predict the last word
in the text the clouds are in the and
you probably said sky here we do not
need any further context it's pretty
clear that the last word is going to be
sky suppose we try to predict the last
word in the text i have been staying in
spain for the last 10 years i can speak
fluent maybe you said portuguese or
french no you probably said spanish the
word we predict will depend on the
previous few words in context here we
need the context of spain to predict the
last word in the text it's possible that
the gap between the relevant information
and the point where it is needed to
become very large
lstms help us solve this problem so the
lstms are a special kind of recurrent
neural network capable of learning
long-term dependencies remembering
information for long periods of time is
their default behavior all recurrent
neural networks have the form of a chain
of repeating modules of neural network
connections in standard rnns this
repeating module will have a very simple
structure such as a single tangent h
layer lstms's
also have a chain like structure but the
repeating module has a different
structure instead of having a single
neural network layer there are four
interacting layers communicating in a
very special way
lstms are a special kind of recurrent
neural network capable of learning
long-term dependencies remembering
information for long periods of time is
their default behavior ls tms's also
have a chain-like structure but the
repeating module has a different
structure instead of having a single
neural network layer there are four
interacting layers communicating in a
very special way as you can see the
deeper we dig into this the more
complicated the graphs get in here i
want you to note that you have x of t
minus one coming in you have x of t
coming in and you've got x a t plus one
and you have h of t minus one and h of t
coming in and h of t plus one going out
and of course uh on the other side is
the output a um in the middle we have
our tangent h but it occurs in two
different places so not only when we're
computing the x of t plus one or we
getting the tangent h from x to t but
we're also getting that value coming in
from the x at t minus one so the short
of it is as you look at these layers not
only does it does the propagate through
the first layer goes into the second
layer back into itself but it's also
going into the third layer so now we're
kind of stacking those up and this can
get very complicated as you grow that in
size it also grows in memory too and in
the amount of resources it takes but
it's a very powerful tool to help us
address the problem of complicated long
sequential information coming in like we
were just looking at in the sentence and
when we're looking at our long short
term memory network uh there's three
steps of processing sensing in the lstms
that we look at the first one is we want
to forget irrelevant parts of the
previous state you know a lot of times
like you know is as in a unless we're
trying to look at whether it's a plural
noun or not they don't really play a
huge part in the language so we want to
get rid of them then selectively update
cell state values so we only want to
update the cell state values that
reflect what we're working on and
finally we want to put only output
certain parts of the cell state so
whatever is coming out we want to limit
what's going out too and let's dig a
little deeper into this let's just see
what this really looks like
so step one decides how much of the past
it should remember first step in the
lstm is to decide which information to
be omitted in from the cell in that
particular time step it is decided by
the sigmoid function it looks at the
previous state h to t minus 1 and the
current input x t and computes the
function so you can see over here we
have a function of t
equals the sigmoid function of the
weight of f the h at t minus one and
then x a t plus of course you have a
bias in there with any very neural
network so we have a bias function so f
of t equals forget gate decides which
information to delete that is not
important from the previous time step
considering an stm is fed with the
following inputs from the previous and
present time step alice is good in
physics john on the other hand is good
in chemistry so previous output john
plays football well he told me yesterday
over the phone that he had served as a
captain of his college football team
that's our current input so as we look
at this the first step is the forget
gate realizes there might be a change in
context after encountering the first
full stop compares with the current
input sentence of x a t so we're looking
at that full stop and then compares it
with the input of the new sentence the
next sentence talks about john so the
information on alice is deleted okay
that's important to know so we have this
input coming in and if we're going to
continue on with john then that's going
to be the primary information we're
looking at the position of the subject
is vacated and is assigned to john and
so in this one we've seen that we've
weeded out a whole bunch of information
and we're only passing information on
john since that's now the new topic so
step two is then to decide how much
should this unit add to the current
state in the second layer there are two
parts one is a sigmoid function and the
other is the tangent h in the sigmoid
function it decides which values to let
through zero or one tangent h function
gives a weightage to the values which
are passed deciding their level of
importance minus one to one and you can
see the two formulators that come up the
i of t equals the sigmoid of the weight
of i h of t minus 1 x of t plus the bias
of i and the c of t equals the tangent
of h of the weight of c of h of t minus
1 x of t plus the bias of c so our i of
t equals the input gate determines which
information to let through based on its
significance in the current time step if
this seems a little complicated don't
worry because a lot of the programming
is already done when we get to the case
study understanding though that this is
part of the program is important when
you're trying to figure out these what
to set your settings at you should also
note when you're looking at this it
should have some semblance to your
forward propagation neural networks
where we have a value assigned to a
weight plus a bias very important steps
than any of the neural network layers
whether we're propagating into them the
information from one to the next or
we're just doing a straightforward
neural network propagation let's take a
quick look at this what it looks like
from the human standpoint as i step out
of my suit again consider the current
input at x of t john plays football well
he told me yesterday over the phone that
he had served as a captain of his
college football team that's our input
input gate analysis the important
information john plays football and he
was a captain of his college team as
important he told me over the phone
yesterday is less important hence it is
forgotten this process of adding some
new information can be done via the
input gate now this example is as a
human form and we'll look at training
this stuff in just a minute but as a
human being if i wanted to get this
information from a conversation maybe
it's a google voice listening in on you
or something like that um how do we weed
out the information that he was talking
to me on the phone yesterday well i
don't want to memorize that he talked to
me on the phone yesterday or maybe that
is important but in this case it's not i
want to know that he was the captain of
the football team i want to know that he
served i want to know that john plays
football and he was a captain of the
college football team those are the two
things that i want to take away as a
human being again we measure a lot of
this from the human viewpoint and that's
also how we try to train them so we can
understand these neural networks finally
we get to step three decides what part
of the current cell state makes it to
the output the third step is to decide
what will be our output first we run a
sigmoid layer which decides what parts
of the cell state make it to the output
then we put the cell state through the
tangent h to push the values to be
between -1 and 1 and multiply it by the
output of the sigmoid gate so when we
talk about the output of t we set that
equal to the sigmoid of the weight of 0
of the h of t minus 1 and back one step
in time by the x of t plus of course the
bias the h of t equals the outer t times
the tangent of the tangent h of c of t
so our o t equals the output gate allows
the passed in information to impact the
output in the current time step let's
consider the example to predicting the
next word in the sentence john played
tremendously well against the opponent
and one for his team for his
contributions brave blank was awarded
player of the match there could be a lot
of choices for the empty space current
input brave is an adjective adjectives
describe a noun john could be the best
output after brave thumbs up for john
awarded player of the match and if you
were to pull just the nouns out of the
sentence team doesn't look right because
that's not really the subject we're
talking about contributions you know
brave contributions or brave team brave
player brave match
so you look at this and you can start to
train this these this neural network so
it starts looking at and goes oh no john
is what we're talking about so brave as
an adjective
john's going to be the best output and
we give john a big thumbs up and then of
course we jump into my favorite part the
case study use case implementation of
lstm let's predict the prices of stocks
using the lstm network based on the
stock price data between 2012 2016.
we're going to try to predict the stock
prices of 2017.
and this will be a narrow set of data
we're not going to do the whole stock
market it turns out that the new york
stock exchange generates roughly three
terabytes of data per day that's all the
different trades up and down of all the
different stocks going on in each
individual one
second to second or nanosecond to
nanosecond but we're going to limit that
to just some very basic fundamental
information so don't think you're going
to get rich off this today but you at
least you can give an eye you can give a
step forward in how to start processing
something like stock prices a very valid
use for machine learning in today's
markets
use case implementation of lstm
let's dive in we're going to import our
libraries we're going to import the
training set and get the scaling going
now if you watch any of our other
tutorials a lot of these pieces just
start to look very familiar because it's
very similar setup let's take a look at
that and just reminder we're going to be
using anaconda the jupiter notebook so
here i have my anaconda navigator when
we go under environments i've actually
set up a cross python
i'm in python36 and uh nice thing about
anaconda especially the newer version i
remember a year ago messing with
anaconda in different versions of python
in different environments anaconda now
has a nice interface
and i have this installed both on a
ubuntu linux machine and on windows so
it works fine on there you can go in
here and open a terminal window and then
in here once you're in the terminal
window this is where you're going to
start
installing using pip to install your
different modules and everything now
we've already pre-installed them so we
don't need to do that in here but if you
don't have them installed in your
particular environment you'll need to do
that and of course you don't need to use
the anaconda or the jupiter you can use
whatever favorite python id you like i'm
just a big fan of this because it keeps
all my stuff separate you can see on
this machine i have specifically
installed one for cross since we're
going to be working with cross under
tensorflow we go back to home i've gone
up here to application and that's the
environment i've loaded on here and then
we'll click on the launch jupiter
notebook now i've already in my jupiter
notebook um have set up a lot of stuff
so that we're ready to go kind of like
uh martha stewart's in the old cooking
show so we want to make sure we have all
our tools for you so you're not waiting
for them to load and if we go up here to
where it says new you can see where you
can
create a new python 3. that's what we
did here underneath the setup so it
already has all the modules installed on
it and i'm actually renamed this if you
go under file you can rename it we've
i'm calling it rnn stock and let's just
take a look and start diving into the
code let's get into the exciting part
now we've looked at the tool and of
course you might be using a different
tool which is fine uh let's start
putting that code in there and seeing
what those imports and uploading
everything looks like now first half is
kind of boring when we hit the run
button because we're going to be
importing numpy as np that's uh the
number python which is your numpy array
and the matplot library because we're
going to do some plotting at the end
and our pandas for our data set our
pandas is pd and when i hit run it
really doesn't do anything except for
load those modules just a quick note let
me just do a quick draw here oops shift
alt there we go you'll notice when we're
doing this setup if i was to divide this
up oops i'm going to actually let's
overlap these here we go
this first part that we're going to do
is
our data
prep
a lot of prepping involved
in fact depending on what your system is
since we're using cross i put an overlap
here uh but you'll find that almost
maybe even half of the code we do is all
about the data prep and the reason i
overlapped this with uh cross let me
just put that down because that's what
we're working in uh is because cross has
like their own preset stuff so it's
already pre-built in which is really
nice so there's a couple steps a lot of
times that are in the karass setup we'll
take a look at that to see what comes up
in our code as we go through and look at
stock and the last part is to evaluate
and if you're working with
shareholders or
classroom whatever it is you're working
with the value 8 is the next biggest
piece
so the actual code here crosses a little
bit more but when you're working with
some of the other packages you might
have like three lines that might be it
all your stuff is in your pre-processing
and your data since cross has is cutting
edge and you load the individual layers
you'll see that there's a few more lines
here and crosses a little bit more
robust and then you spend a lot of times
like i said with the evaluate you want
to have something you present to
everybody else and say hey this is what
i did this is what it looks like so
let's go through those steps this is
like a kind of just general overview and
let's just take a look and see what the
next set of code looks like and in here
we have a data set train and it's going
to be read using the pd or pandas dot
read csv and it's a google stock price
train dot csv and so under this we have
training set equals data set train dot
ilocation and we've kind of sorted out
part of that so what's going on here
let's just take a look at let's look at
the actual file and see what's going on
there now if we look at this
ignore all the extra files on this i
already have a train and a test set
where it's sorted out this is important
to notice because a lot of times we do
that as part of the pre-processing of
the data we take
20 percent of the data out so we can
test it and then we train the rest of it
that's what we use to create our neural
network that way we can find out how
good it is uh but let's go ahead and
just take a look and see what that looks
like as far as the file itself and i
went ahead and just opened this up in a
basic word pad and text editor just so
we can take a look at it certainly you
can open up an excel or any other kind
of spreadsheet
and we note that this is a comma
separated variables we have a date uh
open high low close volume this is the
standard stuff that we import into our
stock or the most basic set of
information you can look at in stock
it's all free to download in this case
we downloaded it from google that's why
we called the google stock price um and
specifically is google this is the
google stock values from as you can see
here we started off at 1 3 2012.
so when we look at this first setup up
here
we have a data set train equals pd
underscore csv and if you noticed on the
original frame
let me just go back there
they had it set to home ubuntu downloads
google stock price train i went ahead
and changed that because we're in the
same file where i'm running the code so
i've saved this particular python code
and i don't need to go through any
special paths or have the full path on
there and then of course we want to take
out
certain values in here and you're going
to notice that we're using
our data set
and we're now in pandas uh so pandas
basically it looks like a spreadsheet um
and in this case we're going to do i
location which is going to get specific
locations the first value is going to
show us that we're pulling all the rows
in the data and the second one is we're
only going to look at columns one and
two and if you remember here from our
data as we switch back on over columns
we saw we start with zero which is the
date and we're going to be looking at
open
and high which would be one and two
we'll just label that right there so you
can see now
when you go back and do this you
certainly can extrapolate and do this on
all the columns but for the example
let's just limit a little bit here so
that we can focus on just some
key aspects of stock
and then we'll go up here and run the
code and again i said the first half is
very boring whenever you hit the run
button it doesn't do anything because
we're still just loading the data and
setting it up
now that we've loaded our data we want
to go ahead and scale it we want to do
what they call feature scaling and in
here we're going to pull it up from the
sk learn or the sk kit pre-processing
import min max scaler and when you look
at this you've got to remember that
biases in our data we want to get rid of
that so if you have something that's
like a really high value let's just draw
a quick graph
and i have something here like the maybe
the stock has a value one stock has a
value of a hundred and another stock has
a value of five
um you start to get a bias between
different stocks and so when we do this
we go ahead and say okay 100 is going to
be the max
and 5 is going to be the min
and then everything else goes and then
we change this so we just squish it down
i like the word squoosh so it's between
one and zero so 100 equals one or one
equals a hundred and zero equals five
and you can just multiply it's usually
just a simple multiplication we're using
uh multiplication
so it's going to be uh minus 5 and then
100 divided or 95 divided by 1. so or
whatever value is is divided by 95.
and uh once we've actually created our
scale we're telling is going to be from
zero to one we want to take our training
set and we're going to create a training
set scaled and we're going to use our
scalar sc we're going to fit we're going
to fit and transform the training set uh
so we can now use the sc this this
particular object we'll use it later on
our testing set because remember we have
to also scale that when we go to test
our model and see how it works and we'll
go ahead and click on the run again it's
not going to have any output yet because
we're just setting up all the variables
okay so we pasted the data in here and
we're going to create the data structure
with the 60 time steps and output
first note we're running 60 time steps
and that is where this value here also
comes in so the first thing we do is we
create our x train and y train variables
and we set them to an empty python array
very important to remember what kind of
array we're in what we're working with
and then we're going to come in here
we're going to go for i in range 60 to
1258 there's our 60 60 time steps and
the reason we want to do this is as
we're adding the data in there's nothing
below the 60. so if we're going to use
60 time steps we have to start at point
60 because it includes everything
underneath of it otherwise you'll get a
pointer error and then we're going to
take our x train and we're going to
append training set scaled this is a
scaled value between 0 and 1. and then
as i is equal to 60 this value is going
to be
60 minus 60 is 0. so this actually is
0 to i so it's going to be 0 60 1 to 61.
let me just circle this part right here
1 to 61 2 to 62 and so on and so on and
if you remember i said 0 to 60 that's
incorrect because it does not count
remember it starts at 0 so this is a
count of 60. so it's actually 59.
important to remember that as we're
looking at this and then the second part
of this that we're looking at so if you
remember correctly here we go we go from
0 to 59 of i and then we have a comma a
0 right here and so finally we're just
going to look at the open value now i
know we did put it in there for 1 to two
if you remember quickly it doesn't count
the second one so it's just the open
value we're looking at just open
and then finally we have y train dot
append training set i to zero and if you
remember correctly i two or i comma zero
if you remember correctly this is zero
to 59 so there's 60 values in it uh so
we do i down here this is number 60. so
we're going to do this is we're creating
an array and we have 0
to 59
and over here we have number 60 which is
going into the y train it's being
appended on there and then this just
goes all the way up so this is down here
is a
0 to 59 and we'll call it 60 since
that's the value over here and it goes
all the way up to 12
58 that's where this value here comes in
that's the length of the data we're
loading
so we've loaded two arrays we've loaded
one array that has uh which is filled
with arrays from 0 to 59 and we loaded
one array which is just the value and
what we're looking at you want to think
about this as a time sequence
here's my open open open open open open
what's the next one in the series so
we're looking at the google stock and
each time it opens we want to know what
the next one 0 through 59 what's 60 1
through 60 what's 61 2 through 62 what's
62 and so on and so on going up and then
once we've loaded those in our for loop
we go ahead and take x train and y train
equals
np.arrayxtrain.npraytrain we're just
converting this back into a numpy array
that way we can use all the cool tools
that we get with numpy array including
reshaping so if we take a look and see
what's going on here we're going to take
our x train
we're going to reshape it
wow what the heck does reshape mean uh
that means we have an array if you
remember correctly
so many numbers by 60.
that's how wide it is
and so we're when you when you do x
train dot shape that gets one of the
shapes and you get
x train dot shape of one gets the other
shape and we're just making sure the
data is formatted correctly and so you
use this to pull the fact that it's 60
by um
in this case where's that value
16 pi
1199 1258 minus 60 11.99 and we're
making sure that that is shaped
correctly so the data is grouped into
11 99 by 60 different arrays and then
the one on the end just means at the end
because this when you're dealing with
shapes and numpy they look at this as
layers and so the end layer needs to be
one value that's like the leaf of a tree
where this is the branch and then it
branches out some more
and then you get the leaf np dot reshape
comes from and using the existing shapes
to form it we'll go ahead and run this
piece of code again there's no real
output and then we'll import our
different cross modules that we need so
from cross models we're going to import
the sequential model dealing with
sequential data we have our dense layers
we have actually three layers we're
going to bring in our dents our lstm
which is what we're focusing on and our
dropout and we'll discuss these three
layers more in just a moment but you do
need the with the lstm you do need the
dropout and then the final layer will be
the dents but let's go ahead and run
this and they'll bring port our modules
and you'll see we get an error on here
and if you read it closer it's not
actually an error it's a warning what
does this warning mean these things come
up all the time when you're working with
such cutting edge modules are completely
being updated all the time we're not
going to worry too much about the
warning all it's saying is that the
h5py module which is part of cross is
going to be updated at some point and if
you're running new stuff on cross and
you start updating your cross system you
better make sure that your h5 pi is
updated too otherwise you're going to
have an error later on and you can
actually just run an update on the h5 pi
now if you wanted to not a big deal
we're not going to worry about that
today and i said we were going to jump
in and start looking at what those
layers mean i meant that and we're going
to start off with initializing the rnn
and then we'll start adding those layers
in and you'll see that we have the lstm
and then the dropout lstm then dropout
lstm then dropout what the heck is that
doing so let's explore that we'll start
by initializing the rnn regressor equals
sequential because we're using the
sequential model and we'll run that and
load that up and then we're going to
start adding our lstm layer and some
dropout regularization and right there
should be the q dropout regularization
and if we go back here and remember our
exploding gradient well that's what
we're talking about the dropout drops
out unnecessary data so we're not just
shifting huge amounts of data through
the network so and so we go in here
let's just go ahead and add this in i'll
go ahead and run this and we had three
of them so let me go ahead and put all
three of them in and then we can go back
over them there's the second one and
let's put one more in let's put that in
and we'll go ahead and put two more in i
mean i said one more in but it's
actually two more in and then let's add
one more after that and as you can see
each time i run these they don't
actually have an output so let's take a
closer look and see what's going on here
so we're going to add our first lstm
layer in here we're going to have units
50. the units is the positive integer
and it's the dimensionality of the
output space this is what's going out
into the next layer so we might have 60
coming in but we have 50 going out we
have a return sequence because it is a
sequence data so we want to keep that
true and then you have to tell it what
shape it's in well we already know the
shape by just going in here and looking
at x train shape so input shape equals
the x train shape of one comma one it
makes it real easy you don't have to
remember all the numbers that put in 60
or whatever else is in there you just
let it tell the regressor what model to
use and so we follow our stm with a
dropout layer now understanding the
dropout layer is kind of exciting
because one of the things that happens
is we can over train our network that
means that our neural network will
memorize such specific data that it has
trouble predicting anything that's not
in that specific realm to fix for that
each time we run through the training
mode we're gonna take point two or
twenty percent of our neurons and just
turn them off so we're only going to
train on the other ones and it's gonna
be random that way each time we pass
through this we don't over train these
nodes come back in in the next training
cycle we randomly pick a different 20.
and finally they see a big difference as
we go from the first to the second and
third and fourth the first thing is we
don't have to input the shape because
the shapes already the output units is
50 here this item the next step
automatically knows this layer is
putting out 50 and because it's the next
layer it automatically sets that and
says so 50 is coming out from our last
layer that's coming up you know goes
into the regressor and of course we have
our dropout and that's what's coming
into this one and so on and so on and so
the next three layers we don't have to
let it know what the shape is it
automatically understands that and we're
going to keep the units the same we're
still going to do 50 units it's still a
sequence coming through 50 units and a
sequence now the next piece of code is
what brings it all together let's go
ahead and take a look at that and we
come in here we put the output layer the
dense layer and if you remember up here
we had the three layers we had lstm
dropout and dense dense just says we're
going to bring this all down into one
output instead of putting out a sequence
we just know i want to know the answer
at this point and let's go ahead and run
that and so in here you notice all we're
doing is setting things up one step at a
time so far we've brought in our way up
here we brought in our data we brought
in our different modules we formatted
the data for training it we set it up
you know we have our y x train and our y
train we have our source of data and the
answers where we know so far that we're
going to put in there we've reshaped
that we've come in and built our cross
we've imported our different layers and
we have in here if you look we have what
five total layers now cross is a little
different than a lot of other systems
because a lot of other systems put this
all in one line and do it automatic but
they don't give you the options of how
those layers interface and they don't
give you the options of how the data
comes in cross is cutting edge for this
reason so even though it's a lot of
extra steps in building the model this
has a huge impact on the output and what
we can do with this these new models
from cross so we brought in our dense we
have our full model put together a
regressor so we need to go ahead and
compile it and then we're going to go
ahead and fit the data we're going to
compile the pieces so they all come
together and then we're going to run our
training data on there and actually
recreate our regressor so it's ready to
be used so let's go ahead and compile
that and i can go ahead and run that and
if you've been looking at any of our
other tutorials on neural networks
you'll see we're going to use the
optimizer atom atom is optimized for big
data there's a couple other optimizers
out there beyond the scope of this
tutorial but certainly atom will work
pretty good for this and loss equals
mean squared value so when we're
training it this is what we want to base
the loss on how bad is our error we're
going to use the mean squared value for
our error and the atom optimizer for its
differential equations you don't have to
know the math behind them but certainly
it helps to know what they're doing and
where they fit into the bigger models
and then finally we're going to do our
fit fitting the rnn to the training set
we have the regressor.fit x train y
train epics and batch size so we know
where this is this is our data coming in
for the x train our y train is the
answer we're looking for of our data our
sequential input epics is how many times
we're going to go over the whole data
set we created a whole data set of x
trains so this is each each of those
rows which includes a time sequence of
60. and bad size another one of those
things where cross really shines is if
you were pulling this save from a large
file instead of trying to load it all
into ram it can now pick smaller batches
up and load those indirectly we're not
worried about pulling them off a file
today because this isn't big enough to
cause a computer too much of a problem
to run not too straining on the
resources but as we run this you can
imagine what happened if i was doing a
lot more than just one column in one set
of stock in this case google stock
imagine if i was doing this across all
the stocks and i had instead of just the
open i had open close high low and you
can actually find yourself with about 13
different variables times 60 because
there's a time sequence suddenly you
find yourself with a gig of memory
you're loading into your ram which will
just completely you know if it's just if
you're not on multiple computers or
cluster you're gonna start running into
resource problems but for this we don't
have to worry about that so let's go
ahead and run this and this will
actually take a little bit on my
computer it's an older laptop and give a
second to kick in there there we go all
right so we have epic so this is going
to tell me it's running the first run
through all the data and as it's going
through it's batching them in 32 pieces
so 32 lines each time and there's 1198 i
think i said 11.99 earlier but it's 1198
i was off by one but each one of these
is 13 seconds so you can imagine this is
roughly 20 to 30 minutes run time on
this computer like i said it's an older
laptop running at 0.9 gigahertz on a
dual processor and that's fine what
we'll do is i'll go ahead and stop go
get a drink of coffee and come back and
let's see what happens at the end and
where this takes us and like any good
cooking show
i've kind of gotten my latte i also have
some other stuff running in the
background so you'll see these numbers
jumped up to like 19 seconds 15 seconds
but you can scroll through and you can
see we've run it through a hundred steps
or 100 epics so the question is what
does all this mean one of the first
things you'll notice is that our loss
can is over here it kind of stopped at
0.0014 but you can see it kind of goes
down until we hit about 0.014 three
times in a row so we guessed our epic
pretty close since our losses remain the
same on there so to find out what we're
looking at we're going to go ahead and
load up our test data the test data that
we didn't process yet and a real stock
price data set test eye location this is
the same thing we did when we prep the
data in the first place so let's go
ahead and go through this code and we
can see we've labeled it part three
making the predictions and visualizing
the results so the first thing that we
need to do is go ahead and read the data
in from our test csv you see i've
changed the path on it for my computer
and then we'll call it the real stock
price and again we're doing just the one
column here and the values from
ilocation so it's all the rows and just
the values from these that one location
that's the open stock open let's go
ahead and run that so that's loaded in
there and then let's go ahead and create
we have our inputs we're going to create
inputs here and this should all look
familiar because this is the same thing
we did before we're going to take our
data set total we're going to do a
little panda concat from the data state
train now remember the end of the data
set train is part of the data going in
let's just visualize that just a little
bit here's our train data let me just
put tr for train and it went up to this
value here but each one of these values
generated a bunch of columns it was 60
across and this value here equals this
one and this value here equals this one
and this value here equals this one and
so we need these top 60 to go into our
new data so to find out we're looking at
we're going to go ahead and load up our
test data the test data that we didn't
process yet and a real stock price data
set test eye location this is the same
thing we did when we prepped the data in
the first place so let's go ahead and go
through this code and we can see we've
labeled it part three making the
predictions and visualizing the results
so the first thing we need to do is go
ahead and read the data in from our test
csv you see i've changed the path on it
for my computer and then we'll call it
the real stock price and again we're
doing just the one column here and the
values from i location so it's all the
rows and just the values from these that
one location that's the open stock open
let's go ahead and run that so that's
loaded in there and then let's go ahead
and create we have our inputs we're
going to create inputs here and this
should all look familiar because this is
the same thing we did before we're going
to take our data set total we're going
to do a little panda concat from the
datastate train now remember the end of
the data set train is part of the data
going in let's just visualize that just
a little bit here's our train data let
me just put tr for train and it went up
to this value here but each one of these
values generated a bunch of columns it
was 60 across and this value here equals
this one and this value here equals this
one and this value here equals this one
and so we need these top 60 to go into
our new data because that's part of the
next data or it's actually the top 59.
so that's what this first setup is over
here is we're going in we're doing the
real stock price and we're going to just
take the data set test and we're going
to load that in and then the real stock
price is our data test test location so
we're just looking at that first column
the open price and then our data set
total we're going to take pandas and
we're going to concat and we're going to
take our data set train for the open and
our dataset test open and this is one
way you can reference these columns
we've referenced them a couple different
ways we've referenced them up here with
the one two but we know it's labeled as
a panda set as open so pandas is great
that way lots of versatility there and
we'll go ahead and go back up here and
run this there we go and uh you'll
notice this is the same as what we did
before we have our open data set where
pended our two different or concatenated
our two data sets together we have our
inputs equals data set total length data
set total minus length data set minus
test minus 60 values so we're going to
run this over all of them and you'll see
why this works because normally when
you're running your test set versus your
training set you run them completely
separate but when we graph this you'll
see that we're just going to be we'll be
looking at the part that we didn't train
it with to see how well it graphs and we
have our inputs equals inputs dot
reshapes or reshaping like we did before
we're transforming our inputs so if you
remember from the transform between zero
and one and uh finally we want to go
ahead and take our x test and we're
going to create that x test and for i in
range 60 to 80. so here's our x test and
we're appending our inputs i to 60 which
remember is 0 to 59 and i comma 0 on the
other side so it's just the first column
which is our open column and once again
we take our x test we convert it to a
numpy array we do the same reshape we
did before and then we get down to the
final two lines and here we have
something new right here on these last
two lines let me just highlight those or
or mark them predicted stock price
equals regressor dot predicts x test so
we're predicting all the stock including
both the training and the testing model
here and then we want to take this
prediction and we want to inverse the
transform so remember we put them
between zero and one well that's not
going to mean very much to me to look at
a float number between zero and one i
want the dollar amount so i want to know
what the cash value is and we'll go
ahead and run this and you'll see it
runs much quicker than the training
that's what's so wonderful about these
neural networks once you put them
together it takes just a second to run
the same neural network that took us
what a half hour to train add and plot
the data we're going to plot what we
think it's going to be and we're going
to plot it against the real data what
the google stock actually did so let's
go ahead and take a look at that in code
and let's uh pull this code up so we
have our plt that's our oh if you
remember from the very beginning let me
just go back up to the top we have our
matplotlibrary.pi plot as plt that's
where that comes in and we come down
here we're going to plot let me get my
drawing thing out again we're going to
go ahead and plt is basically kind of
like an object it's one of the things
that always through me when i'm doing
graphs in python because i always think
you have to create an object and then it
loads that class in there well in this
case plt is like a canvas you're putting
stuff on so if you've done html5 you'll
have the canvas object this is the
canvas so we're going to plot the real
stock price that's what it actually is
and we're going to give that color red
so it's going to be in bright red we're
going to label it real google stock
price and then we're going to do our
predicted stock and we're going to do it
in blue and it's going to be labeled
predicted and we'll give it a title it's
always nice to give a title to your
graph especially if you're going to
present this to somebody you know to
your shareholders in the office and the
x label is going to be time because it's
a time series and we didn't actually put
the actual date and times on here but
that's fine we just know they're
incremented by time and then of course
the y label is the actual stock price
plt.legend tells us to build the legend
on here so that the color red and real
google stock price show up on there and
then the plot shows us that actual graph
so let's go ahead and run this and see
what that looks like and you can see
here we have a nice graph and let's talk
just a little bit about this graph
before we wrap it up here's our legend i
was telling you about that's why we have
the legend to show the prices we have
our title and everything and you'll
notice on the bottom we have a time
sequence we didn't put the actual time
in here now we could have we could have
gone ahead and plotted the x since we
know what the dates are and plotted this
to dates but we also know that it's only
the last piece of data that we're
looking at so last piece of data which
in somewhere probably around here on the
graph i think it's like about 20 percent
of the data probably less than that we
have the google price and the google
price has this little up jump and then
down and you'll see that the actual
google instead of uh a turn down here
just didn't go up as high and didn't
load go down so our prediction has the
same pattern but the overall value is
pretty far off as far as um stock but
then again we're only looking at one
column we're only looking at the open
price we're not looking at how many
volumes were traded like i was pointing
out earlier we talk about stock just
right off the bat there's six columns
there's open high low close volume then
there's weather i mean volume shares
then there's the adjusted open adjusted
high adjusted low adjusted clothes they
have a special formula to predict
exactly what it would really be worth
based on the value of the stock and then
from there there's all kinds of other
stuff you can put in here so we're only
looking at one small aspect the opening
price of the stock and as you can see
here we did a pretty good job this curve
follows the curve pretty well it has
like a little jumps on it bins they
don't quite match up so this bin here
does not quite match up with that bin
there but it's pretty darn close we have
the basic shape of it and the prediction
isn't too far off and you can imagine
that as we add more data in and look at
different aspects in the specific domain
of stock we should be able to get a
better representation each time we drill
in deeper of course this took a half
hour for my program my computer to train
so you can imagine that if i was running
it across all those different variables
it might take a little bit longer to
train the data not so good for doing a
quick tutorial like this and that brings
us to the end of this live session on ai
and machine learning full course
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning to be future ready don't
forget to subscribe to stay tuned for
more from simply learn
you